[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
yeah
it
[Music]
a
it
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
d
yeah
[Music]
he
you've seen the speed Chess Championship
ship now it's time for the rest of us to
get a turn with no Grand Masters allowed
it's the I'm not a GM speed Chess
Championship watch your favorite chess
personalities duke it out in chess.com
exciting speed chess
format there will be brilliancies GL
stacking another P Bishop C3 and Rook a
one oh Rook a one there will be blunders
no no he fell for it 16 players are
fighting for a chance at the eight
player knockout see old rivalries this
is how long new
foes with a $155,000 prize pool who will
take home the crown this year and that
is the match the imcc starts right
[Music]
now welcome to the I'm not a GM speed
Chess Championship I'm Robert H
alongside me none other than my good
friend James KY III James you're someone
with a lot of familiarity with this
tournament a finalist a year ago thanks
for joining me in the chairing did you
decide to give everybody else a chance I
did I had to give everybody a chance or
they just would have been mad at
hess.com I mean chess.com I'm here with
my man's Robert and the chat we're
having a great day and it's another
great event and I do really like this
event a lot as I made it to the finals
with Eric Rosen the soft broken but
he'll Crush you anytime any day Eric
Rosen it was nice and now we have
another event imcc I'm good to be I'm
happy to be here how are you Robert
what's up dog hey a lots up I'm happy
that you're with me and I think that we
should take this moment to explain to
everybody what the imcc is they just saw
Hikaru and Magnus in the speed chest
Championship well this is for
international Masters and other content
creators as they take part in a speed
format it's your favorite personalities
young Stars they are C they're on a
collision course for that title there
will be a new IM champion $155,000 at
stake but James you know they care about
the money but they care much more about
the bragging rights look at these 16
competitors Chad oh my goodness okay now
this is on you chat we're putting it on
you who are you rooting for look at the
groups here you got Greg shahadi and
group a you have a lot of others
obviously you have Levy Rosman and Nemo
in group two you got Paulina Sha you got
Danny wrench Lawrence Trent over there
and cost kavousi of the chess Dojo live
wow who are you going for chat that's
crazy there you got any picks for you
Robert what you thinking there are too
many people to choose from look at all
of these Stars we have chess explain we
got the big Greek over there in group C
along with Chief chess officer in that
madeup title like you said Danny wrench
but we are going to start today in group
a we see those four players there they
are four worthy competitors because
James when you have a field like this
with players who are quite evenly
matched at least on paper it's going to
be a fun event but let's remind
everybody of the new format because they
may be used to in the speed chest
Championship where it's 16 players and
an elimination bracket we're doing four
groups of four players this time around
kind of like the FIFA World Cup or round
robin going on but unlike that World Cup
only the group winner advances the other
three are eliminated we say goodbye to
them so Jay I like it because you get to
play every single person
in your group I'm not going to lie look
I I actually chose just not to play this
year because I you know I made I beat
three IMs I made it to the finals I
proved a lot so I was like okay cool you
know I I'll sit out this year but I was
like oh this is the format I'm glad I
sat out this year this is much harder
than locking in with one guy you're
going to have to fight three different
matches and it's only six games really
two four and six there to three
different formats obviously first to
three and a half wins so that's really
important here it makes it actually a
little bit more hard and you're going to
have to start off really really strong
in these events it's a good point
because in the long SEC formats you may
lose the first three games we saw Hikaru
do something like that against Maxim
Vash lra but here if you lose three
games you just allow one more draw you
already lose the mess that's it so we
are going to see some hotly contested
matches you can't get out to a rough
start but the good news is if you're
trailing on the leaderboard you can take
down inir competition another player but
James we're going to start with these
two matchups four players in group a
it's going to be a fun day with these
four we're starting with none other than
the proess league commissioner Greg
Jihadi taking on D cheriff the head of
Polish content for chess.com and then
the other matchup we have two of the
biggest female stars on the planet in
Mary arabid and elen robers who's one of
the most talented Juniors out there the
Dutch Women's Champion a star in her own
right so James no matter where you look
we've got some fun ahead of us yeah this
is really strong obviously here I mean I
can't wait to see it's a different group
it's a different matchup it's like o all
these emotions here Greg is going to be
playing and of course Greg is a veteran
out here been playing chess a long time
here and he's also the commissioner you
know you see us chess school all this
stuff he's around great chess then you
got DED who just hit International
Masters so he's fresh he's hungry he
wants to prove himself here big event
for him then you got the all Lady class
those are very very very strong ladies I
have actually played Mary personally
online and I was like yeah this is not
any easy battle it was back and forth
games she's really strong right and alen
being a young 17 I mean the top top I
think uh um in in the country for for
for Dutch or something like that so I
mean she just has a lot of accolades and
it's good to see her play she's going to
be hungry too as well so that's a
heavyweight match up two of them today
so I'm excited it's going to be good
it's going to be really good it's going
to be fantastic and you said the word
heavyweight here's a man who lifts some
heavy weights that's none other than
Greg shahadi you know he likes to hit
the gym do that CrossFit but he's also a
great chess player people forget about
that because they're so focused on him
being the commissioner of the PCL the
proess league your favorite team event
online he won the US junr Open way back
in 1996 way to H him chess.com we didn't
put these Graphics together you did but
1996 with the year he won the US Junior
open his best accomplishment of all he's
the brother of Jennifer Shah we all love
Jen she's such a great ambassador of the
game
but James I think we should highlight
this point most of all it's his fourth
IM appearance he's made the semis twice
but last year he lost in the very first
round to Lawrence Trent and I I actually
redeemed him of course cuz I had
Lawrence Trent in my uh third round
right before I played Eric Rosen I was
able to take down Trent he talks a lot
of trash and he can back it up here and
Greg is ready to now bring it back and
obviously uh winning this match this is
a new format for him and I think in his
shorter time controls or the shorter
matches like only get two games yeah
definitely Greg has has some favorites
there being a veteran not this is not
his first time playing this so he could
have you know a trick or two up sleep
and another thing that might favor Greg
over some of the others is that he's
retired as an over theboard player he
does not whip out the chess set and play
classical games but somebody who does
and with great success these days is
international Master Mary arabid because
not only is she great in online in title
Tuesdays she's a 2023 Eur European
women's chess champion that is not an
easy title to win she also is great in
team formats with 2015 women's world
team Chess Championship and a three-time
youth champion in the under 10 the Under
12 and under 18 so no matter how old she
is she seems to rack up those successes
those titles and James today she will
try to make it through group a where
it's going to be tough
sedding yeah she's she is very strong
very strong strong strong as you know
look at that determined serious on the
face did she not playing around no
Smiles like that's dangerous very very
dangerous player here today Robert I
don't want to be playing her anytime
today um so she's very strong obviously
and it's going to be some good chest so
let's see what happens you yeah she is
super strong as is her opponent in the
first match and this is Mary arabid
she's taking on alen robers and alen is
a fan favorite she played in vikin Z she
had some upset victories and so alen is
a name that you should have circled when
you look at the top player rankings you
should look at a lean but Mary's saying
I don't care how young you are I don't
care how promising you are I am strong
myself as you said James so there's no
fear from anybody in this competition
including the lowest rate on paper is
DED Sheriff but he's the head of Polish
content for chess.com he's locked in he
knows how to create some content and
some brilliancies look at him got the
shirt on he look like you know like some
type of magnet swag there with just the
endorsements on on the shirt here I'm
ready to go hair is all nice right the
background okay magnus's background be
all like you know clothes everywhere and
stuff but at the same time here he's
ready to go lock in look at that focus
focus Jedi Focus says theed yeah he's
ready to go and we're going to see how
he's going to you know match up against
his first match up which is Greg who's
again a season veteran this is going to
be heated and the games are about to
begin we see these two match ups Greg on
the bottom left hand side of your screen
taking on DED and then the right hand
side we have elen robers and Mer Mary
arabid so we see that the match is off
between well not both Greg decided to
finally move so James I love the two
board scene here very different openings
from the players yeah see a dust there
you know it's funny actually as I'm
finishing my Chester course my joa
London I'm actually doing some Dutch
work right now and so far so good from
white or working on the Dutch chapter
and so far so good from white I mean she
chose a Dutch I was not expecting that
but of course I guess she is Dutch right
so
haha you know what I mean I guess jokes
on me right so yeah that's funny and
then we have the Sicilian here is that a
fresh nikov with a G3 oh yeah that's
like line yeah that's like kind of
bookish so so far so good just following
Mainline stuff nothing crazy yet yeah
they're playing that topical theory on
both boards why don't we first go to
Greg against DED of course we will be
equally focused on these matchups but if
we dive into to our board on the left
hand side where Greg shahadi he wants to
get back to the semi-finals we know he's
a two-time semi-finalist in the IMC has
not been able to go further than that
he's playing a pretty classical setup
here James where we have this Knight on
D5 that's always a good piece and this
Pawn on D6 that is a backwards pawn and
that's usually Black's weak point in
this opening
line yeah absolutely it it's a pawn that
you know of course even though D6 is
weak you see this in the night off
structures one thing that I've noticed
actually studying these structures is
they say that hey you can't have both
meaning you can't attack the D6 pawn and
also have the D5 Square so if you want
to play Knight D5 well then you actually
block of course the D6 Pawn so I can
play around the pawn if you try to bully
the pawn at some point well I can defend
the pawn which it looks like Greg's
going to choose that route and I think
that is more of the flexible route
keeping Knight D5 options still open and
also of course we can't attack yet the
weak D6
Pawn Yeah it's a very interesting
position where both sides have their
struggles a D6 is a weakness but black
is ready to pry open this a file and use
that Rook develop it from its starting
square and you see the he's pausing
right here because the tension that's
always a big question in chess James
when do you release the tension I would
not take on B3 just yet 100% right keep
the tension is what the grand Masters
say and of course uh Robert has just
said that so of course you keep the
tension here 100% we will keep the
tension but I think the annoying part is
about what is the plan you have to
usually play F5 which I like this G3
Bishop G2 move um well now it really
turn the F5 push so maybe I have to move
the Rook but I mean where do I move the
rook and then I want to keep it on the a
file so he goes Queen C7 maybe with some
Rook d8 options there just not a fan of
Black's position I used to like these
positions from black being in the
chesnik off I guess we do have the D4
square but it just felt a little bit too
you know maneuver is to be a sicilian
for me and I was not a biggest fan of
this Sicilians usually you have
aggressiveness you're you know you don't
feel any type of that no aggression here
no anything I feel why is just has the
space and it's easier orace uh feels
better to play as white here than black
I'm with you although I like what D is
doing because he's playing quickly he
defended his Pawn he can't take on B3 at
some moment but there's no increase of
pressure for him unless this Knight gets
into D4 so your point is very well taken
James that Knight D5 is not a move that
white ever plays lightly because that
locks up the position so instead Greg
decides to build in the center Rook D2
Rook D1 if you ever swap on B3 that's
fine the queen defends that pawn over
there this Knight can actually slide
back to C2 at the right moment to go
after the B4 Pawn so I think that black
does have a lot of things to figure out
and it's all about control of the dark
squares maybe a queen C5 a knight C6
things of that nature absolutely Queen
C5 Knight C6 and the pawn structure of
course is like the the tell you the
plans of The Game and his this Pawn
structure obviously with the pawn on D6
is saying I have to play D5 at some
point but we have this moroy buying type
structure from Greg here on pawns on e4
and C4 which really makes it really uh
annoying for the the black pieces to try
to get anything going besides getting
the breaks F5 or D5 in hence you will
see things like G6 and F5 from black at
some point but usually that's when you
still have a dark Square Bishop so you
don't have that Bishop here you could
create some weaknesses around a king and
and at some point we're going to have to
either wait and or play for G6 F5 or
white just you know can play for two
results in a way just maneuver move
pieces around slow move here slow move
there and try to wait for you to crack
cuz black does have just more weaknesses
than white does it's true and the one
active idea with Knight to D4 is always
met by Knight C2 swapping those Knights
off that should be a decent play for
white but it's this position it's
positional let's go back to our bird's
eye view because there's a lot more
action taking place in our other matchup
between alen robers and Mary arabid so
while this one they'll be jockeying uh
for some setups maneuvering around
trading off some pieces the other one
looks adventurous and very aggressive on
the right hand side of our screen 100%
of course the Dutch is a very risky
opening but it also can be very strong
um I mean it depend on it depends on the
positions here castles was a missed win
somewhere in there Robert it must have
been maybe B5 you know my grandfather to
says you have to sacrifice first and
think later so I think B5 was probably
it oh here we go yeah because
grandfather to just take it Robert do we
just take it or not I would definitely
go about taking that pawn uh sacrificing
on the right hand side of the screen
James is looking at that A6 square and
now as we look in there James all eyes
all arrows towards that A6 B7 side of
the board you know that Mary she wants
to sacrifice and deliver a Checkmate in
the near future oh 100% Bishop Tes A6 is
coming there this is ugly look at all
the pieces how many pieces do you start
with class raise your hand right with
the black on the black side here okay
you got your pieces there and 1 2 3 4
five six pieces are like basically all
on the back rank there for the black
pieces that's really bad that's really
bad Robert we don't have any development
I'm castled I got my pieces out I'm
aiming at white I mean I can move my
Rook back to B1 and F1 for two moves
just to be ridiculous and then you know
do something on the queen side just to
tell you how authoritative um this game
is for the white pieces I'm with you you
can just deliberate and you don't have
to press through right away and that's
why I like Mary's last move Queen back
to E2 she didn't sacrifice just yet
she's waiting for the right time because
that Knight on C5 that's not a knight
that's a stallion and if you take that
Knight the B Pawn takes back opening up
the line in front of the black King so
that would be devastating I don't
actually see an idea for alen usually
you have to just like open up the king
side but you're so far away from doing
that if this was a longer match I would
have an idea here Robert I would just
probably hit the button AKA hit the
resign button try again you know what I
mean let's try another game and then
we'll go for another but you can't risk
any of that here because you have I mean
three and a half games three and a half
points wins the match so if you want to
win here you're going to have to fight
have to use everything that you can here
but man this is just hard for black
black right now we don't have anything
if we could get G5 G4 in then maybe we
can create some problems but we have and
there it is Bishop takes A6 he didn't
even think for like the 10 seconds there
brilliant move it's on the board Robert
Bishop
A6 right it seems natural because you're
breaking open the king but sometimes you
go for a sacrifice and it does not work
out but as you said Mikel tall always
went for those sacrifices and Mary Arab
she's such a great player won the
European Women's Championship and right
now she's looking ready to win game one
here James I don't see an idea Queen B7
is mate and you stop it for now but C6
is falling you can play B5 to pry openen
the B file as well I just feel like this
should be over in a few moves but hey
maybe alen will be able to fight on
especially if she can trade Queens this
is very ferocious I mean ferocious
attack here now you can't put anything
on C7 Knight A6 hit the button
immediately right so this is going to be
really really scary here you got B5 B6
coming this is a master class here and
it's okay sometimes the Dutch can go
absolutely 100% wrong and that's what
happened in this game but sometimes it
can go really really right when you see
the ly Gro Dutchess from of course
obviously car Nakamura me even see in
the database uh who was another one um
Alexander kusia chess Queen very strong
of course aggressive plays the Dutch
with some success I've seen so it's a it
depends sometimes you get you a good
Dutch and sometimes you get a really bad
one and this one did not work out at all
for yeah I think we know what kind of
Dutch this ended up being here comes a
rook to B1 with check the black king has
only one square there goes and in comes
the night all of White's pieces playing
aart and there's a discovered check I
don't know oh my gosh it's made on B7
next my goodness yeah yeah got get that
off the screen man we got under rage
watching this Robert we got to get that
off the screen to
to to that was a fantastic game from
Mary arabid just an obliteration and now
lean going to an offbeat opening she's
known for playing in this kind of cagy
way not trying to go down deep
theoretical territory it didn't work out
well for her in the first game now we
have a scotch like setup for white where
she controls the center but as we go
back to our a bird's eyee view Greg
shahadi he only has half his face on the
screen but he's going to have to keep
his eyes in both directions here because
that black queen sliding over to the
left hand side of the board aiming
towards some of White's vulnerable pawns
I think at best Greg is going to make a
draw here how is he perfectly half of
the screen too like like it's so funny
how you did how you said that but he's
like literally half of the screen right
now and he's finding some moves though
C5 is really strong but B3 is hanging
there's a head shake from D there and
it's 17 seconds so look at the clock
that does matter as well
Robert well look at this all of a sudden
D's King is in big trouble so Greg was
able to trade pawns it's even material
but it's not an even position because
the black king is stuck and Bishop B5 is
coming with a check mining attack so
it's not just half his face he became
Cyclops he only needs that one eye he
just lifts those of that those goggles
off and Bam it is lasers and he is about
to Checkmate the black king on E8 wow
you know it's going to be scary what if
he had his whole head on the screen like
what would what would that look like
that's only half his head here wow
that's crazy here as he's taking up the
pawns check check uh wait and the Eva
bar dropped all the way down there but
now we get it back where is the win here
I mean maybe just trade check and push
maybe very possible don't have any time
got to move oh my gosh and because Greg
doesn't have time the advantage go away
and suddenly white is up a PA on the
left hand side of our screen and we
brought the board up for you that even
though White's up material the advantage
isn't there and it's likely because the
B Pawn is not any worse than the C Pawn
I like to say it's not about the pawn
quantity it's about the quality and the
C Pawn is closer to the black king which
means it's hard to promote the B Pawn on
the other hand that's much harder to
stop for white absolutely this is uh
yeah this B Pawn is the is the problem
here I think they both are going to end
up maybe he takes a draw but yeah's he's
going to take a draw take a draw there
makes it makes a lot of sense he's like
yeah I'll take a draw okay okay okay
draw okay yeah yes yes yes they very
nice thank you oh you see that he just
he went like this you know he's like
okay that's a good start for me draw
with black draw
okay he's going to take that yeah he's a
really really good player and I think
that when you see ratings especially the
online Blitz ratings for some of these
players who aren't actually competing
quite as much they're misleading I do
think DOR is underrated he can take down
Greg and Greg going to his kacan and he
feels comfortable in these setups so he
makes fun of the Scandinavian James but
then he's playing the kacan which is
kind of like the scandy it's a solid
scandy of course if you I mean literally
if the queen was on A5 this would be a
line of the scandy queen takes D4 like a
scandish type of thing he does make a
lot of fun of it we always make fun with
John when John raids us we like John you
have ruined the world you know that
right you know with the Scandinavian
stuff and all of that and scandy lovers
but yeah Greg's that guy too as well he
he always just talks about how garbage
the Scandinavian is but he does play a
kro Khan which is a better Scandinavian
due to the pawn structure and the queen
doesn't have to come out many times here
so pretty solid pretty solid engine
hated Bishop G5 here Robert interesting
yeah I think it didn't like Bishop G5
perhaps um there are going to be some
tactics but I think Bishop G4 that's
available now cuz normally but Knight
takes F6 with check but the problem is
after e takes F6 now your Bishop's under
attack so this is a deep concept for a
Blitz game Bop
G but do that Greg Bishop G to and the
much need development that he's
currently lacking yeah that's actually
oh that's interesting Bishop G4 I didn't
even think of that cuz just seems like a
regular me seems like a good move it's
Bishop G5 and Bishop G4 I don't even
have to really take maybe I go Queen G3
or something but I mean it's interesting
oh there's Bishop E2 and then King takes
there's some wild lines in here okay wow
Bishop G4 is what a move there he takes
on D5 though which is understandable
like Bishop G4 trying to find out here
definitely
something yeah and white is down upon so
unless you're forcing unless you have
that clear initiative we just call that
compensation right we're going to put
those quotes on it oh yeah white has
compensation but what does that mean I
think here it's relatively clear that
Rook comes to D1 this Knight can hop
forward to G3 or F4 and how do you
develop look at these pieces all on the
back rank not developed if you play G6
we might see Wham H4 so is Bishop E6
James what's that about this feel like a
bass candy and in fact he shook his head
after like bit I don't even know what
I'm doing like what is this position he
like he he heard everything you said and
just was like you're right bro this is
garbage and just shook his head and play
Bishop E6 here as it this just doesn't
feel good why has all of the activity as
you see Rook can come to D1 would love
to Castle Queen side but of course hey
you know what Castle King side just get
out of the way obviously get my pieces
get the Rooks activated and literally
good things happen when when you develop
pieces so Castle bring a rook to D1
bring the other one to E1 go Knight D4
some at some point and just try to you
know maybe open up the shop now of
course black is extremely solid because
I do see Bishop D5 and maybe moving the
queen and playing E6 and if we can't
stop all of this and I mean Black's just
solid and there's nothing we can do so
we have to push everything we can um at
Greg right now I like that point though
that Bishop D5 is the idea it explains
Bishop E6 it's given a question mark and
that means that white has something
quick here but Bishop E6 makes perfect
sense and the E5 bar it's only5 better
for white that's an unclear position
like Knight F4 I would think is the most
natural looking move to me but he plays
Rook to D1 and after Queen C8 don't move
that Knight do not play Knight F4 do not
play Knight D4 because Bishop G4 is
going to hurt you and if you have to
spend the tempo playing H3 James then I
think G6 Bishop G7 and black is getting
out of it he is getting out of it this
bishop on G5 is really annoying I do
like the fact that sometimes making
moves like this you're like well I'll
just be kicked away like why why would I
move it if he's going to kick me away
well it will actually create some
weaknesses so if yes okay he plays H3 we
may see this G6 but we have to be
careful with Bishop G7 obviously because
Bishop takes E7 so H6 may come into play
somewhere which makes more weaknesses
around the black king here and I think
black is actually pretty solid which he
goes to G6 he is pretty solid here but
at the same time white does have his uh
his trumps trying to you know create
some weaknesses here black really solid
though yeah and I think one issue for
black it's not so easy still to Castle
because E7 might be loose and that's why
D plays in this manner but F6 I know Ben
FAL has never played but he's a GM he's
not invited to this tournament he's not
in IM anymore he was for a long time he
actually got his Grandmaster title quite
late in life relative to other players
but F6 here James that's a good move
because you kicked his Bishop away then
you Castle your king is perfectly safe
and you could tuck the bishop back on F7
never play F6 but here yeah it's fine
it's just fine D just do it it's F6 Chad
like what is that F6 could be very nice
and then you move the bishop and then
castles and then we play F5 at the right
moment to open up that Bishop there but
um B3 was a question mark man that's
crazy to think about when the engine
like question marks something like that
B3 like just question mark missed like
man why is the eval bar even on like
this just every move terrible nope try
again not today terrible move like
everything
and its nature Blitz right no matter how
strong you are mistakes happen and the
accuracy from these players is quite
high but it's just these little things
that are being allowed so for example
after Knight D5 I'd be playing Knight D4
let me go after this bishop and maybe
white gets to regain this Pawn in the
center and the engine is claiming that
if we get all these trades to happen
that black might be in a bit of trouble
down the line so I think that white
should play Knight D4 and we'll see
these players continue to figure things
out but uh James I think we should hop
back to our Bird's eyee view just
because while this one still has a lot
of life remaining our other matchup
between Mary and alen that game fewer
pieces are on the board and suddenly I
think things are turning around a bit
because alen's position at the corner of
my looked better and now it's heading
into an end game where white may be up a
pawn but once again it's about the pawn
quality not the quantity Black's pawns
are more advanced I didn't even know I
mean really it just didn't feel like of
course if you just looking at the
position it didn't I didn't feel this
extra Pawn which says a lot if you're up
a pawn sometimes you can feel it like oh
man this is I got space I got this I got
that now of course white has some checks
b7s coming but man the quality of these
D and C pawns here against the one two
on one plus obviously our pieces may
feel a little bit more active as black
here I mean just the King on F1 but also
my king on F7 there is a queen B7 check
coming you know yes I'm down a pawn here
but even engine says yeah everything's
fine it's equal and of of course from
practical standpoint my pawns are a
little bit closer to C and D to queening
than yours are so let's dive into that
one just because we are later into that
game and here comes D3 so look at this
Mary gives up a pawn and her point and
it was awarded a blunder or sorry I
should say awarded usually you're
awarded good things it was questioned
but we we understand that right because
after Pawn takes Pawn then Pawn to C3
and suddenly that c Pawn is like a
runaway train yep and here it is C3
played and look at the time time is
definitely something to pay attention to
here is of course obviously uh Mary has
a little bit less time they're around
the same you do get that 1 second
increment which is not a lot of time the
queen can come in we can also block with
the bishop if we need to on a queen B7
checks so this is a bishop F4 question
mark I'm thinking either
C2 or queen maybe A2 feels like one of
these should be something there's a
bishop E5 or G5 as much she's may be
going for she goes Queen B3
I like that move a lot because James it
takes away given an exclamation point it
takes away the B7 check that you were
indicating so no checks for white and
that Bishop E5 idea or Bishop G5 trying
to exploit a pin piece I think that the
white king is too vulnerable so oh I
love the way both these players are
taking it to each other Queen B3 says so
what Here Comes G4 and does G5 win the
game that's the big question the engine
doesn't seem to think so and of course
G5 is definitely a moveie you want to be
playing he's like I got to cover I got
to cover here worst case scenario I
could just take um I think she's
calculating at Bishop G5 Bishop G5 is
equal right now Robert equal what equal
what your math is off engine what are
you talking
about uh this equals a position where
both sides usually blunder but Queen C3
protecting the bishop threatening C1
equals Queen can you promote to a queen
right now I think you can and now black
is up a bishop black is up a bishop but
of course we do have the pawns and the
time is low three two oh man he made
that move with 3 seconds on the clock G5
Bishop
E7 got to move5 seconds I feel like it's
hard for black to lose this because uh
Black's pieces are all defended so I
think Queen takes A3 might have allowed
an immediate draw but it's hard to lose
when all of your pieces are defended
right yeah of course check King H oh
yeah yeah you want a draw we'll take the
draw here oh three oh whoa draw what no
draw she's trying to play for a win is
alen robers
uhoh James I think she might be playing
for both a win and a loss you have to be
careful in this position but now that
the Pawn's at G7 I think yeah black has
to force the draw I believe just keep
giving checks yeah there's no way
there's no way you can um okay this is a
peaceful result looks like peaceful
check check check check check check
check
check and the King cannot Escape Queen
F2 is the final check the game is drawn
Mary arid I think she's happy about that
James she's up one after half so draw it
inches her slightly closer to the Finish
Line that's what they say one with right
draw with black of course Mary's like
hey you know that that game you played
the first game in that little Dutchy
Dutch you know yeah try that again right
so let's see if we get another Dutch
here if she's going to stick to her guns
her meaning aen if she's going to stick
to her guns and play The Dutch again we
might see D4 and or maybe we may see
something different um from here from
her but D4 was a Dutch so it didn't end
very well got a draw there she feels
good wipes her face there it's like all
right reset and El Le needs to get on
the board with a
win yeah well right now A Lead just by
one point for Arab the other game is in
time trouble and black had the advantage
at first now suddenly white is better
because Greg shahadi King is dancing
around but this isn't a happy dance this
is just scurrying away from all the
checks and James I would be so worried
Queen E5 check given a question mark but
I don't know it looks dangerous for the
black
king it does look dangerous doesn't it
yeah especially after Bishop B6 6 very
nice with this queen A8 check here
hitting B7 he says I don't care about
none of that take the pawn running for
the heels track star we out of here
check King F6 we play Queen I would have
probably won King F6 to fight for more
Queen D7 okay check up may we have
another draw here boys not today I feel
like the Eva bar is really misleading
cuz white has this outside pass pawn and
that's often difficult to deal with
especially when your king is in the
center but I love what Greg just did he
brought his King to safety and with the
Queens off the board now I'm with you
James this looks like a peaceful result
in the making unless one of these
players loses on time and that can't
happen man that's what's up to in that's
what's up that's very like you know
gentleman like you know here I'm trying
to win I don't care about none of that
you know I want to no you I'm forc the
draw now of course uh yeah cuz it's it's
really you only one gets out of here so
yeah okay peaceful draw we got it no no
Bloodshed there and it happens so it's
one to one first to three and A2 wins
the thing that's the second game so I
think they go to 3+ one now it's about
who's faster here who's been playing
more Blitz who has more experience here
but I think it's evenly
messed yeah one to one in this matchup
so they will start the three plus one
and the shorter time controls normally
that's what the players are accommodated
to or used to I should say in the title
Tuesdays but when you just play 5-1 you
have to adjust on the fly to the shorter
time control so DED we saw him shake his
hands out he might be a little bit
nervous but he's playing well and the
other matchup there is a lead for Mary
arabid and I saw James they went back to
the Dutch so here we have um just
probably a positional battle in the
making and Greg no longer playing E4 and
getting a sicilian uh but I think the
other game promises some serious spice
because that Knight is back on C5 oh
absolutely that Knight's on C5 I am not
a fan of the like when you play the
Dutch you're looking for that attack
right like you just think of Dutch and
aggressive and this just it seems like
it's the other way around she's just not
getting into positions where you would
think that it came from a dust this may
look like it came from some type of like
caral Khan or Petro but like C Pawn
isn't moved and the night like how did
that happen in a Petro with the double F
Pawn so it's definitely you know weird
but it's just not fun to play from the
black side I mean I'm attacking you
you're not attacking me I'm attacking
you and we saw what happened in the
first game between them yeah why don't
we dive into the game on the right hand
side of the screen because we're talking
about a potential attack we see that
Knight or should we call it a knife on
C5 James doesn't this feel too easy for
white I just don't see how black plays
it's not so simple because you look at
the pawns you want to play G5 G4 maybe
that was a great move by the way Bishop
E6 because you couldn't play G5 with
that F Pawn hanging a moment ago what
she did was the the the the infamous
water sip you know you see this in all
formats all games all matches when they
sip whatever it is water tea adult
beverage whatever it is that they drink
of course is when they're feeling good
and she took the water ship there after
you know night C5 happened and you just
feel like you're in control a little bit
she's going for the same setup as last
time of course there's no Bishop on D3
this time but she definitely knows hey
I'm a little bit better here I don't
care about what you're doing over here
but I do like this approach from Eileen
here today that's actually now in this
game she should have probably went for
obviously G5 G4 H4 what she's going for
we have the opposite side castles
whoever gets to the king first is going
to win so now she's trying to do that
trying to get G4 in open up the king
side and hope for some type of
attack okay so now black pawns are
rolling white trying to do the same so
it's opposite flank Kings which means
that we're going to see both players go
all in for an attack and I may have
spoken too soon James I thought that
white was having all the fun but as we
look at this position isn't Black's next
move G4 and where is White's attack
going to come from do you have to play
B5 B6 ASAP I was thinking the same thing
because like now yeah there is uh this
is what she should have went for in the
first game and just white was just
steamroll her because it never happened
you never got G4 in you never got G5
look at this he plays F3 and never play
F6 never play F3 fine gold is molding
right now over this move aha see that's
why you don't play it that's why you
don't play it right F3 is a very very
annoying move and it's a hook in a way
G4 is coming G4 Rook G8 okay so there a
Miss maybe G4 anyway but yeah this is
double edged I definitely like B5 B6
immediately you're just going to have to
go B5 B6 sack and hope for the best
that's all you can do queen B5 is a sign
of something went wrong whoa okay so
trying to trade Queens off there's no
choice for black here and is the claim
that the pawn structure is better for
white and we say that because there are
no double pawns but when you have double
pawns You' have open files that e file
is available to a black rook and maybe a
doubling of the Rooks E3 is loose if
black plays B6 in the near future the uh
Pawn on B4 was loose and actually B 6
while by Bishop A6 here James there
might already be a tactic sheesh that is
actually a pretty nice move yeah she
kind of missed that sequence there
totally understandable in the time that
they have as well here but yeah this is
I like the bishop here to be honest but
this is a position where the knights can
Thrive but positions usually open up so
having two knights here aren't always
the best to tango with where do that
come from um Jeremy s May rest in peace
that was the uh the book uh reassess
your chess actually talks about that
with two knights are not the greatest to
have of course obviously you can use
them you need to know what you're doing
but as the position opens up as it is
right now look at E3 being weak I have
an open G file The Bishop's now a
monster can take on G4 can kind of do
what it wants here and things open up
and then the bishop start to Prevail
this looks amazing for black H3 is a
threat Rook G8 is a threat and look at
Mary just stealing this Pawn on F6 I
wouldn't be surprised if black could
even get away with a piece sacrifice
just going in for the kill but Bishop G5
that's the kind of tame move that strong
players make they don't just go directly
for checkmate if a piece is hanging and
they're unsure they waited out but James
where is The Knockout coming from you
have to find accurate moves here
otherwise white can St stay around
that's a great that's a great
observation I I'm trying to figure it
out here I have to move the bishop maybe
back to H6 to make you do something with
G2 so Bishop H6 a little wiggle there
and now what I may be able to sack on E3
but no yeah it has to be calculated so
maybe just Bishop H6 he goes C6 allowing
the kn
D6 and now oh that was the plan that you
attack the Knight on D6 to G2 hangs but
that's given a question mark but from a
blitz perspective James that's clearly a
good idea beautiful because we got the
pawn here of course right who cares what
the engine says oh it's wrong with like
who cares bro it was a good move good
plan it worked especially in the time
they have I keep forgetting that like
guys look at the time they're under 10
seconds right with one second increment
here obviously but definitely I would
take black here white is trying to hold
takes takes okay oh H3 take it if you
like but G3 check yeah wow this was
great defense by Mary she got her Knight
to F2 her Rook behind the pass Pawn that
Pawn's going absolutely nowhere and so
she goes after the A6 Pawn in wait we
Queen que what are you doing what are
you doing that's a dub count oh my gosh
count it James there was such good
resilience but that is the pressure it
was relenting from alen she really
earned this game she better put it away
now she's up a full Rook right and she
can just take and a resi there oh and
it's tied up she like I got the dub I
needed that and I'm on the board it is
even Steven and whoever gets three and a
half wins and it's even Steven on this
game in this match as well white is up a
pawn but those pawns can't go anywhere
with Bishops of opposite color so that
that's the problem with Bishops like
this is this bishop on B6 can't attack
anything you would love to turn that
into a light Square bishop and try to
trade off this bishop on B7 that is not
allowed that's not how chess works so
Greg shahadi he's going to have to be
content with another half Point James I
love how locked up this match is yeah
these guys are just they just playing
great chest evenly masked they can't
crack this one I can't crack you right
we tried a different opening this game
same result you know different openings
same thing draw and it was an ingame
draw like or at least is it's heading
towards that should be drawn here oh he
allowed it take takes and Bishop G3 and
that's for me this is De resy Page hold
on let me check the winds to the east
deor reski page 87 okay so this is a
wrap here this is over this is over yeah
you promote promote the C Pawn the
bishop takes you and then you get the a
pawn through and Greg jiadi just when we
saying a draw was likely D Sheriff
shakes his head he can't believe it but
that was just tenacious play from Greg
and also in the time so of course yes he
might be deeski page 111 theoretically
drawn but if the time is very low
anything happens and that's exactly what
we saw there we have a dragon over there
oh man and then over here what is this
this another what is this opening what
did they play in this game Mary actually
cam was gone there what did what was
that opening let me check right now
actually it looks like a sicilian that
turned
into what yeah Sicilian Pawn's on C6
yeah it's cilian though there there was
a swap of knights over there that's the
right hand side of your screens on the
left- hand side Greg chiadi once again
just showing one eye to the crowd half
of his face he doesn't mind moving away
from the optimal camera view but DED in
the bottom left James you can see it he
looks very concentrated but he also
still looks flumix from what happened a
game ago the problem is you have to get
over these very fast like okay if these
were you know you know like last year in
the formats before you was locked in
with that guy you know you or or gal
like you just get in the room there and
you just swing it like close the door
one person comes out like you're in
there and that for a long time so you
can go down a few games you know here
and there but this is a three and a half
and done type of match it's different
you're going to have to bring your best
every single game here you can't let
anything slip take every point that you
can hear and he does you have to get out
of that he has to get out of his head
now um or he's still shaking his head
there about that game you have to get
over it now or it will affect you in uh
in the game he's playing right now you
can see my arrow in the left hand side
of your screen Knight takes E4 is a
tactic and there it's found because all
of Black's pieces are aimed at this
Knight on D4 which is pinned because the
bishop on E3 is in some trouble and so
this was a good tactical find by Greg he
is now in charge in this match and I
just want to get chat involved so Greg
he seems to be doing well but give us
your predictions will Greg be able to
win this match against DED and how about
in the match between alen and Mary it's
TI one and a half one and a half give us
your predictions chat come on I don't
often welcome you to spam but go for it
give us who you think will win in these
opening round matchups let's go chat who
is going to win who do you think you got
Greg you got DED you got mared there you
got lean who do you think is going to
win wow Knight F5 I saw this little
tricky move maybe you can take on C3
first tactic senses are tingling Jedi
let me see can I take C3 first might as
well throw it
in and then maybe just move the queen
away that's a very good line recommended
by you and found by Greg so he will be
up upon maybe white has some counterplay
because after Pawn takes C3 the queen
has to move and then Knight takes Bishop
on G7 that Fen kettled Bishop is really
important to keep your king safe black
is better we see the engine saying as
much on the left hand side of our
screens but but it could be difficult
just because you're traded off your key
Defender and on the right hand side of
our screen James it's your style game
over there it looks like black is going
in for an attack she doesn't care that
she may have to sacrifice a pawn 100%
I'm definitely a fan of the attacking
chest of course the Sicilian here is
very nice when you have attacking
chances for both sides especially when
you have this lately these pawns like
this like these pawns are all fga a they
pushed up but the problem is is Robert I
can't push them any further so that
means I'm not having to attack well
engine just says I guess you you have
lost your mind what is this like engine
always says we lose our mind so what is
this a problem here I'm very curious I
actually don't know I have no idea why
this is a bad move maybe you just play
H6 or
something this is interesting
ni3 we see the chat is all in alen's
favor she's super popular I'm not
surprised that they support her but Mary
being so strong and look at the clock by
the way James I didn't even notice that
but alen is down to 13 seconds and
mistakes happen when you don't have
enough time to calculate yeah I didn't
even notice the time and that is when I
mean she didn't either here of course we
did have to remember that this is the 3+
one portion 3+ 1 much faster you don't
have that extra 2 minutes to sit and
think around at all in fact that that
diminishes very very quickly 13 seconds
to a minute yeah I'm going to take black
here okay so the E5 Pawn is under attack
that Knight can slide into B6 at the
right moment so I understand why she
played Queen to E3 three I wonder what
the drawback is because it's clear based
on the question mark given that black
has something to keep her in the game I
have to say I really like White's
position I don't see the I was going to
say yeah yeah this is like I mean look
at this like this classic right triangle
you know like uh it's a it's very solid
it's very solid over here and then you
got G5 in E bar dropped D4 oh that was a
sick move Queen B8 defend to D5 but okay
B3 I mean yeah but okay like it's
nothing really yet
can you take Bishop B before Bishop C3
no that doesn't work the bishop on B3
and if that becomes a Pawn on B3 white
is very happy because now there's no
attack so maybe black has one
opportunity not to try to steal one from
8 Mile here but I feel like there might
be just one idea that saves black maybe
Queen B5 she plays it Knight on A4
that's loose Rook takes A4 coming next
might have to take and play B3 what do
you even do she just said go for it I
don't even care about it takes takes and
Mary is in the driver C here I'm going
to mate you somehow some way is there a
queen sack Queen A2 there was Queen A2
there Queen A2 would have led the
Checkmate and then white was suddenly
winning but yeah and then something
crazy happened but man wow James she she
missed Rook G1 because Queen takes A2
was a forcing Checkmate she should have
played Rook G1 threatening a mate of her
own and that was missed by alen robers
because she doesn't have time to
calculate all her
options yeah this is uh speaking of
calculate options here these oh man the
ladies here Anything Can Happen Bishop
E5 on the bo Bishop D4 I mean queen C2
is down a pawn or piece I mean yeah this
is this this could be bad just don't
blunder any kind of back rank check and
no there it is nice and that's time and
there it is Mary with another
duve she is one away from clinching it
one away just one point separates Mary
arabid in a match Victory against alen
robers and that could have gone either
way but a match that is maybe getting
away from doid sheriff is on the left
hand side of the screen it looks like
Greg shahadi is in the driver seat up
not just one but two Pawns in a bishops
of opposite color Rook end game James at
this point seems quite easy for Greg to
play and he's aheading the clock and as
soon as I said that the eval bar takes a
nose
dive give me the pawn appreciate it
thank
you he took oh yeah he lost his absolute
mind on International television yep it
happens it does happen and let me see
yeah it's a Time factor it's the time
once again oh and for D he's hanging in
there with Greg it feels like step for
step he's just about level but he's a
little bit too slow on the clock and
Greg is finding the tactics when he
needs to but that was that was an
unforced error by
deid 100% yeah it happens in time
pressure you see it from the best of us
see it from the worst of us it happens
and when you get in that time pressure
sometimes it really just gets to you
right and maybe he's not playing enough
of the faster chest and having just the
time under pressure it gets to us all
here and he is down once again and Greg
is looking to close it out he's half a
point
away oh Greg he's trying to win this
matchup uh but we see on the other
matchup it's uh the fifth game of it
which means that they're in bullet it is
one plus one time for these players no
time to calculate no time to consider
all the tactics and that means it's fun
for everybody so Greg he can lock up
this match with a draw and for Mary if
she wins the match is over but James I'm
looking at the right hand side of her
screen it's chaos yeah it's definitely
there's just pieces fighing everywhere
we play bullet in 30 second every night
on stream so it's really nice so but
here it still
doesn't there's so many things going on
that you have to look at and at one
second it makes it different it's not
true bullet so like if you are losing
there is no flagging like not most
likely not flagging you might lose that
game for real especially with that 1
second increment thing so it's real here
you're going to have to play some good
chest in bullet how does that even make
sense right so it's really hard really
hard format to say the least sounds like
an oxymoron a good chest and bullet
don't don't typically go hand in hand
I'm looking at the right hand side of
the screen uh oh it looks
like her Rook
her The
Rook The Rook oh my gosh but but James
this would be the match she was better
before and then her Rook got trapped
she's down a piece so if she could
Swindle a draw she stays alive but Mary
arabid breathes a side of relief and
she's about to take this match an inch
closer to the top of the group and
potentially a IMC semi-finals appearance
so I do want to put that out there I did
have her as like one of the favorites
but actually my favorites are Believe It
or Not Kristoff seli from uh chess
explain and shes Roy or like the guys
people just don't even know who that is
some people don't know who that is but I
definitely know who that is and I think
he has a great shot as well they all do
here anything can happen I actually mean
for me I made it to the finals last year
and I started as the eighth seed right
you know I had one guy or in the chat it
was like Hey is ky gonna win a game
today and then we made it to the final
right so anyone right anyone can make it
anyone can make it everybody has their
choices and stuff like that and and
there are the people they pick here but
Mary's definitely one that this was kind
of expected no way as he is really
really strong they both are but and
that's it that's the match great job
from Mary look at that on the screen s
of relief breathe
breathe yep drink some water relax as
long as you can because Mary araby
defeats alen robers by score three and a
half one and half she gets to watch the
other contest for now but the action
will continue because in this group
format we have four players and they all
play one another in these six game let's
call it mini matches but Greg shahat
was winning but in a second game in a
row he blunders his C Pawn now D Cher
has a chance because Greg shot's lost in
this game James Bishop D5 check is about
to win on the spot oh Bishop wait what
trade Queens he he didn't do it okay
trade Queen Rook D1 oh what what Roberts
Roberts
no I can't believe it's not good I can't
believe this he can't believe it look at
Greg oh my goodness and great winning oh
my goodness you got to be kidding me you
must be joking you got to be kidding me
bro white is
winning oh yeah it's just a bad day in
the office that's just there's no other
way to put it it's just a bad day in the
office it happens it's happened it is
what it is it's just not my
day and Rook F2 getting the Rook behind
the pawn the the thing about this game
is it a draw wins for white because Greg
has three points and that's all he needs
is a draw in this game he doesn't even
want to win he takes the match 3 and a
half one half so James we saw both
matches end in the score as Greg shahadi
he takes match one but the matches were
very close right this could have gone
either way and for both matches in fact
man that's a water SHP there Greg hey
man you need to hydrate some more man
hey hey great you need to you need more
water we need to make sure we get him a
water sponsor over there as well but at
the same time here yeah this definitely
was really really intense for both
matches there Mary had the upper hand
just in both game or all the games there
but it could have really swung anywhere
I think the time trouble is what got you
know both parties there in the games and
both matches so time was the issue and D
was fighting but Greg was just a little
bit more experienced there and got it
done so good job so we know after the
first matches who is in the lead there
are two players who will be very
thrilled with the start that they just
had and that is Mary arabid and Greg
shahadi both winning by a score of 3 and
1 half 1 and a half and unlike the
traditional brackets where you lose a
match you're gone these are shorter
matches but you get three of them so
there is time to mount a comeback if
you're Al Leen or deed but only one
player moves on and here is our cross
table you see Greg shahadi and Mary
arabid both winning by a score of three
and up one and a half James what do you
think of what we just
saw yeah it was really strong it was
really fun it was also like more of a
warmup for everyone there now of course
you have to only advance for three and a
half so and now they're warmed up this
is going to going to be even you know a
stronger a more intense more emotions
match you may even see more blunders cuz
the stakes are high knowing that I win
this match I'm going through that's it I
am the winner right so it is bigger uh
for them so I mean hey you know it's
good good chess some bad chess in there
happens it's fast chess so and in a
format makes it even more you know um
nerve-wracking just only playing two
games per per uh per time control there
Robert Stakes are high time is low
players who lost that first match they
will need to mount a ASAP we're going to
take a quick break but when we turn it's
Greg against El it's Mary against DED
the action continues here at the imcc do
not miss a
[Music]
Beat
sh
[Music]
J let's
check
Peter check I check oh
sorry I didn't hear you say
[Music]
anything
y
thanks I thought badana played extremely
well very very solidly didn't make M
didn't make mistakes and made good
positional moves all the time the last
time I was wiped out by a woman was by
Nona gaing Dash in 1966
she beat
me she beat you two two
wins nice yeah
[Music]
I'm
he
[Music]
International master elen robers in what
looks like one of the most impressive
studies I have ever seen I hope she
studied hiar nakamura's end game manual
not just on end games the end of bullet
games because the scrambles have not
been going her way but she is super
strong she's the youngest player in the
a group and she is a very accomplished
player in her own right despite being
under 18 years old she's the highest
speeder rated under 18 woman in the
world she finished in ninth place that's
high at the 2023 Women's World Cup and
she won an individual silver medal at
the 2022 chess Olympiad 7 out of 10 she
actually tied in terms of performance
rating with Pia kremling who won the
gold medal but Pia played 11 games alen
played 10 but alen is very very strong
and James what is she going to have to
do differently against Greg shahadi in
order to turn her fortunes around I
think a lot is uh two things one is
going to be AB absolutely in the time
scramble you're just going to have to be
better you got to try to be more
accurate try to be more sharp it's
easier said than done but that's just
something we're going to have to do the
second thing is actually of course uh
understanding the plans in that Dutch
there she's probably maybe going to
bring out some more Dutch too as well is
to just go for the plan right that game
where she lost really bad um to uh to
Mary there was just a kingside Onslaught
where she never was able to get her her
attack in when they castled on opposite
side so if she can keep that up then she
may have some good chances against Greg
here and she's a very aggressive player
and we saw that Greg when he was playing
in his first match against DED cheriff
he was playing a little bit more
positionally some of these Sicilians
where they were just moving their
Knights back and forth so in a round two
matchups we have Greg shahadi against
elen robers and we also have Mary arabid
who won her first round matchup she
plays DED cherub so James we were just
talking about Greg and alen what does
DED have to do to take down
Mary just get out of his own head and me
take some advice for me CaRu here is
like literally don't care and also you
do have to say that I have to have um uh
short-term memory losses another thing
Carl likes to talk about is hey look you
know it happened you lost that match it
doesn't it's over with get to the next
one try to play good in this one and who
knows what can happen if we win the
other ones maybe somebody else who loses
a match anything can really happen here
so we just got to get over that match
and bounce back stronger in this one and
here we go game should be
happening any second now ready for D I
think he should have some confidence
because he was holding Greg CH they were
even in that match even in their
positions but then in some time trouble
DED went wrong and he lost some
positions that should have been a draw
but we have lift off we have the games
on screen on the right hand side in Mary
against the weed we have a queen Pawn
opening on the left hand side we're
getting some Sicilians and I don't
actually know the ins and outs of the
line that Greg and alen are
playing yeah this was a what the E6
Bishop C5 is a little bit different um
that is something I'm not familiar with
to is why must I love playing Sicilian
2o and like e4s and stuff but this one
is sort of a rare one D6 and C7 pawns or
um um squares are obviously weak but
black can counter with D5 especially
with the king in the center he goes
Bishop C7 and then play be something
exactly Bishop D6 and we just control
the D6 Square he says and look at this
alen true to her style she says no Queen
trade for you so we have Kings on
opposite sides of the board and
meanwhile Mary arabit she put her Knight
on the rim not looking so dim it's going
to take that Bishop on the right hand
side of your screen but why don't we
just first go to Greg against alen
that's such a fascinating matchup
different styles Kings on opposite sides
of the board so if we are going to dial
in to one position let's go there
because James King on C1 King on G8
who's King safety do you prefer whose
position would you rather have I prefer
white I mean we got more pieces I'm a
big fan of development I worked with
some Russian chess coaches in the last
year and it was just like you know they
are really big on get the pieces out
right move develop and calculate right
develop and calculate culate right
that's what they would always be saying
so develop get the pieces out and of
course white has a lot of pieces out um
and now we can go Bishop D3 now Bishop
B7 it didn't like too much black can go
Rook C8 so I do like the what what elen
did here is going like basically real
fast B5 get the bishop out get the Rook
to C8 as fast as humanly possible then
we got to get these Knights to do
something U maybe Knight KN on E8 is
defending G7 but it is going to be
extremely passive which means you're
going to be holding and from White
standpoint we can go F4 H4 H5 H6 F5
everything five and go for mate here
when I don't see really the same for
black yet especially after knight2 I
mean how are you even attacking me on
the queen side right Knight E2 played
because B4 doesn't even need to be
played the Knight wants to get on over
to the king side maybe all the way up to
H5 at the right moment and for black D5
is very tempting but then we get this
french-like structure where white just
pushes through to E5 so E5 is available
to White right now but especially if
black chooses to push then E5 comes in
whose Bishop is better it's very clear
the French Bishop is bad the bishop on
D3 that's a very very nice piece where
it sits if you play the move
D5 here all the pieces he pushes H4 I'm
curious to see what the idea is let's
say we do get the pawn H6 and then G6
happens I'm trying to figure out what is
the the plan from there which is a hard
part is okay yeah you get everything you
want El lean's like yeah go ahead do it
I'm going to push G6 and like you know
look at you real hard through the zoom
camera like what are you going to do now
buddy yeah that's exactly what's
happening H6 G6 yeah it's there and you
know what are you going to do Greg what
are we going to do is the question
you're starting to do accents like da
you're also becoming a prophet like da
you said exactly this the pawn goes up
to H6 black plays G6 and now we got the
Swiss cheese all of these dark squares
look weak but this Knight on E8 it's
undeveloped but it is defending some
very very critical squares on both sides
of the board so I think alen made her
intentions very clear Bishop A6 she said
Robert stop making fun of my light
Square Bishop I can play Bishop A6 at
some moment to trade it off and that
would be good news for her because then
d 5 it won't shut down your Bishop if
The Bishop's off the board you know I'm
offended Robert I you didn't say that
you know you know uh me and da are
brothers did you not does it not look
like that we twin brothers like that's
my twin brother we play the same
openings we say but okay all the time
like you know it's it's the I'm the same
person right so I cannot believe you
couldn't see the resemblance but you
know back to the game here it's it's
more that night is gross on E8 obviously
I I guess we have to go with F4 okay F4
play f45 and like try to break through
but I don't exactly I don't even know
engine's like yeah I don't know either
but like yeah what do we do after F5 I
mean I don't see it Greg shakes his head
and I think black will be able to
probably play A4 B3 and make some some
really weird things happen on the black
on the black on the queen side for black
I'm looking at F5 I think black can also
consider F5 herself I was talking about
this bishop not being strong if I can
get rid of your E4 Pawn that's a great
bishop and sometimes the best defense is
getting offensive on the same flank
because F5 gives this Rook a task it
actually has more space in front of it
so F5 it's a committ move it's a very
very big decision here but I'm not sure
if it's a bad decision just because I
feel like this Knight on E2 in
particular it's not doing the most it
needs to get active uhoh whoa that is
not a move apparently okay but why is it
Queen H4 do I just pick up a knight and
Knight Knight have a good knight get him
off the night AKA board oh great vision
by you because it looked like you were
pushing your pawns but suddenly you see
Knights on the same diagonal it's not
where they belong and Greg says Queen G5
and we live James see your same idea
winning a piece and after E5 we play D
E5 F5 and have a nice day hit the button
the resign button that is uhoh this is
really bad news for alen robers and she
goes Knight to D5 I have to say if
you're going to lose a piece this is
probably the best way to do it white
needs to be very careful in some
positions Knight C3 is a check that
might open up the be line for this queen
over here but objectively Greg is
winning as long as he doesn't miss a
tactic in front of his King and he goes
whoa two resign oh shoot I was like what
happened what happened bro it was so
fast I think I was like yo is that a
mount function chesc what are we doing
like oh snap it was just a resi it was
so fast
yeah she said game over here so why
don't we go back to our Bird's eyee view
because while game one seems to be done
with oh and maybe maybe it wasn't maybe
there was a just a a glitch on my end my
apologies everybody but we see that in
the other game Mary Arab will not slow
down for anybody she is going right
after DED Sheriff's King and that King
doesn't look like it's long for this
board let me tell you something look I
have I actually have played Mary many
times and I compliment in here I sent
her a message like you are extremely
strong cuz like we played like I
remember 10 seven 10 11 games we was
going back and forth and I'm like man
she is really strong like I hit her with
a combo and like ah Flex real hard then
she does the same next game like whoa
who are you you know so really strong
player I think underrated she goes under
the radar a lot of people don't know
about her I just knew about her from
getting caught in the pool you know
getting matched up and uh and playing
and and she's really really strong here
and she's trying to go through this
field here so she is going to be a force
to be reckoned with I felt the force the
force is strong with this one and and
Mary and uh she's doing the same thing
right now in this match against
D and now Leen robers has in fact
resigned after Greg's brilliant
sacrifice on G6 just ripping open the
king side so is Now official that Greg
chotty is up one to nothing but on the
right hand side of your screen it's kind
of a similar story James we saw Greg he
won a piece and then went for checkmate
here you know Mary's thinking can I play
a move like Rook takes G6 check go right
after d King yeah oh you know we got to
sack first think later we don't even
know what's next Robert we just know
that all of these pieces are on the king
we have to sack it of course she didn't
go she went Bishop C1 which is totally
normal but I definitely would have tried
to make that sack work a thousand times
um somehow Some Way Queen E8 that just
doesn't hang anything does it let me see
Queen E8 nothing hanging we want to get
D7 in but it doesn't work doesn't work
here Robert I
mean actually wait doesn't doesn't that
work Rook G6 oh we Queen takes G6 is
check Queen takes G6 check oh my
goodness and you hit the button
instantly Instant Button hit okay oh man
because if that King were on A1 Rook
takes G6 would win for white but because
the king is in that diagonal that would
be one of the worst blunders and I was
thinking the same thing does a rook G6
just go for the tactics I think what
Mary is so strong at James is she is
able to keep herself composed and she
doesn't just go all in she knows the
moments to pick to go for the attack she
doesn't just throw her Pieces away for
no reason 100% I think also she uses her
time very well and oh wow okay Bop G was
not the move but I mean okay still I
still prefer white 100% but here um a
lot of a lot of things come with uh
having this one second increment is
really nice because she does think a lot
I remember playing her many times and
she uses her time like obviously you
should use your time but see you know
when you're playing with no increment
there's flagging possibilities and you
have to play quicker here you can play
quick but you can play quick enough to
like yeah okay I'm down on time like she
is right now but I do get that one
second increment and try to nurture this
position or at least try to play the
best moves but you can't get solo on
time cuz she is getting into the 20s now
which he had 1 second increment but it
is like you know I'm in 20 second
territory you got to relax here move a
little bit faster and it looks like
black is trying to
consolidate yeah trading Queens was a
bad decision I think that if you gave
her a second chance if she played that
position 100 times she would not do that
because her King was safer now that we
have Queens off the board but black is
suddenly up a pawn that pass Pawn is
gone and wait a second Rook takes D1 the
F5 Bishop she taking
here aha guess eight maybe Knight G8 you
get two for one or something I don't
know Knight something and you can even
play gf5 Pawn takes E5 and Rook takes H3
if you're worried about anything she
goes for that James she's up a pawn
there's no risk in her position and
that's a healthy passer excuse me his
position D is the one with black
suddenly I'm talking about black with
winning chances yeah yeah that black
definitely has the winning Chances with
the pass Pawn here now as well I mean
what a miraculous turnaround this
happened here where she was just you
know we came in she over here hitting
them with the kitchen sink and then
throwing throwing them through the door
and like hey leave him alone right this
man has a family and then you see he
just you know call the ambulance but not
for me says D we here as uh he's
actually like turning this around 100% I
mean this is with check by the way free
move
almost yeah F2 throw that pawn forward
and James I think this goes to show how
great this format can can be when you
have the group stage where D instead of
being eliminated instead of going to a
losers bracket no he could take down
somebody who won her first match and
then for if Mary we're not saying it's
over in this match it's literally the
first game but if she does lose this
match then she plays Greg so she has a
chance to control her own destiny that
is really a cool element of this year's
IMC and I think Rook C2 that looks like
a good move but then King d3f somehow
she's fighting I don't see how to put
this game away just yet yeah I am
definitely trying to figure out how do I
make progress and that's the hard part
here maybe just move the king forward
maybe some type of weird zugang maybe
here King like King E4 is coming great
decision great call because that Rook is
overloaded it's it's now it's done
because yeah there's like a
weird do I take and King up no King ner
Che King n Che what is this how do you
win Rook
Che she he goes the other way but where
is the win here oh rookie one check is
the
threat sick and there it is Boom there
it is on the boards you see those fist
pumps James the weed is pumped
up start swinging at the air punching
the air all hard let's
go hey you know they they don't really
often say greed is good but Creed is
good and he's taking some lessons from
Apollo Creed delivering those punches
into the air and I think Sylvester
Stallone would also be proud so DED
cheriff gets his first dub of the day
bad news for Mary Arab but let's go to
the game on the left hand side of our
screen here alen robers is just going
right after Greg shahadi King and
apparently the position is already
winning for her it's surprising to see
this early in the game but those light
squares are Pride open what was this
opening oh was this that
Scandinavian was it no way Greg he
played the scandy I think he he did and
you see this okay chat look shout out to
John Ro also not shout out to John roal
that's my my boy shout out to JB this is
what you're causing look at this game
this is John ral's fault here every time
100% And I mean as much as uh Greg talks
about Scandinavian just being a garbage
opening I mean you're seeing it
firsthand right now you're seeing it he
plays a Scandinavian and what did he get
from it what did he get from it this
position so you know it's Jo James can
we talk about how selfless he is just to
prove the point that the scan Haven is
bad he decided to lose a game of CH so
Greg on purpose Applause to you yeah
you're just a a really kind soul for the
chess Community but look at alen she
doesn't probably face the Scandinavian
that often and she's ripping it to
shreds Queen takes E5 or Knight takes E5
available Bishop takes F7 that looks
like a free Pawn to me snack on that the
light squares are a permanent problem
for the black king I think that alen she
has her choice of Pawns to grab I would
be taking the one on F7 I just think
that's very very free and bad news for
Greg yeah Greg is is never playing this
again I mean he's like why did I play
this what did I do like yeah why did you
of course you just gave yourself a point
here now you got to fight back okay well
obviously you are up one um and then you
know if you the game's not over yet she
should win this one she's projected to
win this one is what we say cuz things
happen obviously with time weird time
gets weird and Etc but at the same time
here uh Greg Jose Scandinavian and he's
getting worked and she is actually doing
uh everything in her power to get this
dub here to make it even first to three
and a half wins this match obviously and
that's a second Pawn now that she can
grab like you close the light squares
but you give away all your pawns and
after Queen takes E5 I don't even know
if I can look at this position anymore
the Queens have to come off I would
assume but after the Knight takes oh no
Knight G6 is a fork you could play B5
and try to rip open those light squares
again at any moment moment I can't look
at this
James yeah I mean of course I guess we
got the okay you know from to terms of
service here that certain things can be
this is more pg-1 13ish so this is fine
um here this is pretty rough for for
Greg 196 like I mean just clean up shop
two Bishops look at your knight on B8
what is that piece like it's the same as
if you like pick it up and put it off
the board it would be doing the same
thing so the piece is really bad here
terrible position for Greg her oh and
look at this she doesn't even take the
Rook because it can't move that's how
bad it is for Greg shahadi she just
defends the pawn does Alan robers
there's no takes on C3 with a fork of
the Rooks and Rook E5 what if she
doesn't take it again what if she plays
F4 here that would be awesome if she
play F4 just disrespectful like you know
say respect your elders here you know
what I'm saying like at4 is just
straight up disrespectful and I oh my
goodness she don't care about nothing
yeah she's scary she very scary now
she's very scary be very afraid of el
robers be very afraid and you know how
we know Greg's afraid both eyes are on
screen here no longer you see the
Cyclops right now he's getting worked
really badly so Elite Rober said you may
have taken game one but this should be
worth like three points right now that's
how head she is wow man look like you
know Greg got a few hairs on his head
after that one I can see that that's
crazy it's grow they growing immediately
that's powerful lean is very powerful he
grew them just so he could scratch them
and try to fix F out what to do in the
next
game oh and the rook's trap too just hey
bro hit the button bro hit the button
Greg hit hit the button hit the button
my guy okay takes takes Rook D1 and like
just
straight you know we we are obviously
joking about Greg we're good friends
with Greg shahadi and Greg loses that
game here so it is one to one in this
match yeah that Greg was not happy about
that one and he just like what else can
you say like CH don't try that at home
chat so all the scandy fans out there
I'm sorry you know what I mean I'm sorry
you had to see that but that's what
happens when you play scandy a lot of
times so it is what it is cool we we
back he's into his element now playing
E4 and more stuff here only the right
hand side of the screen what is that
opening what an on Earth is this let me
actually oh it was it was a sicilian
another one same thing trading on C6
okay but the left hand side scen still
opening Theory let's go to that game on
the right hand side of the screen
because Mary arabid lost game one we saw
how happy David Cher was he's going to
be thrilled he is just blasting open the
kingside and James am i counting
correctly is he also just up a pawn
sometimes you know it takes that one win
where you just like you know anything is
possible Right Kevin Garnett like you
can do any anything is possible
immediately after you get that game when
you get that oh shoot I won I can do
this wait I am a beast you know and then
you just start beasting and right now I
mean from losing the first game or was
losing now he won the first game and
then this game this is a this could be
potentially a 20 lead getting three and
a half I'm feeling great who know who
cares about the first match I lost in as
Greg I forgot about that already right
so he's feeling really really good here
if I'm theed here very strong very very
strong now we have to finish maybe
you'll see some G4 F5 and we do have to
maybe you know obviously stop B4 or
watch Black's counter play but white
isn't driver right ween need seven St
black can't castle that Bishop on G5
says no you don't you can't run away
from me no Castle in Queens side and he
uh plays Queen H7 your idea and James is
there going to be like a a rook H1 Queen
G8 Rook h8 can you just s of slow play
it and just go for checkmate there's
also exactly Rook H1 Queen here and then
you can sack it almost Queen takes
obviously and Bishop F6 with Rook h8
Mage ooh it's getting spicy it's getting
it's a lot of spice he's going for
Rook H1 and Eng didn't like it as much
of course like question mark what are
you doing I'm going for mate like shut
up you know what I mean that's I talk to
the engine bro shut up like what are you
talking about going for mate like engine
always gives you something stupid but
Knight E2 wait also you can go Knight E2
Knight G3 Knight H5 that should also
just land on F6 and that's going to hurt
and the Queen on H7 is so powerful that
it defends the C2 Pawn which is Black's
only idea of trying to go for checkmate
whoa um I mean I guess guess we just go
for the
plant yep why
not
G3 it's going to inviting it my Knight's
under attack I don't really want to
spend time defending it so Knight G3
Knight H5 and I'm landing on F6 and I'm
landing on F6 and now the question is
actually believe it or not if we allow
this and then oh you just King d8 and we
take on D7 take on F7 that should lead
to game over somehow trying to figure
out what was the followup afterwards
nice
I believe it's that straightforward that
there's nothing that Mary can do it's a
very natural plan
uhoh wait wait wait what yeah yeah he's
going for Queen G he's going for that
mate but there's something wrong and I'm
trying to figure out what it is cuz it
is it does work where you can sack the
queen I don't see why bro that's crazy
to me wait Queen takes
E2 and then Queen be Queen
C oh after check correct yeah you bring
the queen back to C5 y you bring the
Queen back to C5 wow the idea here chat
is after Queen to G8 right Queen takes e
well Queen takes E2 first queen comes to
G8 with the second possibility he's
going to go for it that's why he play
Bishop F6 to cut the king off but now
you have this check and the queen gets
back to C5 and he missed this can Queen
gets back to C5 now engine says it's
still okay you can't obviously go Rook
here she plays it it's on the board it's
there but here you hanging made on the
back rank on National Television don't
do that so Queen takes is going to be uh
Queen takes f8 right so now we just have
to figure out what we let me see is
there any emotion from him nothing don't
see anything okay it's still hard for
for black to move though but James I
think King D1 was better and he Wast the
time or has to spend a turn I should say
playing A3 and that's why King D1 was
better it would have freed that Rook to
go up to a square like H7 or h8 oh she
took it now Rook H7 Rook H7 oh Rook
H7 that's game oh that's it that's it
let me see the let me see her face
nothing I don't see
any any emotion from
that D J she need she's Stone Cold like
no emotion okay now now we see a little
I was like yo this is over you know that
right like she just now you see a little
bit little bit emotion she needed to
move that light Square Bishop to free up
space for her King earlier or the
seventh R Rook A7 would defend F7 if the
bishop were not sitting on that D7
Square so Pawn takes A3 Maybe she
thought she's just grabbing some pawns
and all is good but no All Is Lost right
now Rook H7 stopping one square short of
the initial plan is delivering made on
F7 next that's sick that is sick very
strong here she might have to try Queen
E7 obviously and Bishop takes and King
takes and say oh but you can't even like
what does that even do yeah this is GG
this is game over like I mean you could
try Queen E7 and then but no wait that
just prolongs the mate all right cool
cool yeah I'm just made it I'm just made
it I'm just made it and I like to say
when you see mate look for better but D
sheriff is looking much better another
celebration from him and he goes to two
and0 in this match he's playing great
chess and in our other game on the left
hand side of the board they're in the 3
plus one 3 minutes 1 second increment
quicker time control and elen robers she
has the edge you see the eval in her
favor opposite color Bishops but her
pawns are better and suddenly Greg
shahadi is sweating for the first time
today he might be fa facing his first
deficit after this game as she's piling
up all the pressure towards the F2 pun
James E4 sacrific that pawn and go for
F2 oo E4 is really strong that's the
move I missed cuz I was like okay I go
Queen F3 and then what do you have buddy
yeah and then well she plays F5 which is
that's a wicked move I really like that
because the queen has squares going up
to F6 now E4 is even stronger where the
queen is kind of like maybe not trapped
but I can't move many squares so it's TR
all the way down oh yep that's the w oh
man oh man you're getting cooked rookie
three Rook check who who wait she took
it she moved to fast so much time yeah
she moved way too fast there was it just
check but then there's Bishop F1 and
maybe there was Queen A1 there or
something like that takes B3 Rook F1
King G2 Rook G1 King H3 Queen check King
G like there's there's a lot there's a
lot obviously but I mean Too Fast Too
Fast Too Furious happens both sides are
making mistakes here that's happen in a
scramble black is up upon do not take
that pawn though because Bishop C4 would
pin and win that Rook so as long as you
don't blend that your head if you are
black here King to G7 I would get that
King out of the diagonal but she wants
the F2 Pawn right away going right
forward opposite color Bishops the op
color Bishops here be very careful D6 is
going to be a really annoying check
after the king moves wait a second you
better go to the right square right okay
check oh she's she's good after Bishop
takes wow that's going to be nice very
nice no mating possibilities
and what is happening here H4 King G4 oh
Bishop picks up to check and you don't
have King to G2 there there King F3 oh
my gosh that's mate anyway o everything
mate
ooh
ooh yeah that
hurts and you see Greg he breathes out
and he's like what is going wrong all we
know is everything going right in the
Tactical sequence for elene Rober she
now leads 2 to one in that match up
James right now DED up two nil alen up
21 we're seeing a reversal from those
first matches absolutely of course it's
a lot it's about warming up it really is
about warming up like and shout out to
CIA too as well like I started the first
match last year when I was playing in
this event I I beat Coosa by three right
but I started the match 5-0 so I'm
thinking like man Coosa man I'm about to
work this guy and 5 and then he almost
5ed me at some point in the match so you
have to be warmed up in fact right get
that warm up do your thing all right
cool I'm done I got my games in now
let's play this game and that's what's
going on you get those games you get the
Jitters out they're playing really
strong everyone is now and if these
matches if the people who are leading
right now win will have everybody tied
with one match victory that would be
super cool heading into the final round
of the group stage but we see in these
boards right now a peaceful start on the
left hand side of the screen I just
protect all the pieces on the right hand
side James I see some really ugly pawns
for D cherub those double isolated C
pawns not looking good to my eyes yeah
it's not looking good he I do like the
fact that he does have the bishop uh
which I guess can offset the fact that I
do have this ugly structure in a way
also um the fact that you know the ten
the tenaciousness or tenacity from uh
DED here just fighting you know okay
this position was bad the first game he
was actually losing and now he's too old
out of nowhere so yeah position may be
bad here I've actually had worse so I'm
going to feel better about this one at
least as the weed I can fight in this
one but we need to make some things work
I do like this Knight on C3 though it's
really a disgusting piece like that
Knight is really strong on
C3 and I love that Rook D5 move on the
right hand side please take me says D
Cher because I'll will fix his Pawn
structure so both games are interesting
thus far I saw that comment there saying
alen she'll become a GM we all hope so
she's just 17 years old she'll be
playing in uh the the women's Grand
Swiss at the end of the month in Isle of
Man has some great opportunities ahead
of her she was Electric in the Women's
World Cup she won her first few matches
and she was dominant in them and against
Greg shahadi who just played F6 had
earned a question mark so they're in
their fourth game of the match James if
elen can take this game she'll head into
the bullet only needing a draw but I
have to say Greg is probably the better
bullet player between the two of them so
she does not want to let this lead slip
yeah definitely especially all you need
is a draw shoot a you win this game here
mean you're trying to do as as much as
you can you just don't want to go to the
bullet portion and lose both games maybe
you could split one that's fine you're
really close to winning anyway you just
want to get on the board for the rest of
the games if you can get on the board
then by mathematically you should be
able to get three and a half first so
good strategy there just keep playing on
try to play the best that you can this
is such an endg game on the right
there yeah that's a really funny
position right right so many double
pawns but that Knight on C3 you called
it James that's allowing black to stay
in it for D cheriff so he's just has the
activity white has a Superior Pawn
structure as long as the pieces remain
the same it should be dynamically
balanced but I'm looking at the left
hand side like things uh looking quiet
for now peaceful at the moment but any
moment now things can wake up on this
board unless they trade Queens in which
case we'll just be in a pretty level end
game yeah in fact it looks like both end
games will here in fact it's more about
I guess who has the better in game
technique who's going to improve the
positions better who's just not going to
blunder this should be just very level
here I think the game on the right has
chance to actually spice up somewhere
more likely for the black pieces having
just more activity look at the Knight
how it's restricting everything white
can do you can't even go anywhere and
The Rook on the dile there is doing a
great job un let's be find maybe a
Perpetual here Knight H4 and Knight F3
might there it is yep and there it is
there it is okay so a draw is a fair
result between Mary and DED but that's
good news for D Sheriff who now is one
point away from match Victory if he can
win this game with the white pieces he
earns himself a match win and will be
much happier and thinking positively
about his chances but in the left hand
side of her screen there was a blunder
just now let's go to that board you see
Greg shaking his head his position
actually isn't bad so I'm just to go
back to that moment here we tuned in uh
just quickly the move C4 is played The
Rook is under attack you can't move the
Rook without losing the bishop so Greg
has to he simply must take this bishop
which was given the double exclamation
point because he's only down a bishop
and a pawn for a rook that's not a huge
material deficit and James as we look at
the live position right now we see the
bishop we see the pawn it looks very
healthy for black in the center and the
engine starting to prefer Black's
position is Greg he's going not just for
a draw he's trying to win this thing
yeah he actually you know it's the Rooks
need open files that's how they can be
active and they are aren't really any
okay she's trying to create one now with
F4 makes a lot of sense here um so okay
I think white can hold white can
definitely hold black can try to play
for more you know maybe get the king up
Greg is definitely shaking his head
because it was a mistake it wasn't like
you voluntarily gave this up you had to
do that to not lose more material here
limit the damage here so you know we'll
see what happens that D3 Pawn is weak
but you can't really win it it's going
to be difficult here could be draw could
be
yeah and this Pawn H2 is hanging but I
wouldn't grab that because then when
this Rook slides to H4 it also hits the
H7 Pawn you calling for James what Rooks
need open files open space and right now
all the files are pretty closed down so
I think that black is best suited by
King D7 even Bishop D6 saying I'm sorry
where are you going to try to win this
game from I don't see it and oh B5 now
this would be a big shot for white
because A4 is loose she misses it but B5
is available the is overloaded I think
he's seen it and then well is it still
there it is not anymore okay cuz now you
can take on B5 with the c Pawn so he get
out of it real fast with King D7 trying
to cut off The Rook I think is what he
wanted but it was just in the wrong
timing also whoa speaking of time again
this is uh yeah this is game four this
is the last three minute game time is
running really really quickly for them
really really fast she's under 15
seconds now got a move under 10 and she
makes a move at 11 seconds Rook to
C2 she's in some trouble here because if
this king gets up to D5 suddenly I'm
looking for C5 breaks this A3 Pawn
cemented in place on a dark square that
is bad news but Rook C4 she's getting
activity once again the king could slide
around to C2 or Rook E2 because the Rook
takes D3 James Rook back to D2 forcing a
rook trade in some positions that could
be really good news or actually Rook E4
she found a better way she doesn't even
give up the D Pawn now it's a pure
endgame Rook against bishop and pawn
James what do you think does white have
good winning chances
let me see De resy Page uh 301 talks
about this this one actually is uh
holdable but it is hard to do and it
needs to obviously you need to keep the
pawns on the board and maybe try to make
some trades favorable for you makes make
some weaknesses like he did with that A3
Pawn but yeah it's just defend it just
defend it it is doable in this time
control though anything is possible in
this time control takes takes King up
and then she gets the pawn yeah that's
the W Rook too active Rook too active A5
and now it is clean extra exchange and
where's her King going I thought the
King was going to go up the board she
went the wrong way the evil bar is back
hovering towards the center so both
sides making mistakes mere seconds on
the
clock okay this H4 Pawn I think that's
going to be in trouble later in this
game but James I think Greg is relying
on some kind of Bishop G3 Bishop E5 back
and forth oh yeah yeah I can definitely
see that I can definitely see that here
it is winning but she has to find the
right maneuver maybe walk the king all
the way over to E4 and threaten his sack
on E5 can you get she barely got the
move off oh je I just looked the clock
she had 3 seconds left for one of her
moves so she's barely getting them off
in
time okay gu good move now her King is
free she did this very well then she
gets the King around and then somehow
she's going to sack somewhere King E6
and then here comes the sack no maybe go
King F7 and then go for yeah go for the
g king F7 wow you can't oh it's check
it's sh that was check oh
oh my goodness two
seconden oh my God anything is possible
what are you doing it's over wow Greg is
winning see it she grabs her head a
heartbreaker there oh my
goodness great oh we're going to show an
inant replay after the game but look at
this everybody the win for greet jotti
right here King G7 walked into the
diagonal of the bishop allowing F5 an
exclam point the only idea to save black
and not just saved him allowed him to
win the game that is a Swindle that will
go in the books unfortunately for robers
all those books behind her doesn't don't
help you when you're in the final
seconds of a game you're just nervous
you're stressed and what is this why is
there pawns on A4 and a55 this is some
what is
that and it is the bullet portion so it
makes sense you can do that you know but
yeah maybe she just
got man that game this game just like I
mean okay I'll be I'll be pissed too I
was completely winning got swindled
there man king G7 oh my goodness you
dirty dog you je that is crazy come on
Greg how do he do it and Greg's he's
seen it all right he's played for so
many years that he's found all sorts of
tactics to save the day but I don't like
his position Greg shiti with the white
pieces here is there like a G3 Knight G4
coming to a theater near you that could
deliver a checkm
attack Dam that's a nasty sequence
luckily the KN on C4 be hit now it's
yeah now it's sick it'll work see if she
sees it she went 94 though very
aggressive player so I think if she
works more on tatino tactics that is she
going to be spotting some nasty stuff
she might even go Knight F three she's
definitely looking eye in Knight oh it's
coming here it comes Knight of three you
better Mo your king don't block with
your face here Greg cuz it's definitely
very possible to block with your entire
face right now King H1 G3 anyway my
goodness I'm mating she G3 is coming so
it's good she didn't have to rush it but
now G3 is game over you're threatening m
one and after Pawn takes KN just not
playing
G3 okay maybe she just doesn't see it E8
is not
hanging
yeah check I mean maybe just A7 throw it
in there G G3 is complet winning chat
what you think chat come on chat Knight
F3 okay that shoot dang I think he just
getting mated anyway it doesn't matter
what you do I think he's just getting
mated like what do you have to look at
it's just getting it's just mate
everything's mate everything mate it
smell like mate everywhere if you look
like mate smell like mate yeah it's is
mate this is just delivering The
Knockout and just Queen G4 Queen G2
Queen G1 game over in elen robber's
favor and Greg he laughs he he's like
what am I supposed do otherwise I'll cry
right yeah exact I laugh about that one
she just like obliterated him in that
that was a very aggressive game and I
mean so many times she just had every
piece in the right position King Indian
attack here
nice okay so we see on the right hand
side of our screen D Sher he is up two
and a half half if he wins this game the
match is over this should be a draw for
Mary Arab which gives her life heading
into the bullet but if she BL ERS no
there's no way to blunder this anymore
that game will for sure be a draw which
means that maray has given up her final
Half Point she can't afford to give
another half point in the bullet
portion so there are some weird thing
okay yeah she knows what to do yeah yeah
she knows what to
do and yes the problem is the black king
needs on the right hand side of the
screen needs to be way further away from
that pawn because now after King G7 Rook
G1 check you just check the king back in
front of the pawn there's nowhere to go
so they're just maneuvering moving about
nothing to see there if you are Mary
she's not worried she found the right
move too as well me keep the king in
close proximity here and move the Rook
over and that's it yeah she found the
right drawing
technique what just happened oh my
goodness
into there's a bridge 106
Heil the
bridge you little you little devious the
fist pumps the waves oh my goodness I'm
not I'm just I got to find out where he
is if I'm if I'm her I'm like ah what
are you doing but him great job look at
the smiles that's a winner right there
that is a winner baby boy sip that you
deserve it great job I've never seen a
happier person in my life just to
Swindle somebody in a rook and hwn
ending but Cher gets a much needed match
Victory he has a legitimate shot and
this is our final game remaining of the
second set of matches and alen robers
James what has she been eating in the
last few games she's just going all out
for the attack against this poor King
I'm a I'm a big fan of her play very
aggressive I did like the Dutch games
yes okay the Dutch was uh you know it is
risky and things happen but at the same
time she just she just whipped up some
very aggressive chess here and a lot of
times if you're not able to handle this
which Greg is I think more of a
universal player I think he's more on a
positional side but a lot of times when
you meet an aggressive player like a
lean like this and we just keep
attacking you you're you're going to
have to keep defending and he was not
able to do it now here looks like look
at this Pawn Chain by the way like
beautiful Pawn chain please take it just
for the pawn chain bro like for the
memes look at this Pawn chain both
people have Pawn chains aiming in
opposite directions black is winning
because there's no threat for white and
this bishop can slide back to
six apparently there's nothing wait
Queen G oh wait what do we do now Knight
G6 F7 F7 oh my goodness Greg shotti
plunders Greg is yeah that's the rrap
take Rook takes Rook takes Rook Queen
takes Rook
F1 this got to be ajor she's too
accurate Rook F7 oh yeah yeah that works
too and Rook f8 oh my goodness get him
off the board get him off the board dub
dub and Greg was playing great defense
but I like to give credit where it's due
elen robers steals this game and the
match 4 to2 so what that means is all
four players are tied in a Leen robers
she's not betraying her emotions here
she's just kind of focused on the next
game but I have news for you Le there
are no more games in this match you have
beaten Greg shahadi you have beaten the
man the myth the legend himself Greg
shahadi you are on the board you're one
in one and that feels good because now
Greg is one in one and also Mary is one
in one it's anybody's game they all back
even basically so it's all about these
next few matches to see who is going to
get what how and when man this is crazy
so
far I know the win is now and we've
guaranteed that we are going to have to
have a tie break because uh we have all
four players with one match Victory I
love this cross table here you see some
higher numbers on the left hand side and
then you see some uh lower numbers there
as well because the players they're
beating one another alen robers lost to
Marb then she beats Greg shahadi D
Sheriff lost to Greg then beat Mary so
they're all beating each other and that
leaves us with one round to go James
pretty pumped aren't you oh I'm pretty
pumped absolutely 100% especially as
everybody is like there's no one coming
out like oh I'm winning all my matches
they like no you know they just stand in
there you ever seen a slap Fest like we
just oh and then they they slap you and
then it's just back and forth you hit me
I hit you and whoever is going to stand
last is going to win here so far so good
even matches here aggressive chest
blunders everywhere and good games
brilliancies guys uh this is fire I did
not expect it to go like this I thought
it would be one side it somewhere just
in nowh but it's all even it's all even
Robert the we is nowhere and that's
where you should go don't go anywhere
because James Knight will be right back
as group a here at the imcc continues we
have a between all the players you will
not want to miss who gets through see
you soon
[Music]
everybody just played an exciting game
and want to see if you got of brilliancy
or maybe where you could have improved
chess.com game review is just a click
away game review is a fast fun and
instructive guided review of your games
see your accuracy and your opponent's
accuracy check out the eval graph for an
instant overview and scroll down to see
how many great moves best moves blunders
and yes brilliancies you have played
learn from chess.com coach who gives
move explanation
opening statistics and shows you the
best lines of play with retry mistakes
you can get another shot at finding M
opportunities try game review today on
web iOS or
Android chess again no this is spell
chess do I dare read the instructions or
should I go in without reading them I
didn't read the rules this man is just
blundering what basically it's normal
chess but there two spells jump and
freeze the freeze is applied to a 3X3
area man this game is what freeze here
night check boom that's me oh that's
that's that's incredible stuff oh oh
freeze wait I froze my car a jump spell
which allows you to jump over a piece
and I'm setting up a win oh then black
would just freeze
me then I make a double threat you don't
have any freezes is left so if
here this is too hard wait once I get
the hang of this we're going to be
winning so many games though I can't
block with any of those pieces but I can
use this this and then
this raise this and then go
here yay I won let's go cannot take my
Bishop he cannot take my
Bop it's a nice feeling for when you
start understanding the game and you win
oh they resigned I never Li I think I'm
one of the greatest spell chess players
to ever play spell chest that was fun
I'm enjoying
[Music]
this
a
[Music]
a man now in control of his own destiny
is the weed sherff you see him here on
screen I'm not sure if he's praying or
getting ready by punching his other Palm
but D chair he should be happy with his
play and he's familiar to the chess.com
scene and audience because he is the
director of Polish content for chess.com
this is not scripted he's earning his
match victories but he is a prolific
chess content creator commentator and
author 40,000 plus followers on Twitch
if you're watching on Twitch go get his
channel a follow right now and he is a
recently minted I am James he got that I
am title just a year ago 2022 very
inspiring of course you can always do it
is I'm doing the same here man he
working I like that I like to see the
work and it's working right now I
remember playing him as an FM and I'm
like I remember seeing it I'm like wait
is that's an eye did he just and he did
he just got that shout out to Big DWI
darus he's uh you know feeling better
you know he's like everybody's even I
lost the first match won the second now
let's continue this winning thing I like
how that
feels there is no I in team but there's
an i in I IM and an ion win and D
Sheriff just won that second match and
as we look at the standings for group a
it looks like a lot of the same because
we see that each player has a match
Victory it doesn't matter if you're
first through fourth here because you
are tied up you control your destiny you
need to win your upcoming match and then
you're going to have to win a tie break
so as we look forward to our round three
matchups in group a it's Greg shahadi
versus Mary arabid it's elen robers
against the wi chair James when you
first look at the matchups who do you
think is
favored that's a great question here I
think it actually favors you know what
DED like DED and alen are right now
their their momentum is there they have
that momentum so having these next
matches here you know that momentum
really matters now obviously you don't
let it get to your head and just you
know relax the days ago you still have a
job to do but of course that momentum of
you winning it feels good you want to do
it again and you want to lock in if I'm
merry here on the screen I'm going to
stay locked in and stay focused yes I
lost but it's not over I got another
mask to do and let's see what we can do
in this
one and Mary Arab won her Opening match
against elen robers suffered defeat at
the hands of D sheriff and in the IMC
all players do have chances we weren't
lying to you we were serious that it
doesn't matter if you're the lowest rate
on paper you got a shot so D sherff he
did beat Mary AABB but she beat Elaine
robers who beat Greg chiadi so they're
just beating each other right now and
it's one match Victory one loss for all
the players James I don't know who is
going to win this group I think that
Greg and Mary that's a tossup match to
me yeah I think it's the same here in
fact um if if Greg can keep composed or
if Mary can strike you know when the
Iron's High here it depends uh on what
positions you get it really is a tossup
50/50 for sure in that match I think in
the elen match with that weed there DED
I think maybe has a slight maybe like
psych Edge he just feels good he's
pumped you know I won that right um but
alen is very ferocious as we saw what
she did to Greg in those aggressive
games there so if she keeps that up I
mean she may be running through every if
they're not able to defend what's coming
at
them right and D we saw how happy he was
he showed that to the audience and alen
she was stoic but she did win a very
important match against Greg shahadi and
here we go the left hand side of our
screens we see Greg shahadi and Mary
arabid on the right hand side of our
screen we have alen robers with the
white pieces against the weed cherub and
so James as we look Sicilians Galore
both matchups feature that trusty
opening yeah I actually I mean I'm a big
fan of Sicilian from both sides so and
and on the right there I'm actually a
fan more of D's position because now we
have the F5 push and I remember looking
at um some some files on this from the
black side and this is very fun for
black to play yes of course it looks
kind of crazy and he can Castle which he
does but F5 is going to be coming and
this is the dynamicism that you may see
in um in the snov Sicilian maybe even a
D5 here like there are lots of things
that can happen in this position like
with F5 and D5 are coming at some point
might be D5 right now allow a rook to D1
and maybe play Knight E7 and just really
push D5 F5 and E5 are squares here so I
think that's a really Dynamic game and
then in the other game there of course
this was some type of timeing off with
the queen F3 to G3 I think giri
recommends that now and his course his
newer stuff uh so you know it's pretty
nice I like White's positions usually in
this because it feels like I can just
press forward with F4 E5 and black needs
to know what they're doing a lot
I'm with you I think that both of these
games are very rich they will be
tactical and we see that on the right
hand side of your screen the re sherff
deep in thought on the left hand side
there is an advantage for Greg shot out
of the opening but he didn't play the
correct move you just see the eval bar
slide down H4 was maybe a move too slow
and it takes away F4 because you've
permanently handed the G4 Square over to
Black if you do push the F Pawn so Greg
he's playing a little bit too cautiously
it's not helping him out according to
the evaluation bar and the right side
they're throwing caution to the wind I
mean look at alen look at D over there
James let's go right into that game
between alen robers and dared Cher
because that one is looking oh so spicy
yeah this is one of the this is what
makes the fres nikov Sicilian so fun to
play is these lines right here there are
certain lines like for instance the one
where where Greg played against theed
and queen was on D3 and then pawns on C4
and E4 those aren't as fun cuz it's
super positional but the Tactical ones
the Tactical ones that you get out of
these FES off cilian like this one it
suits really both of them cuz it lean me
it's strong and aggressive as she is but
then also the we playing a very
aggressive type opening here F5 now we
have all three of these pawns up here
looking pretty nice right pretty solid
stuff so all the pawns are here it's
pretty pretty good pretty good I mean I
like stuff like E4 coming maybe even
Bishop F7 at some point um we do have to
figure out what to do with this pin and
f5's on the board look at this Bishop
being attacked
twice and it's good point you called for
this a while ago the pawns are storming
for black but that D5 Pawn can be tender
with that Knight on C2 aiming towards
that B4 square if you have to play E4 as
black you give up the D4 Square there
are always consequences to pawn pushes
so F4 might be a third idea for black
but it's never easy to open up the G
file in front of your own King so I
don't know what black should do you look
at the he's a chess player through and
through he put his hands on his heads
he's trying to tune out the rest of the
world but James I think we can both
acknowledge it's a difficult position
for both sides not exactly clear which
Pawn to move 100% it's hard to figure
that out here maybe you just move the
bishop back and just kind of figure out
something else from there someone asked
in the chat why is ky not playing I was
not playing because I played last year
great question I played last year and I
made it to the finals I won three
matches back to back to back so I really
kind of proved a lot so I just didn't
care as much to play this year um
because I just like I made it to the
finals so I felt really good about
but at the same time um it I don't want
to cut you off why you lying you just
wanted to commentate with me that's the
real reason just tell everybody exactly
right you're right bro you're right
that's exactly why I just wanted to I
just wanted to commentate with with
Robert chess Robert chess we might as
well just call him that by now Robert
chess guys okay Knight D5 this is a
Wicked Game what is going on right now
bro he took the pawn and like I don't
know what to actually make of this
position engine says equal equal what
like what are you talking about Rook at
five what the I don't know what to make
of this as well like I mean there's yeah
there's all of tactics and the A8 Rook
is loose and that Queen on D wait Knight
of six check you pointed this out maybe
it's
Queen I take with check though what the
heck is this he it's
PL okay we're going to have some fun
here maybe Rook takes F6 takes the
bishop and then queen queen
H6
right A G
again wait there might be rookie five
check at the end of that though James
the white king is serious
trouble this is tough I think black's
winning EV bar say is the
same because Rook e five an Unstoppable
threat wow man this queen is like you
don't have any rookie five check after
check it's coming like you have to move
the queen again you have to move the
queen again Queen F3 you have to I think
I think white can legally Castle but
then comes Rook G8 Rook G5 and you just
resign anyway so goodness uh that's a
problem he's legally exactly he can
Castle Rook G8 Rook G5 quite annoying
Queen E2 Rook E5 is a bare minimum you
can play you can also have Bishop C4 I
you got like every move works here wow
what a queen sacrifice bro I think D
Sheri as you said he needed that warmup
and now that he's warmed up he's on fire
the games that he's playing they're
ferocious they're tactical he's afraid
of nobody and he can deliver what is
going to be a devastating first round to
alen robers here there might be like an
F3 oh my gosh just give this man his
flowers I'm going to give him the round
of applause I'm going to give him the
thumbs up there he can do no wrong right
now they're the fireworks they're on
display and they're for it the we chair
yeah he just he he's definitely going
crazy right now as the fireworks so yeah
that's funny yeah but it actually it
worked I mean this man had the warmup
he's feeling good you can tell from the
strides here and he's playing really
strong chess right now wow and alen
being as strong as see as she is I mean
he just played a very great game that's
fresh nikov was very Wicked it's very
ferocious opening that from both sides
here if the positional rout I think is
the most annoying to face as if you're
playing a fresh nikov like how Greg
played it against him in the first round
in the first match so playing it in the
way that they want is like n off's you
know best day ever like that's what you
want you want this type of position in
his rashnikov not what you got you know
game one or two of a first game with
Greg versus
de truly a sick game right now from
diten he should be able to land that
final decisive blow but that Knight on
C2 is going to work its way into E3 at
least she is staying alive for now and
with the black king on F7 I don't even
know how long there will be some oh wait
Rook h8 traps the queen doesn't it or
Rook H4 same deal my goodness Rook H4
yikes just hit hit the button yeah just
start a new game there it is man look I
love his
celebration ah let's go we going to the
championship bro you got two more games
bro get back out there all right you
right coach you right coach you
right I do love it it's just a little
clap and then he's right back at it but
a win for the re sheriff and then the
left hand side of her screen it's still
game one between Greg chiadi and Mary
arabid and let's be honest about this
position Mary arabid is is having all of
the fun 100% of it for her because that
King on B1 uh-uh unhappy the King on G8
that's like on another planet it's safe
it's tucked away over here there's not a
fear in the world for it the key though
is being precise if you play A3 and then
white plays B3 maybe you don't have the
attack that you thought you did so be
careful when you push your pawns
advancing them to the enemy King that is
definitely something to pay attention to
here is like as you noticed it's on
another planet that's exactly right like
trying to get get to that King is just
not happening the pawn the Knight on G4
Pawn on H5 with that Outpost there I
when you play F5 I go E5 this is a
sicilian player's dream here as like my
king is very safe I have B4 and A4 both
Rooks on the files here it's just a
matter of time but it has to be precise
CU things can happen obviously as we've
seen in many games but here you
definitely take black all the day even
the engine likes it as well we just have
to find the right way to finish this off
A6 is hanging now have to deal with it
yeah blending your Rook on A6 that would
not be a good way of going for victory
and I'm looking at the clock both
players approaching that one minute Mark
Greg a little bit behind on time here I
like just moving The Rook Rook A5 as you
mentioned the Rooks are both on good
files doubling the Rooks into what your
own Pawn that doesn't look too appealing
to my eyes so Rook A5 controlling that
fifth Rank and queen A5 instead all
right same idea and watch out for an
idea like B3 things are happening here
it's about to heat up it's about to heat
up there may be an idea of clearing the
way for the Knight to come to C5 to help
with the B3 push at some point but now
that's exactly why she play Queen A5 it
makes sense she cleared the way she
wants to get another piece into the game
um mean meaning the Knight but you can't
play B3 without hanging the queen so you
are going to have to move the Queen Once
Again White's trying to set up E5 E5
could be a shot in the dark and like you
just go for for everything Magnus just
lost a game today with something similar
uh loow into the 2500 everybody going
crazy we're like this sacrifice on F7
happened and it was just a Wicked Game
you better be very careful here on both
sides obviously here but anything can
happen A3 any A3 and I think you're
right when you say anything can happen
cuz James with the attack black is in
good shape but if the Queens come off
the board Black's in big trouble this B3
Pawn will be a long-term weakness if you
trade every piece except for the king of
Pawns white is winning so that is what
Greg has to look forward to but I'm
looking at his clock down under 30
seconds with your King on B1 how do you
survive a position like this yeah he's
especially after a sacrifice that just
feels like you should just do it you
know there's a game with Fabiano playing
white versus nepo with black pieces he
plays yeah the nepo game you you know
what I mean Rook takes A3 right that was
a sick game so I mean it was uh same
idea Rook takes A3 takes I think the
Rook is on B8 and you play like Knight
A4 and into C3 which is really sick
here okay so E5 the pawn was captured
and Knight takes B3 now but you know
it's the bad news for white you got rid
of one issue there's not going to be a
checkmate with a rook sack on A3 but
you've open whoa she goes for anyway I
believe this oh man I understand I feel
it sack first think later he believed in
it to check check but oh takes and uh
wow what's happening takes but there's
chaos yeah right chaos3 93 that was the
sick tactic ever and then check and the
queen would be lost yeah that was hard
to F spot especially with no time here
she ain't got no time she got one second
two seconds now she realizes what
happened shakes her head let's be let's
be honest James if you find 93 check we
might have a different kind of problem
no one's finding 93 check not Hikaru not
Magnus nobody that move was sick nasty
and Greg he I want to say he earned that
Victory but I think Mary she's the one
who's to look at the game be like I
spoiled a golden opportunity oh man
Knight E3 with Rook at Rook C8 check
there is really hard to find especially
in that type of uh situation with the
time there but Greg gets a win he feels
it better he feels a little bit better
yeah he feels a little bit better so now
we just reset what DED over there with
some emotions what is going on in that
game why is he getting so emotional I
mean looks like a good position for DED
on the right hand side of our screen on
the left hand side we have a grunfeld so
that's going to be a bit slower to move
forward let's go to the right hand game
because we just saw the eval bar go all
the way up which means that DED might
have a winning move in this position
James and I got to go Knight H6 into H6
Knight H6 sack yeah I like that's
exactly what I'm looking at Knight H6
maybe Sack or maybe F5 Knight H6
something like that knight6 is there and
maybe F5 because you have to go King G7
or f8 and then F5 or Knight takes F7
these both feel really good F5 yeah F5
is really strong and there it is
really strong move bro who what happened
do we just like leveled up in like the
last two matches he's just a whole
different player bro he's just a whole
different player F5 with takes is coming
I mean are you kidding me Rook F7 I can
sack now I can draw more arrows I did go
to the school of hikaro bro like it is
definitely about to get Wicked in here
my guy like this is very serious stuff
Knight takes F7 now looks super strong
cuz that The Rook takes Pawn takes G6
and entire position is collapsing your
king is going to get checkm this is over
yeah this is a sick game bro what was
this was a
sicilian oh it's sevening and Paulson
okay six some time off basically
wow yeah he he's snapping now he's he
just zoned in like he got that warm up
he lost the first match then he won his
second one he was like I can win this I
can do this and then when you that's all
it takes is a little belief in yourself
and some good chess moves and you you're
on your way to
Greatness he should be a believer right
now it looks like there's nothing
stopping him oh wait a second the idea I
don't even know what you follow up with
I have no idea that's just yeah I have
no idea bro cuz you I don't even know
your followup what is your followup yeah
he closed the position down he could
have ripped that black king to shreds
but instead he closed the position and
James I'm going to be honest I'm looking
at this position here the F7 Pawn is
defended I don't see a way to create
another attack against anything and I
feel like black could turn this game
around in just the next few moves I
thought bishop2 as well but the E5 Pawn
is hanging and then we take take I mean
I guess in game might be better but then
there might be a rook D2 at the end of
everything hitting G2 and then C2
hanging like what is going on bro Queen
takes E5 KN on H6 takes takes Tak
freezes E2 E2 yeah James it freezes all
of Black's pieces so maybe he actually
is smarter than all of us put together
because there's no to defend that F7
pawn and you're just stuck in place and
now after the queen trade take the
Knight on H5 take on E5 put your Rook on
G5 put your Rook on G7 can you actually
stop any of this takes takes yeah that's
pretty sick Rook takes E5 I was thinking
he can go Rook D2 here but F7 does hang
and then after King G8 you go Knight H6
which he goes for it's logical but of
course it makes sense cuz you don't want
to sit around James I hate to interrupt
you Rook G5 Rook f8 Rook G8 check
man don't do this no Robert don't do it
oh my goodness there are kids watching
Robert oh man you dirty dog that's a
nasty M Rook G5 Rook G8 Knight F7 he's
going for it Rook G8 and Knight F7
smothered with some gravy oh my goodness
this is about to be made bro we is she
going
spotted he can't believe G Rook G8 Rook
G8 oh he missed it oh he missed it but
it's a resi though and I guess Rook G8
is like you know you played anyway but
man show that J show show the
fans you got to show the fans real quick
right oh my goodness Rook G8 guys Rook
takes oh and Knight of seven was going
to be made there guys you know they you
know to right they just said they was
like oh K he about to show it get it off
the screen before we get in trouble over
here so they didn't want y'all to see it
but you can go back and see that guys
Richie eight Knight of s Jack
man so two nothing in the Sheriff's
favor so for alen robers not the start
that she wanted out of this match and
the left hand side of her screen we're
still only in the second game between
Mary arabid and Greg Jihadi and James
when I look at a position like the one
on the left hand side of the screen
black is up a pawn but white has the
best Pawn on the board that pawn on D6
is a huge Thorn In Black side it's a
passer it's quite Advanced only two
squares away from
promotion that is a very nice Pawn there
it reminds you of some type of grunfeld
in fact
um may be what it was but it is
definitely that D Pawn is probably the
most annoying Pawn ever in fact yes it's
equal you're like equal what like what
are you talking about look at the
Bishops look at the pass D Pawn like
you're taking white all day because of
this it feels better black has two pass
pawns but they are way far away from
doing anything at all so you know I do
like white here but that maybe we have
like a sack on B4 Play Bishop C6 at some
point but we need to be correct whose
move is it it is on Mary she plays King
G2 little just like you know well your
move pass pass what are you going to
do and H6 is the answer from Greg he
wants G5 to get this D6 Pawn but H4 was
the obvious reply and there could be
some vulnerability for this black king
you can't move this bishop CU then H6
will fall so I would be worried if I'm
Greg here especially given that both
players have two and a half minutes and
James I saw the corner in my eyes
something weird is happening with DED
and alen and D seems upset he does not
hide his emotions at all he'd be a very
bad poker
player you're right you're like yeah I
got double A oh I'm winning I'm going to
bet you know I'm fing like I'm just
going to fold you're not getting none of
my money bro like I'm gonna get all
yours but yeah 100% he definitely shows
his emotions uh Bishop to D4 happened
here he doesn't like the move engine
doesn't either here isn't the engine
doesn't either maybe there's a knight A4
or something there and okay Greg
responds with H5 look at the weak pawns
though or weaknesses around the K there
may be even a G4 in there myself but
have to be
careful I liked your idea of Rook takes
B4 Pawn takes and Bishop C6 on the left
hand side of your screens we're drawing
it with arrows that would help push this
pass Pawn forward I think that was a
great opportunity for Mary and if I'm
Greg here I'm trying to figure out how
to stop that at all costs I do not want
to see that pawn get to the seventh rank
Bishop E5 comes to mind let's try to
swap off some pieces I don't think
Mary's afraid of that either though
because the black king is weaker without
the bishop sitting in front of
it yeah it's uh I do not want to trade
Bishops too much um but definitely dark
Square Bishop for sure may maybe I can
go Queen F6 and try to make some things
happen but the more trades that happen I
think my Pawn gets weaker and those
pawns get stronger being and see there
it's just hard to like that Knight on B4
is such a nuisance like you can't really
I can't get to the seventh rank as I'm
trying to Bishop G5 happens though
trying to provoke a weakness if not
maybe I wiggle in
E7
okay so both games here look at that on
the right hand side of our screen are B4
given an exclamation point from elen
she's just gaining space against the
weed on the queen side and on the left
hand side of our screen we see that kind
of the status quo continues between Mary
and Greg and it's only the second game
of their match so a draw is not the
worst thing in the world for Mary but on
the right hand side of our screen alen
needs to win you can't afford to give
too many points at this stage of the
match and Rook da given a question mark
it looks like elen has a very promising
position yeah definitely I mean it looks
like some type of well okay we could say
Italian game but it's really not I mean
the knight's on G3 like pawns you have
the space of the Italian game which
should say that you get with the pawns
when you push C3 B4 and A4 and now up to
A5 lots of space look at the nice this
is positional dominance I think here D5
Square F5 Square now I can move my
Bishop out maybe to C4 D3 Maybe just put
a knight on F5 yeah Bishop D3 probably
first just to to defend my Pawn on e4
and then really go into F5 at some point
could be really nice so we do want to do
and Bishop developed makes sense makes
sense Bishop E6 yeah that's why I like
Bishop D3 a little bit better but guess
he wanted to stops maybe some D5 pushes
Bishop D5 is a nice
move Bishop D5 looks great on the right
hand side of the screen on the left hand
side well there just a bishop dance a
bishop and Rook dance where Mary on the
left hand side of our screens keeps
bringing her Bishop back to defend this
pawn and now Greg says wait a second let
me interpose on the diagonal I'm willing
to trade off pieces because guess what
black is up a pawn Jam I don't know if
anyone else knows that secret but black
is a pawn ahead although white has the
most promising Pawn this D6 Pawn I
actually did forget about that sometimes
you're just like man the position just
looks so good for some somebody that you
just forget the material and that's
exactly I was like yeah he is a Pawn wow
I didn't even see that you know but this
D6 Pawn is like yeah I am the alpha here
I am just the strongest Pawn on the
board right now G4 it's played that is
an aggressive move you might be able to
take and play F5 but then that weakens
the king I would love for you to do that
F5 he plays it Bishop F3 so now I have
Rook takes B4 up to Bishop D5 in some
type of cases I have a H5 looming you
know there's some things King G7
beautiful move from
Greg okay let's dive into the game
between Mary and Greg just because a
Mary arabid down under now about to be
15 seconds but that black king looks
wide open here she's trying to make her
decision does she play H5 does she bring
a rook to the G file can't she afford to
allow this Knight to D4 she allows it
but James Knight D4 is she going to sack
The Exchange and try to pick up this
Pawn in the center you know what I
wouldn't even think twice about it cuz I
can also take on B6 too as well and she
plays it takes takes and then I might go
H6 just because it's there it looks nice
and if you take there's mate you know
Rook check Queen G5 Queen H4 mate really
sick mate there so it's a very nasty
move I mean I could just open up the
game no no I don't want to open up the
game though Bishop D5 with some threats
of maybe bishop G8 but I mean h i don't
really want to go there she does it
though yeah this is a draw now this is
just like hopefully I can draw this like
hope I can draw three seconds she gets
that move off a 2.1 left queen B7 check
Queen D5 so white isn't in danger of
getting checkmated the queen would
likely land on D7 to force the Queens
off the board so that's the good news
for Mary here she has to like Queen D7
she doesn't Queen G2
check oh that's got to be a rap that's
got to be got to be cooking he's cooking
now cook let him cook let him Rook chat
let him Rook let him Rook check King
three check and yeah yeah just getting
made it somehow it's got to be here come
all the pieces Queen B1 and then it's a
ladder checkm you don't see the ladder
like this very often but greig jotti
takes game two James unfort
slip for Mary there she needed to trade
the Queens but when her King was unsafe
she failed to do so and she suffered the
consequences and in the other game James
let's dive into that one because D Cher
is in charge oh until that move we got
here and he let his Advantage go away I
think he's fine with the draw he's like
yeah I mean I can push you know I'm
going push here as much as I can some
type of deeski theoretical game that he
must have missed here F3 doesn't work
wow that's a sick move G3 was an
excellent move
U maybe King E5 check and apparently
it's winning now I don't know how that
was oh King C2 King C2 she went the with
King wow she miss R G6 she she missed
two different wins and she might still
win this game but you need to find the
moments here Rook D7 there's also no
time there no
time yeah James all King and pwn games
would be winning because the black king
would have to go over the sea file now
she's just winning directly team d8 and
that's that o and she found a way to win
it very strong yeah this is GG well just
hit the button there start the new one
maybe going for some draw techniques oh
there was a checkm
one it's okay as I say when you see
Checkmate look for better James she
stole that game now it's only a onepoint
spread only a onepoint spread of course
but got to bounce back if I am the wi
here and try to be trying to do what I
can but he's the D okay Dutch again you
have another Dutch here I go H4 yeah you
know what's funny this is like my jaava
course is coming out is I be I just cook
the Dutch like all the time so this is
like really fun to see really fun but
this s he played it completely
differently cuz I'm supposed to have
like I'm not supposed to give up the E4
Pawn so I'm not really the biggest fan
of we position right now but it is very
playable she has a nice at least they're
setup enter entertaining us James where
DED and alen they're holding absolutely
nothing back they're playing Fighting
Chess each and every game and that's on
the right hand side of our screen on the
left hand side we have a more closed
battle between Greg and Mary so Greg has
given Mary a bunch of space namely this
Pawn on e4 but the position is closed
there's not open files nothing to work
with just yet and after Bishop takes
Pawn takes this E4 Pawn may go from
strength to weakness in the near future
so I think Greg is very happy about his
match
situation yeah Greg definitely he like I
think think he was doing better in the
for so far from the matches we've seen
he's been doing better in the positional
games more than the Tactical ones but
then of course he was able to bounce
back like in the with in the defensive
tactical which is not even a word but
today it's how it is in the defense
tactical he was doing very good like
defending with and have finding tactics
but then when he's like you know on the
attack it just wasn't working for him so
much but getting good positions weren't
really a problem so he is getting some
good positions as long as he's playing
good openings and Etc do like to space
he has here and also the option of
taking on G4 at the right moment when we
want to kind of playing on both sides of
the
board yeah it's just a Clos lock down
position if Bishop takes G4 Pawn takes
G4 that does open a file for the black
rook and this tension not really going
anywhere of course black can retreat but
you're doing just that you're retreating
how are you going to play for a win from
there so Greg happy with the solid
approach he's not risking anything at
the moment and I think he's doing just
fine no weaknesses to speak of but this
is very different from the other game so
I do think that we should zoom out for a
second as Greg finally advances upon we
have to go to the other game we simply
must that one is crazy man come on bro
it's King on F2 he playing an
accelerated decelerated um exchanged uh
you know delayed bone Cloud here as you
see look at the King on F3 guys look at
the King on F3 this is ridiculous but he
still he's still a pece chain so DED his
King is way up there but he's up a minor
piece a knight and I think that alen's
in huge trouble our position looked
really good earlier now it's just
lost yeah I
mean it's just lost bro my kings are
have three like what just lost yeah it's
just and it really is like I mean you're
up to piece here there are some tricks
with like Rook E3 you have to watch all
the little tricks here she's a trickster
and very strong because there's a rook
E3 with Bishop C5 that could be scary
with a rook coming over to E8 in some
cases Rook H5 there is a rook E3 played
King takes Bishop C5 check not playable
because of uh King back to F3 so we do
check do we go Queen F3 but then there's
a check oh 96 there's a
96 King up to the middle of the board I
would put it in the middle of the board
Robert I would do it I promise you I
would put my king right here and go all
crazy I would look in the camera too on
Zoom if I was like put the King on e4
and just look in the camera and then
play 96 that would be so sweet but and
then will be absolutely 100% correct
that youve found all the tactics the
tatinos I know you've been working on
them and now white is up a rook so good
good spot for Rook E3 check the only try
for a lean but even better spot with a
knight blocking on the line with Knight
E6 the king is safe there's not even a
single check that makes sense for black
the queen and Rook are defended the
second Rook is about to join and
resignation time look at
D my king was on E3 look at him wiping
his he price knees weak palms are sweaty
right like you know he's just uh very
very hype over that one wiping his hands
real quick breathe that was an intense
game and I think is that three now yeah
he's half a point away wow he's in the
zone locked
in wow okay so D Sheriff only needs a
draw that's on the right hand side of
your screen it's bullet chest draws are
not very likely in that time control and
look at the left hand side Greg shahadi
up two to nothing but I don't think he's
going to keep that two-point lead for
long it looks like his position is
absolutely falling apart with G takes F2
check there might be a rook takes B3 at
any moment with C4 falling o I think
just tactics everywhere and they're all
in Mary's favor absolutely of course let
me see her time because she has been
really in a lot of time trouble I think
if we had to talk about one thing that
she's just been having trouble with is
her time here she's actually up time
which is really good so that helps
because like you know she was just Lo
winning positions fumbled you know
losing or almost losing on times so if
she can stay up on time here and you
know really close the gap she should be
able to win this game but if time does
get lower Greg is definitely getting
lower on time for sure she should be
able to close this out unless she gets
really low on time look at these pawns I
mean if you can't win with those pawns
there that would be really disappointing
and now it's opposite C Bishops but she
has this protected Pawn on F2 and if you
take on G3 you're probably get
checkmated so that's why gron puts his
Rooks to H1 but it's not threatening
anything we up with the left hand side
of your screen every body this Rook on
H1 open file that's great it's not going
anywhere and Rook d8 was played you
could probably swap but I would play
Rook D4 so when the capture happens I
would take with the pawn and get another
passer very nice very nice get another
passer there Rook D2 okay Bishop D2 look
cleverness that's clever he look look
him shake his head all hard like what is
that I guess cuz he won a bishop e she
won a bishop E1 Bishop act back to F1
played apparently it's just losing all
the way King takes G3 though oh there's
a
a little check check oh behind the pawn
and look at that oh my goodness like her
time every time bro this is this is the
story of her today like she just gets
lower on time and then it starts to
Fumble of course it does happen you know
to the best of us when you get lower on
time it's harder to play and now look at
this position Greg may be
holding he's getting close to holding
this game the good news for her is two
separate pass pawns and that a pawn is
hard to stop but King D5 C6 is it zuk
swong you G3 Rook G3 oh that was check R
G3 that's a sick check my goodness n not
SPL you're not looking at that one
especially now with 5 Seconds on the
clock here check and is he winning C7 is
coming at some point there it is how do
you stop it what are you supposed to do
Robert why is it not over it's over why
was it not over I don't know why it
wasn't yeah that's
crazy and you see Greg chotti shake his
head he cannot believe he not just
survived but one and he is a half point
away from advancing as is D sheriff and
it looks like alen robers she just w a
queen he blundered his Queen James bro
let's back we have time to go back to
that let me see real quick oh he just
played Queen Chad look at this this is
this is too locked in he put the queen
on the Square it wasn't like a capture
type of thing it was more like here's my
queen sorry for the inconvenience like
he just gave me the queen for free here
as the just kind of tilted there I don't
know know what that was but he just gave
up a queen very uncharacteristic all he
needs is a half
point and now if alen wins we have extra
time in their match whereas Greg chotti
up three to nothing so it's very likely
that Greg will be one of the players
duking it out to move on to the
semi-finals in the IMC the group stage
is all play all Greg took down DED lost
to elen now is about to beat Mary
arabizi unless she can go on a win
streak but let's focus here where DED
cheriff only needs a draw and the good
news James if you're an Leen robers fan
is it seems like she doesn't know how to
play for a draw she's always playing
Fighting Chess I love her chess bro I
ain't going to lie yeah I love her chess
we definitely going to have to like you
know do some training sessions together
and just talk about tactics only and
that's the best chess ever so yeah cuz
she's really strong obviously very
ferocious love that style of play here
she doesn't know how to draw so this is
she's like you know hey one way or the
other we're going to get the job done
here she needs a dub and all D needs is
a draw even wait isn't it just Queen
F7 oh what happened on what yeah you
know what I think it might be a case of
like results oriented I know I need a
draw and like actually had I had it from
my first I am Norm like I was half a
point away and then lost the last game
all I needed was a draw but I was
playing great until then like knowing
that you just need that sometimes you
play a little bit differently psych wise
so you you just can't think about that
result you have to play
the board he seems to be okay now looks
like he's
recovered he's doing very well but the
thing about a position like this that
black has the light scored Bishop white
has an extra Pawn is you see ghost you
see how black can win but D5 right now
would be a pretty sick move because all
the weed needs is a draw so if he can
trade off some pieces D5 you take with a
queen Knight E look at this fine d weed
when he is in form when he's not scaring
himself when he's not letting his
emotions get the best of him he might be
playing the best chess of the four today
right I like it I definitely I I agree
with that 100% after Bishop takes D5 I
think there's a rook D1 with the idea of
Rook takes D5 so she goes Bishop H3 says
you know I don't want to deal with any
of that Rook D1 anyway Rook E8 that's
kind of annoying I'm not going to lie
that's a very annoying move Queen D4 and
apparently it's already winning Queen
f53 what how do you stop Queen F3 ooh uh
o Queen
C3 he plays it
Queen e oh my goodness and I have
nothing Queen E2 and like I'm going hit
the button in a minute oh wait but I'm
okay Queen F3 D2 Rook E2 ight E7 yeah
that's it it's not even a good check
Knight E7 wow look at that and there oh
my goodness yeah yeah yeah this is how
you mess up things it happens all the
way it happens all the
time man look from being half a point
away and that means we get everyone's
favorite or least favorite it's kind of
divisive we get armagedon so they are
going uh to I think move to tiebreak and
they'll make their bids and so while
this match is still going the one
between Mary and Greg I'm looking at
this game here and Greg is unhappy Mary
has the advantage according to the eval
bar so that's the left hand side of your
screen she has a good chance to get on
the scoreboard
you know what she had that the last game
too so more more for me it's more like
can she control the time and and convert
cuz that is the problem that we've been
seeing she's been having winning
positions every match actually in fact
she's had some positions where oh she
about to clean up shop but then we look
around and the time's done now here this
is a huge time Edge I don't see I mean
you have to win this one like we just
have to like as marry here or else it's
just we have no shot if we can't win
this one we have so much time the
position is better it's going to be a
really rough rough day um for Mary here
but I think I think she's just easy in
the driver seat here should be an easy
game don't get too low in time and Greg
gives away the B7 Pawn just getting some
activity for his own pieces Rook takes
F7 that's how you blunder the bishop
will take the Knight removing the guard
of that piece so if you are mared you
could probably just trade Rooks or you
could think about doubling your Rooks to
replace the first Rook with the second
and yeah Greg's in very very big trouble
here he's just down upon it's a Healthy
Advantage on the clock on the board for
Mary
arabid 100% she needs to get on the
board here and it could mean shoot
anything can happen as we just saw we
thought the wi was just going to walk
away with it but Leen says never mind as
she wins two backto back games very
crucial to now having it you know uh be
a tie break unbelievable there that's a
tie break there where D thought he he
just had it here Mary needs to get on
the board and then she does have chances
it is possible to go another two in a
row there to tie the score and do the
same thing if you look at this position
it's miserable for black because you
can't move your pieces you move the Rook
this Rook should be able to slide to A7
but then Rook C6 maybe Greg is setting
up a type of Fortress I don't think it
really works because the bishop will
slide around to F6 it should be an
attack for White against this black king
oh gives up a pawn though he definitely
just gave up a pawn and then I can also
go Rook A8 um I I mean there's some
mating ideas here yeah okay Rook F7 yeah
you might be getting mated bro it might
be a H4 Rook G7 works like everything
works here Rook G7 King G4 is mating
like somehow
there there is apparently a Checkmate
and four moves and King G4 wasn't it but
ah bishop h8 and Rook to F6 is
made that's Bishop h8 bro come on dog
that's the puzzle R number 61 like in
survival something stupid like B of ha
bro who plays is that that's so
funny well she did not see the Checkmate
but she's also up several pawns though
Knight G2 it doesn't force a draw King
can go back to H what if H3 you play H3
yourself and that would be gross they
are mating oh Rook C2 no H3 19 kiding me
I'm out Robert you on your own bro I
can't believe this oh my goodness James
from Mary she cannot afford a draw that
allows Greg to win the match and if you
play H3 it's mate if you play King H3
Knight G 4 threatens that same
Checkmate oh but app Knight G4 was the
wrong Square because Rook G7 and take
this Knight the only way for white to
survive so James Knight G4 was wrong
Knight F1 was the correct Square this is
ridiculous I mean I I had heard for
winning this 100% there was no way Greg
was getting out of this Greg is doing
something I don't understand how is he
doing this how every game every game
triple pawns here I got the trips got
the trips there o
E6 that was so nice that was so nice but
there's just nothing there's just
nothing now Black's winning how do you
win this game
Robert how does he like I think the way
you win is what we saw and there is no
other possible way Mary arabid down
three points even if she won it still
would have been tough for her but Greg
chiadi is going to be one of the players
squaring off for a shot in the
semi-finals wow I am baffled by that
she's such a strong player but see the
time every game it has been her time if
she gets that under control I mean she's
just going to be a force to be reckoned
with but here he is Greg he's like
talking yeah I know I was playing like
trash yeah it's all good we made it
though yeah uhuh yeah I know right sh we
made
it and gr makes it through look at that
yeah for Greg shahadi he was worse in
the majority of those games against Mary
arabid but he was resilient he always
put up a fight and we know he's one of
the contestants who will be in a tie
break to go to the semi-finals we have
the bids in for Armageddon alen robers
bid four minutes D chair bid 3 minutes
and 30 seconds so D wins the bid he gets
the black pieces he gets 3 minutes and
30 seconds to alen's 5 minutes James
that's a huge time disparity I would
rather have white pieces in a minute and
a half lead I'm the same I'm the same
and especially I mean I play so much
online chess so much fast chess bullet
in 30 second every night so we we're
fast we quick we play a lot of Chess and
I'm like hey you know what look I got
five minutes and the white piece you got
330 no increment yes I'm going to take
white here and usually I am the one to
take the black pieces in Armageddon or
like in the in the tie breaks usually I
am a fan of having the black pieces cuz
if you draw you win you know but having
that low time it can cause for you to
make mistakes really fast and not have
enough time to recover or think about
what to to do even if you may have the
kill shot having 3:30 on the clock this
could be
tough this will be tough and one famous
example of bidding too low was vishan an
against Pavo pankratov in the chess.com
Global Championship a year ago it was a
huge lead for pankar on the clock vishy
had to play too quickly for his own good
and in this game we have a maroi bind
Sicilian James when you have a huge lead
on the clock do you think it's smart to
keep the position closed like alen is
doing M that's a great question I think
yes um to keep it closed or play
something that you know in and out but
also I do like this this closed type of
position that we have here because it's
just solid you're going to have to
maneuver things it's going to take a
long time but the problem with that is
that if it's too solid and then you
start trading pieces black will get
exactly what they want which is a
position it could be draw like and when
that happens I mean it could be a
problem like because black wins if we
draw you know only time in chess where a
draw equals a win will be right now so
you know it it could happen but this is
far from a draw now because it did open
up this was a maroxy bind but now I mean
where's the bind and I think black's
already better here you got Knight D4
coming in like you this is not a maroxy
b you never let this happen so white
already is uh behind a little bit I
think yeah I don't see the bind anymore
as you're pointing out all I see is that
black pieces are bound for the dark
squares in the king side Queen H4 Knight
to F4 there are going to be problems for
white on that flank but actually the Eva
bar swung back in a favor and that's
what happens when you're D Sheriff you
don't have enough time to sit and think
for say 30 seconds on a given move you
feel rushed and you can't find the
optimal play and white is healthily back
in this
game yeah he's he's he's playing I mean
I like this for black all day I'm a same
player myself but I do like I also love
the accelerated Dragon for a long time
um but when you have the
bind like it's annoying to play against
and now there's no bind so this is
really nice for black here it's almost
like you know a a psychological an
opening win in a way cuz you play a
maroxy bind and then he gets rid of the
bind so now black really has no problems
here and a draw is fine for us um so
it's black to move what do we play
Bishop D3 is a question mark Mo by the
way I don't think it deserves a question
mark especially because D is thinking
here and he goes Rook F7 that Bishop
wants a plant on e4 that Knight on D4
it's annoying but it doesn't attack
anything what there Rook takes F3 now
that I think about it there are tactics
on that square sheesh there was a rook
F3 dang that was sick yeah Rook F3 takes
Knight F3 bro yeah he just missed it I
mean it's understandable like a lot of
emotions here a lot of pressure for both
of them and you know but whoa R was a
nasty move uh unspotted by both Queen
H5 yeah I don't like this for white I
mean maybe I go B4 and trying to create
some stuff feels like black is just on
me
though what a tough position to figure
out both sides have their chances here
and and for D all he need a draw let's
remind everybody a draw wins for black
that will do the
trick yeah a draw wins guys a draw wins
this is the Armageddon part um where the
draw is a win and a win is a win usually
you'll take the black pieces but in when
his time gets lower and rap it all day
you'll take the black pieces on the
lower time here in Blitz it's a little
bit harder to do so because you don't
have any increments so he has two
minutes flat when he gets down to one
minute he's going to have 1 minute no
increment that's going to be tough
that's going to be really tough and DED
took back the bishop on D4 instead of
taking the Rook on C1 given a question
mark understandable Choice by him
nonetheless and look at this James
opposite colored Bishops usually we say
in end games their draw Tendencies but
with Queens on the board it gives
attacking chances look at those dark
squares the bishop lands on G3 you have
to be careful that a queen doesn't get
to H2 but with white blockading the king
side I don't see how the queen gets
in yeah I don't see how the queen get
his in I was just trying to figure that
out yeah Bishop G3 looks great feels
great but then you realize oh I can't
get in there like anywhere and you can't
even back up to Bishop to try to go
Bishop F4 Queen H4 Queen G3 like it just
doesn't work I can always snap on F4 too
as well my Rook feels misplaced on C3 so
maybe a rook D3 or even back to C1 you
know we got to figure out what to do
here um we got to move though we have to
move I think maybe just moving The Rook
away should be good kind of clamped or
cramp that is King H1 F4 is idea she
goes Rook
E3 okay trying to fix the Rook like you
suggested and B6 trying to stop any pawn
pushes on the queen side I F4 you called
it James you're really calling so many
of the Tactical ideas that is a move
that at least confuses your opponent and
the we down under a minute and a half it
also hits the bishop was my whole idea
you want to get rid of this bishop you
also want to hit at the E5 Pawn that
controls the Knight so it's a really
strong move F4 was not a move before Joe
I see you in the chat because there was
a knight2 check that's why she had to
move the Rook Rook e three is was more
accurate first so now you can play you
know obviously F4 um let me see Bishop
H4 Bishop F3 trade them boys off kind of
like white that's good that's good
that's a beautiful move because if she
took on E5 right away after a swap of
Rooks in F1 the white king would have
been exposed she brought her Bishop back
to F3 up to G4 and rookie E4 she is
playing this so calmly that the pawn F4
is defend by the Knight Rook takes D4
becomes a threat and D down to about a
minute in the clock I love how alen
robers is in handling this she
definitely handled this like an absolute
boss 100% Bishop G3 is a question mark
move I think I just have Queen E3 though
oh I guess you have Queen
H4 how do I respond to that is the
question I'm taking on D sacks it anyway
I don't care about none of that give me
the Knight night Knight takes takes K
there Bishop E6 knight7 is mate knight7
is mate one
oh my goodness watch where you look okay
there it is he saw it he's like yeah
you're not about to hit me with the pr
puzzle Rush on National so let me see um
whoa tra okay she just takes up shop
he's down under a minute and it's he's
really going to be kicking himself if he
loses this because he was like so close
he was a half a point away going from
half a point away to going into an
Armageddon to losing that it really is
devastating and you have to fix your
psych there before you go into any other
matches it's going to be
tough James let's not forget that he
blundered his Queen in one move that
Queen A2 check that we tuned into and
she just grabbed the queen took the game
and she was down 3 to one and yet she
clawed back yeah yeah that's the threat
in 30 seconds for DED here he's looking
at this position he knows it's pretty
hopeless so alen robers she will almost
certainly be moving on to face off
against Greg chiadi Queen E7 you can
swap the Queens off you're up two oh G3
give me to piece bro hit the button hit
the button Robert hit the button this
one's a rap go this one's a WAP yikes
yeah man she played an excellent chest
here and I think he just crumbled here I
think a lot of it was the pressure of me
I know I'm half a point away and not
that you relax but it is in your head I
worked with the coast was like stop
worrying about the result you have to
worry about the work that produces the
result you still have a job to do so you
know when you have this it wasn't over
and she had that she was it was one to
three and then she came back here and
she's looking to win
oh Queen
E7 oh my gosh you're kicking him while
he's down that's a dagger because you
can't stop the pawn oh go chill girl you
got to chill you can't be doing that
over here oh my goodness Queen
E7 disgusting you kidding me elene
robers and that's the first time she has
smiled and she should be proud of
herself because that was a nasty Final
Touch to win the game and to move on to
face Greg shahadi for the group a winner
and the winner goes to the semi James
that was so sick I think it deserves
like eight instant replays oh yeah 100%
yeah very aggressive I love her chess
it's just aggressive it's like hey
that's a long loss I knew we we were
alike somehow and that is definitely the
way she definitely just carried it
through from being down two points to
start it out that was crazy great job
for me and she's going on to face Greg
now
and we have to give our condolences to D
Cher because it's unfortunate that he
lost in the minut that he did he was up
3 to one after the blitz portions but
bullet got away from him Armageddon
wasn't better alen robers she proved her
might losing the first match to Mary
arabid and then winning two in a row
over Greg shahadi and D Sheriff so we
get a rematch of um elen against Greg
but before we do James just show that
instant replay that final knockout Queen
E7 woo
shees Queen E7 send him to Heaven I mean
that's crazy Queen E7 nasty move here
bro just stopping all the checks I don't
care what you do or how you do it go
ahead take the queen if you like and he
does right of course if you take the
queen then Pawn takes with obviously the
queening happening and we have Rook
check coming down with queen as well you
have a few checks I mean you can check
me here Queen D1 check doesn't really
matter I can go King G2 even H2 doesn't
really matter I go King to G2 and what
do you do oh you hit the button that's
what you do there you resign because
this is going to be queen and I do have
the check coming to as well to back up
the queen nice game for El sick finish
there for elen robers she as we said
gets to play Greg shahadi it's a rematch
of the first match of the day excuse me
the second match where she beat Greg
after a tough start so with that in mind
we are going to head to a break but when
we return it's the tie breaks it's alen
it's Greg you will not want to miss the
action here in the IMC
[Music]
but she's not going to move it cuz it's
defendant oh she did it I just said I
just said don't go
there we need a compilation chess.com
social media crew look through the PO
Champs games oh baby
let's
go how many times I called the move
before it
happened okay Ley you asked for it here
we
go it's almost the St knows what he's
doing he's going to try to for and
Andrea there's a stalemate coming Pawn
here take King G4 he pushes and it's a
stalemate oh my goodness well you you
clearly you I'm sure you taught Frank
about stalemate no okay don't
oh this I blame you for all of this this
is your manifest good oh my
goodness Bishop takes Pawn takes Queen
takes loses the bishop and if that
happens I will be heartbroken because
you could have
just how's your heart
heavy did feeling
okay heart how is it you you can't even
script this stuff my
man defend the bishop again they just
forgot
okay
okay his position is is hard to lose as
long as it stays how it
is yeah for sure unless he starts going
totally crazy with something like Ponto
G
what is your ability today you literally
said that in real
[Music]
time
a
[Music]
he
a
[Music]
and we are back at the I'm not GM speed
chest Champion it's Greg Shahidi it's
elen robers it's superstitious writings
on the wall that is Greg shahadi who has
changed his shirt James he lost to alen
the first time around he changed his
shirt because he sees that as bad luck
I'm not going to lie you know what I had
a hoodie uh one of my hoodies from the
merch store that I lost like two or
three games in a tournament in and it's
a very nice hoodie it's like so nice a
lot of people have it so I gave it to my
mom like Mom I hate this hoodie cuz I've
lost in it in a tournament so I
understand that he changed the shirt I
feel like a new person let me take the
shirt off you know let me just get fresh
and get ready here thumbs up he says
he's ready to go elen robers is ready
look at the death stair there she's just
ready to go calm collected but very
aggressive on that board she is indeed
and there are only four games that are
going to be play between these two
bullet chests 1 minute for the game with
1 second added per move it makes
flagging a little bit less likely as the
first to two and a half points that wins
the colors will alternate Greg will get
white in the first game and if they're
still tied two to2 after four games we
get Armageddon alen just one her armag
getd match it seems she doesn't mind
getting into those bidding wars but
James it's now about the chess once
again for alen robers she's thrilled she
just outlasted D Sheriff despite facing
a deficit for Greg he smoothly made his
way through to this tiebreak match
against Mary arabid he was a bit too
strong yeah he he he was played very
good they both did they made it this far
that's why they're fighting each other
cuz they were just the best in the group
so now it's off to them and I mean it
could be anybody's game if elen plays
how she been playing it's going to be
hard for Greg but Greg needs to step it
up obviously there and not allow himself
to get those positions he was getting
against El earlier I think he had the
hardest you know time against her in
fact in that aggression and just super
sharp and loving tactics just like a
Jedi would as a Jedi could like myself
here I understand how she plays here and
Greg needs to be ready for everything
that she's about to throw at him okay so
we had this position earlier the bishop
came out to C5 it was an obscure
variation but know what Greg has the
benefit of he had a break he could
prepare for her openings and we're
getting this position once again and
this was interesting castling on both
sides so we have aggressive play here
James do you like that alen is
retreating her night and repeating this
line bro she like blitzing it out too as
well I mean they just going crazy they
blitzing everything out like oh cuz it's
like uh I forgot it's um bullet I was
like why are they moving so fast
sometimes I forget that it's just bullet
chest and they're instantly moving I'm
not a fan of keeping the same choice
because Greg had a great game very easy
a very easy game and looks like he's
getting the same one once again now he
stops to think first to think here just
go F4 I don't know why he didn't go F4
there maybe he didn't like it for some
reason but now he has a little Queen
dance Queen H4 oh he went to D2
okay yeah the queen backs up the defile
is loaded with tons of fire power for
both sides but Knight D6 you don't see a
knight on D6 very often in front of a
pawn but that KN can hop into C4 there
it goes so James that King for white
it's about to be opened up a bit it will
be and this is more like okay it's not a
night or CU there's no D6 E5 but usually
you get I get some night or vibes from
this where like you get the Knight to C4
you take with the B Pawn you move the
bishop you play Rook ba8 and you
actually just go you hunt the king here
and white on the other hand you going to
have to go G4 G5 really fast G4 G5 and
we live as fast as humanly possible here
comes a rook B8 and Bishop takes E4 that
probably could have been a better way to
do it is Rook B8 to set up Bishop takes
E4 but this one okay cool Bishop C6
Queen D4 trying to get the Queens off
Queen B7 wow she's like trade him care
she don't mind the the queenless
position and there's a threat on B2 and
B3 is played so Black's worst Pawn the
overextend C Pawn is gone but that
Bishop on A8 James that's buried in the
corner and she strikes with D5 just for
that reason 100% get the bishop out of
the corner there do like I mean slightly
Black's position but these these Knights
are very nice in the center here so she
kicks one away says go back get out of
here brings the Knight over to F5 with
D4 coming you should go G oh yeah H4 was
hanging that's why H5 something's about
to hang Rook D7 says take on G2 if you
like well taking on G2 will uh send send
her to heaven right that's what you like
to say and now they're traded pieces the
E4 Pawn is a weakness but defended an
outside pass Pawn potential for white I
like Greg's ending here I just don't
like Greg's clock yeah 100% his clock is
very low here but he definitely has a
great ingame here Superior Knight over
the other one one ooh yeah Knight of two
super annoying Knight C3 though defends
everything King where ooh where do you
put the king okay King C2 Knight B4
check though check check check
check Knight back to D3 that Knight's
going to check around oh the hel The
Rook sorry h66 check to that King I
thought he
blundered takes takes B4 coming King D3
or B3 okay hit the Knight first but then
there's Knight oh the hand that's
hanging nice A5 push A5 just getting rid
of the C5 Pawn black is no worse and I
would play for a win after Pawn takes C5
Knight takes C5 don't trade Rooks take
on C5 with the Knight watch out as a pin
down the sea line got to move the king
king where King D4 check oh what are you
doing Greg you lost your absolute mind
if you think you about to get away with
that one not today try
again not today not tomorrow he won't
have a tomorrow in this tournament if he
does not save some of the next games but
James he saw his Knight was going to be
pinned he brought his Rook back
unfortunately to a losing square and now
he can pick off his G Pawn there are no
stalemates take the Knight that lands on
H3 and it's good night two extra pawns a
clean victory in the end for lean robers
instant instant ale instant ale there
buddy that is a wrap that is a wrap wow
and Greg's just playing this out I
wonder if he's trying to get the nerves
away because when you lose a game like
this you're frustrated you're playing
the checkmate you know just there's game
over alen takes game one James alen just
like d Reed before her maybe she's
feeling the Rhythm after two match
victories in a row and winning that
nerve-wracking armor again absolutely I
mean really it does like winning is
contagious right you know losing is two
fact so it goes well way if you lose in
one game you it's very possible you can
lose many other ones in a row if you
don't fix the psych there or get over
the fact that you lost that game and
what can I learn from it now same thing
with winning I'm winning how can I keep
the stride going and she's trying to do
said that right now especially after
having starting out with the lead really
the first two three games always count
in these matches especially when it's
less games involved like this one having
a four- game match these first two games
are the most important games I think
here so if she's able to win a second
one it's going to be on demand for Greg
to win the next two
games Greg's got to get it going and
right here he takes a bishop on E3 so
it's a bishop pair for black but the
Bishops they don't have open space F6
that's a move that you might have to
play sorry Ben fold we already talked
about this earlier today but you need
this bishop to become a bishop and now
it really is absolutely Knight to D3 now
we have some type of like Carl bat in
way Knight goes over to C5 hits the
bishop G4 played played might be Bishop
C8 only whoa okay that's a check first I
tuck and roll with the King all right
and then Bishop C8 maybe only move uh
maybe bishop D7 okay Bishop D7 okay yes
you have Bishop D7 E4 correct takes and
Bishop takes E4 okay there is a knight
E6 not Palace we could have just take
take though Knight B3 wow so many moves
so many moves Al she's playing like she
lost the first game she doesn't need to
be this aggressive and look at her clock
she's almost a minute on on her clock
she's playing too quickly and she's
creating too many weaknesses in her
position she definitely is Queen G3 is
really a nasty move apparently Bishop G6
oh my God Bishop G6 Queen D3 oh my God
Bishop D6 Queen D3 and then King G5 and
Rook F5 King H4 Rook H5
M oh my gosh so there was that tactic
available not easy because there were
some actual potential saves for black
that would have required maybe even more
sacrifices from White and instead Greg
gets to liquidate into a pawn up
position but that D5 Pawn just like in
some grunfeld Knight E4 coming your way
don't take that
pawn and okay shoot yeah Greg just like
cooking this game yeah he cooking
there's a check and check like oh yeah
he cooking he cooking here you going
have to go back to E1 shoot just go back
to the crib go back home like Queen E1
and just chill yep there's nothing else
yikes yeah he's cooking he's cooking
this one let him Rook Chad let him Rook
let him
Rook Brook and James all that extra time
that she built up alen playing so
quickly in the opening uh it's not much
extra time now and she's down a pawn and
that Pawn's about to become a queen C2
and how do you stop that I don't see how
you do
yeah that's over yikes you have I was
about to say Knight G5 you could have
went Queen E4 then Knight G5 oh but he
can just move Ken
G7 that's gross so yeah that's over with
and Greg bounces back big Greg says I'm
back now
wow blow for blow
okay okay let's see uh what's Happening
Here look at this B3 so he plays his
system and A5 A4 allow to black trades
off the queen side white not unhappy
about that James when I've seen these
positions it's always weird just the
Queens side Rooks are missing so it's
like a normal position without play on
that side the board yeah that's funny
like you just took them off hey you want
to play without the Rooks yeah let's
let's do it all right cool Co and he
just like take him off like that's kind
of funny cuz that's exactly what it is
just no Rooks on that side of the board
like nothing which is kind of funny it
is a quite funny position but I mean a
very level for both sides here very
level I see a queen a one coming but
then there might be a queen A8 as well
oh c7's hanging so you went Queen C2 I'm
a fan of that Queen A1 long diagonal
stuff yeah Knight B4 is nice nice Tempo
this is a position that gets complicated
because both players have these Knights
on B4 and B5 there are Outpost squares
don't move your knight from F6 and
that's why she doesn't Knight D7 would
have been a fork and I think that white
it's time to go is there a queen F4 just
trying to say your KN here we go yes and
G4 G5 now G4 H4 G5 and we live
100% what does black even do here
actually don't good move for black
that's a great question he had a great
position here long diagonal Bishop G4 is
coming you play H6 I go H4 I go G5 you
might have to bring the Rook back to f8
but then that still G5 takes takes
there's some uh issues with Knight D7
coming at some point here comes the pawn
G4 you can't play Rook G7 and you can't
play Queen you don't have any access to
F7 that's it that's it G4 H4 is a rep
you know you start a new game Greg out
here working with the little B3 Shifty
Nifty Shifty stuff like just something
new you know take him out of book a
little bit play B3 and now he's uh oh
that's
ni o 50 move love the yeah she's
getting tricky over here so don't take
this Rook to lose your queen there's no
Checkmate that's the good news so you're
not getting mated if you're El lean but
you're down 20 seconds and you're King
is still open and queen G3 keep the
queen on defend Square yeah yeah Queen
G3 oh Knight
G6 yeah he plays it I mean but I just
don't like the fact that I have to trade
everything so I like your move better
because I just don't I just I didn't
want to trade right like gives you some
chances to exactly try to consolidate
here but I'm fine right yeah extra Pawn
Rook check back rank Rook check that's
GG wait okay completely over I saw that
if six but you just take okay you just
take James oh he could have put H5 H6
that was Unstoppable he let the king out
suddenly black does have some chances
here what's the time oh yeah she has no
time but hey you know anything happens
that one second increment Rook takes
B6 Free Pawn Don't Mind If I Do CHP
Chomp you know what I'm saying
appreciate the generosity
and see H6 F3 first oh H6 yeah it's just
GG takes takes I'm up a clean one you
can hit the button yep there there it is
wow so Greg shahadi wins two games in a
row now alen robers needs to win on
demand she gets the white piece F4 she
playing the bird she is straight up you
know what she play Dutch she played bird
which is understandable like it's just
the Dutch in Reverse she know these
positions very well now it's up a Tempo
so you know let's see what she does with
it that's kind quite funny though that
she chose the bird here you can do
anything you can do whatever you like
and
bullet it's true and she's going for a
kingside pawn storm it's kind of like a
Clos cilian here the bishop on G7 Pawn
on B4 aim towards the white king side
and that's why white can't go all in for
an attack Queen H4 will drop the C3 pawn
and James I played the closest to his
white my entire childhood I got terrible
positions it just doesn't feel very good
because black is the one attacking white
has no attack that I can see yeah I had
like I actually lost to uh John maralu
actually JB wasn't a Scandinavian but it
was definitely um a play D4 he played C
five that game think about it so where
does the scandy come from I don't even
know but he uh it was a close I lost
that game but then I I won one which was
nice you get some good positions you get
some really bad ones too as well so it
does happen but this bird here H5 coming
I mean I don't know how I feel about
this it just doesn't feel like that
aggressive yeah I think black did
everything well there's just one bit of
good news for Leen is that it's not like
black has a clear plan either both sides
they're just trying to come up with
something H5 is you point out that's on
the docket the F5 Pawn could be loose H6
would trap the bishop if you allow the
pawn all the way forward and why would
you give away that pawn if you're
Greg oh and C4 hanging now too oh H Rook
he Rook on A1 oh my goodness Rook takes
A1 boom let's see the reaction there it
is he like what am I doing oh my
goodness let me smack my head here I
have lost my absolute mind and he did
100% he just hung the whole Rook guys on
on National Television here that is a
wrap wow you can't do that you just
cannot do that she is back in the game
and it is anybody's game this is oh
shoot yeah that'll be so then what's the
tie break after this what's the tie
break now Armageddon Armageddon with
bidding you know they they tie the tie
break then we get to arm again but look
at this Greg he's not resigning he has a
connected pass Pawn it's protected on B3
suddenly he has some chances here
because the white king isn't perfectly
safe two passers here uh-oh oh you have
to convert this if you're a leon you
know what's funny he has been a magician
all day so I don't put it past him to be
able to find something here now that was
against yeah that was against everybody
he did that with d and Mary now that I
think about it so you know if he's able
to do it here it's just no stopping Greg
if if he can win this game there's just
you just can't stop him today he's just
Unstoppable but Le the one to too smart
yeah she's too smart she gave away some
of her extra material that's an
important for those of you at home you
give away some of your extra material
just to Li liquidate to simplify the
position and speaking of simplify this
is simply awful for black queen takes f8
is Checkmate and one threatened because
that Bishop is pinned and the King has
no
defense yeah he's just getting made it 3
seconds two seconds 1 second got to move
doesn't move Flags over two and two
claps Applause there tie breaks and we
have ourselves
Armageddon James we do have Armageddon
alen she barely reacts Greg he's clearly
frustrated with how that went but the
rules for Armageddon is that black wins
with the draw that's the important point
to keep in your mind the players they're
about to bid for their choice of color
so we saw earlier alen bid four minutes
D bid three and a half DED chose black
and had three and a half minutes to
alen's five so the opponent Who quote
unquote loses the bid you get 5 minutes
on your clock with the white pieces in a
must-win scenario there is no increment
anymore no longer 1 plus one no longer
increment no time added for move
flagging will happen so James now that
we have Armageddon once again how low do
you think Greg will
go I will go
350 350 will be my little I need a
little extra 20 seconds there 350 will
be my lowest bit I can't go lower than
that I just can't just doesn't feel like
I'm I'm I'm playing with fire there
350 well Greg you know he likes bidding
he plays poker he likes all sorts of
funky formats but I'm with you I don't
think you can bid too low of an amount
because then you can't get into the flow
of the game so as we await for alen and
Greg to make their bids chat what do you
think let us know what you would bid
give us a number I want to know what the
most common number will be I bet you
some people would say oh I would bid one
second no you wouldn't do that be honest
with us let's have a good time with it
but I think I think I'm with you James I
would go to about 340 345 that's the
absolute lowest just because you need
time on the clock and hey James guess
what the bids are in it would appear
Greg shahadi if this is correct he bid 4
minutes 20 seconds alen robers bid 4
minutes so alen she'll get the black
pieces with four minutes on her clock
you were pretty close there with how you
would have approached it wow and she
gets black pieces here okay she wins the
bid she gets Black Bullet G is it still
bullet I'm assuming it's still bullet
right no it's a five to four so five
minutes for white four minutes for black
five to four right okay so we have um
okay so she has black so all she needs
is a draw man this is crazy just to
switch from bullet to go right into
four minutes that's a lot here I think
elen though has the best I think elen
has the best chance chat what do you
think
is elen going to win or is Greg going to
win what do you think chat this is it
this we're we're being updated actually
that Greg he did make your bid spot on
so I'm sorry everybody I I misspoke I
was I provided faulty information he bid
350 not the 420 I initially said so he
bid your bid he gets the black pieces
alen will once again get white with 5
minutes he B 350 on the dot so yeah Greg
well he got black okay so it does change
a little bit El I still have her as it
feels like she's just in a good momentum
right now but Greg having black and draw
odds it's it's I think it's I think it's
50/50 flip a coin bro I think it's 50/50
now 350 but based on what we just saw
James alen was super fast in the bullet
maybe too fast for her own good but now
you have to adjust back from bullet to
Blitz you have 5 minutes for Le 3
minutes 50 seconds for Greg that if you
make an impulsive decision because
you're so used to playing a bullet now
your opponent has time to punish you so
both players they need to breathe they
need to take a step back and remember
that they have minutes not just seconds
on the clock James I'm going to put you
on the spot who are you predicting to
win this matchup breathe Jedi breathe
use the force and it
says
elen El oh elen wins El wins very in a
very close one in a very close match I
can feel it through the force thece I
mean alen has been Greg's Kryptonite
tonight because Greg he beat DED in the
first match he lost to Al Leen then he
swept against Mary in that third match
but elen has been an obstacle for him
that he cannot overcome so she's playing
that well and we do have liftoff and I
have to say James as we see the first
move why F4 why are we getting back to
the bird
in a blitz time
control he like what are you doing like
if he if he was the coach behind the
scenes like what I didn't tell you to do
that what are you doing I just wanted to
do it coach I just wanted to do
it well we about to have a spicy game
for sure and it didn't work in the first
game like it was not working maybe she
she'll have more time to fix some things
but it didn't work in that first bird
game it didn't work at all all I mean it
was a great position for Greg he
blundered a full Rook on A1 let's
remember how he lost that game uh but
alen she does know these positions quite
well so she feels that this is her
comfort zone I can't fault a player for
choosing something in their Wheelhouse
in her typical repertoire and she's
playing C3 I don't like this at all she
gives black all the fun on the queen
side 100% I mean you're supposed to go
if you going go for it go for it put the
queen on H4 play F5 go Bishop H6 like if
you going to go for it you go for it
that's why you play played this opening
to go for it here hasn't moved the queen
over to H4 yet I mean F5 now now there's
pressure on the queen side the C3 Pawn
how do you develop the B1 Knight which
you really can't do at all Rook comes
into the B2 at some point what are you
do queen C1 come on man come on Robert
this ain't looking good at all look at
this it's the most passive setup you can
imagine there's one bit of good news
James look at the clocks she's still a
minute ahead so we prefer Greg's
position there's no doubt about that but
Greg at some some point might be looking
at the clock looking at the board like I
need to make a rust choice for now
perfect chess from Greg shotti all of
his pieces are doing something and not
all of alens are I can't even move my
knight from B1 without losing a very
crucial Pawn now I finally can thank you
Greg I can go Knight D2 here I mean I
don't know what's next I just need know
I need to do it and that's what happens
Knight to D2 cuz now I can get the night
out at least at least but I mean oh this
is gross all my pieces are extremely
passive and I play played the bird here
which is not an opening that you're
supposed to ever play passively the
Queen's on C1 and it was on E1 intending
to go to H4 and it didn't go to H4 it
actually moved twice maybe meaning we
wasted a Tempo somewhere so it is a
rough here Anything Can Happen though
anything can happen and all black needs
all grick shot needs is a draw in this
game and he moves on so that's the good
news for him but it's not a clear-cut
position black is better but there's no
way to force a drawing sequence nothing
of that nature and by the way Knight
takes B3 I don't think is a threat
because after a takes B3 you open this
Rook up towards the queen towards the
bishop behind the Knight on A5 so she
plays Knight D2 please take me she says
I'm liking her chances given the time
situation definitely time situation and
just trying to make it work she playing
like off the head here is what we'll
call this she's just trying to find a
move cuz at this point we opened with
the bird F4 intentions were very clear
Queen E1 over to H4 and it just like
never never ever happened right never
happened so now we have this C4 that's
spicy takes takes takes takes takes up a
juicer t t takes Ren Shield takes takes
James James she missed it Knight A5 was
there that was a fork at the end that
would have hit Greg's Queen and Rook at
the same time oh man that was there yeah
that's still there it's there right now
it's still
there night
a5th night a5th and look at him look at
him talking he's like I oh no yeah
missed the fork blows real quick blows
out the air that's a cold shower there
that's a cold shower waves his hand away
usually that's when he loses like when
he he lost last same thing just put the
hand away like I'm done I'm done for now
you still have to play on there is an E5
coming in fact there is a potential E5
that can happen right now so she moved
out of the way of that Queen takes D4 is
a threat in addition the queen takes C3
now so it's not just a pawn but a full
Rook that's hanging she protects her
Queen Queen H4 no longer works so
there's good news for Greg he's not lost
look at the eval bar also if you were
playing this game yourself you would
feel the white king is vulnerable and
black only needs a draw so he doesn't
need to win this game if he can find a
way to draw but James the clock that's
what's telling the tale to me even more
so than the extra Rook for Knight yeah
if you especially knowing guys this is
no increment at all so 151 is all you
got you have 151 and lower the time gets
the lower of course so your time will be
and you don't get any increment you
don't get any time back as you did in
the other rounds or the other matches
other games so it's difficult to do he's
trying to hold if we keep Queens on we
may have some real chances here
especially as time gets lower for both
we want to stay around the same amount
of time as her if he's able
to staying in the pocket I like the
little maneuver just shift back and
forth don't do anything crazy he already
did he's he's gaining clock he's not
gaining time but he's getting closer to
her because she spend ending time he's
making lots of quick moves and watch out
Queen F1 suddenly that King on G3 you
know you don't need to be a hero here
that King will be in checking range from
The Black Queen so o Queen A3 check this
Rook to B3 you don't lose your Rook
luckily man that's almost very risky
might as well throw it in anyway he goes
Queen A5 cuz if the Rook moves he wants
the queen E1 check look at the pawns
like I mean this is crazy like you ever
you guys don't try this at home guys
okay but you know King up here and all
four pawns there's lots of weak is you
have to watch out for a queen coming
from behind here on G1 all right stops
all of the threats here uh B4 is almost
hanging there looks kind of
weird is there D5 yeah I'm looking at
the same thing James D5 for black at
some point will be very scary because
there's pins on the C file Queen to
D4 time getting a little bit closer to
each
other yeah Queen D3 watch out for that
check that that would win The Rook Al in
some trouble here here King definitely
cuz I mean like C maybe Knight C4 Knight
C4 with Knight E3 play Knight E3 is
coming oh but King H2 is apparently just
I mean this is a ridiculous move to find
she found King H1 she had the right idea
but wrong Square which like why who
knows engine like who knows but okay
check King H7 King G7 Queen C3 there
Queen takes E4 check so that won't work
out in White's favor you're dropping
another very important Pawn so Rook C3
sh Queen it's losing oh Queen H3 oh my
goodness King G1 and what do we play
next check
knight3 she completely misses James we
have to let everybody uh know remind
them all black needs a draw so Al has to
play for a win but here we go just back
and forth how do you escape all these
about to lose all the pawns you're about
to lose all the pawns that's it I'm
going to take this one right Queen H3 I
take that one Queen G3 oh Knight E3 wow
what a move Greg dang bro that's a sick
move bro that is Nast wait a second Rook
takes Knight takes Rook C8 and you
threaten the Checkmate over here but I
guess Queen 6 H4 will lead to a
repetition or is there one oh yeah Queen
G4 back or even this yeah even this and
Greg moves on G money Greg
shahat Greg
wins you see his face he's like how
could I make that mistake Greg it
doesn't matter what was in the past all
that matters is the future you advance
to the semi-finals of the I am not a GM
speed test Championship thumbs up yeah
thumbs up to you buddy you survive you
advance you move on the first player to
stamp their ticket in to the semi-finals
and of course elen robers was oh so
close but close is not good enough it's
Greg shahadi moving on Greg is moving on
he earned it there of course it was not
the prettiest it doesn't matter how you
get it done it matter it doesn't matter
how you get it it matters if you got it
done is what I always like to say and he
got it done he is advancing to the semis
there wow Greg shahadi wins out in group
a Greg shahadi that's the name who will
continue in this field unfortunately for
the others they are eliminated but we
will hear from the players after this
short break chat give us your questions
we might be able to ask them some of
your featured questions so stay tuned
everybody we're heading to break and win
return greet shotty L robers will join
us and we'll get to hear their
[Music]
thoughts
Jack okay if I lose a game before I go
to sleep I have to play until I win and
once I win a game then I will play
another why isn't my chess rating going
[Music]
up anyone who has played even a small
amount of Chess especially online is
familiar with the concept of an opening
trap we've all fallen for one at some
point or another in many cases a failed
opening trap will leave you with a
terrible position but not always we've
compiled 10 opening traps that are not
only guaranteed to work but if your
opponent doesn't fall for them exactly
you'll still have a decent position
number two leg almate this opening trap
if your opponent cooperates can lead to
one of the most beautiful and famous
checkmates in chess named after s deal
it dates back all the way to the 18th
century it occurs in an Italian game and
in this position we play Knight C3 three
black might play Bishop G4 pinning the
Knight to White's Queen and we can play
H3 forcing black to make a decision
about the light squared Bishop if they
retreat with Bishop H5 this allows the
brilliant Knight takes E5 where a free
Queen is offered if black takes the bait
and grabs the queen can you spot the
famous mate in
two that's right Bishop takes F7 King E7
which is forced Knight D5 mate so if our
opponent does not take the queen bait is
this a dubious position not at all
Black's best response is Knight takes E5
allowing white to win the light squared
Bishop with Queen takes H5 and after
black takes the bishop on C4 white can
win the piece right back with a queen
check on B5 picking up the Knight on the
following turn no matter what Black's
response is white is up a pawn with
control of the center a great place to
be out of the
opening
[Music]
w
oh
[Music]
w
d
[Music]
and we are back with the players from
that epic Armageddon alen apologies that
they match didn't go your way Greg
congratulations and Greg will'll start
with you how are you feeling because
during that game we saw you throw your
hands in the air after you blunder that
exchange I mean I don't know I had so
many lost positions that I didn't lose
I'm just like my brain is all scrambled
uh that one I thought I was doing really
well until I missed the night and then
somehow her King was pretty weak so I
knew I had some
chances luckily worked out but my brain
is like messed
up elen you have played great chess very
aggressive chess we like to see that
especially me I'm an aggressive player
myself so um who are some of your
favorite players or influences to your
chess style very nice to see some of the
combos today even Queen E7 was a very
nasty find so he was very happy to see
these type of Chess so you know tell us
a little bit about some influences on
your chess
Style
uh well I didn't necessarily study that
many aggressive players just looking at
the top players and doing many
tactics um but I like uh Michael
Tall oh that's my grandfather it makes
sense I knew he was somehow related that
makes a lot of sense now okay perfect
perfect and I mean alen you did have so
many Fantastic combinations and as you
said no surprise that t is an influence
but you're also very popular on the on
the queen side Twitter account I feel
like every or ex I don't know what to
call it these days anytime I go on uh
that platform I see them chatting about
you celebrating your successes what does
that mean to you as you know you're
blossoming in your chest
career yeah well it's I think it's
really nice to have the
support and well fans of people I don't
even know it's really nice to see
that great have what what what kind of
preparation did it take I know you know
me and you we gym heads we in the gym
I'm going to the gym after this so of
course gym time you know did you do some
gym today did you get right did you get
your mind right in the gym before this
or like did you do some intense gym
preparation obviously I know you like
CrossFit and stuff like that so did you
do a lot of that preparing for the
matches well I'm actually in Spain and
it's some kind of better old holiday
here in Barcelona so all the gyms were
closed so I was going to work out but I
couldn't well I could I could work out
not in the gym but I was just like you
know what this is a sign I'm just going
to relax my brain and just you know get
ready for the match um I tried a new I
tried a new um plan of not preparing
very much because I find it very
stressful to prepare so I don't know if
you saw I would just play like a lot of
different openings and just kind of go
with my
feel
that makes a lot of sense and know
speaking of openings we do have some
feature chat questions and our first one
from galolo is for alen and they want to
know as chat was rooting for your bird
openings but why did you choose the bird
opening uh for the
Armageddon uh well I play the Dutch with
black so if you play the bird with white
I just have a Dutch but with the tempo
up so it seems like a pretty good
position
Greg your feature chat question here is
when is the next Grudge Match and of
course I had that too I took care of
that for you with Lawrence Trent of
course so with big Trent our our good
friend there when's the next match with
him next Grudge Match well you know he's
in this
tournament but for for us to have a
grudge match he would have to win his
group and I just don't see that
happening I I I look at his group and I
feel like he's the weakest shots fir
I don't I don't
think but maybe some other time you
know wow shots fired clip it and ship it
yeah fighting words if I've ever heard
some so I guess what is your prediction
for the rest of the field who do you see
getting out of each group
Greg um I didn't look at it too closely
but I do think Levy is in one of the
groups and of course he's very strong he
almost won this tournament before so he
probably has good chances um and of
course Danny wrench like no
doubt I think this is his year what are
the groups here Danny the man Danny
wrench in group yeah he's gonna do it oh
Kristoff CI very strong
too lot of a lot of strong players this
year except for
Lawrence but I want to say
this I want to say this match I was very
I thought was going to lose the tie
break for sure because alen crushed me
in the first match
and in the fast place she was faster
than me played better than me and I was
just really I I didn't think I would win
the way the first match went I had to
change my shirt that was like the only
thing I could think of
and somehow somehow I think the bid I
think getting black was helpful it's
nice to have draw
odds 100% nice to have those draw odds e
who do you think is going to make it out
uh in the next groups there who do you
think or who's your pick basically maybe
to win the whole thing or make it out of
each
group um I haven't really looked at the
groups too closely
but yeah I think Levy will do well he is
a good blit player
and in the other groups I don't really
know that many players I haven't played
them in blitz
so yeah that that makes sense and you
know before we let you go we'll see Greg
soon so I just want to ask uh with the
gr Swiss coming up are you in
Preparatory mode or what are you doing
to get ready for that big
event um well I'm catching up on school
actually because I just got back from
the club Cup in Albania
so I will get into Preparatory mode in a
week or so
okay well that we wish you the best of
luck Elan of course you have so many
supporters out there who are cheering
you on today Greg you disappointed her
supporters but we congratulate you
anyway and thank you both for such an
epic match Greg we'll see you
soon
yeah so just share what you want to say
I felt like people were rooting against
me I just had a feeling and I was like I
don't want to disappoint
them I'm sorry I'm sorry
well you're forgiven and alen thank you
again so much for joining us I'm sorry
that match didn't go your way but we
look forward to so many great games from
you in the near future and Greg we will
see you soon in the semi so thank you
both so much we really appreciate
you thank
you and there you see the final
standings of group a greet shahadi gets
through with three match victories the
third was a nailbiter an armagan win
over elen robers elen she proved that
she was every bit Greg's equal
throughout the day but Greg in the end
he won the Armageddon and so he makes it
through James what do you think of
today's Action Now today's action was
100% everything we wanted it to see okay
I thought it was going to be somebody
blowing just blowing out blowing
everyone out the water just like
sometimes you may see that but it was
way more equal than what I thought it
was going to be um lots of blunders lots
of crazy moves lots of great moves
sacrifices everything we wanted to see
today positional masterpieces flagging
everything happened today and this is
just only the beginning there is another
group today Robert there's only like I
mean you thought it was done not even
close it's a double header today chat so
I'm I'm excited bro I really am hyped
about it and it was great to see Greg
come out of there he is a veteran in
this field and he's now you know made it
again for like I don't know three four
years in a row just passing through
another match good job
and as you said Group B is coming up
next we will have coverage of that for
you Levy Rosman better known as Gotham
chess Kristoff seli chess explain shus
royel whose name has you know it's years
to come you will be hearing that name
over and over again and Nimo she is in
that group so it'll be fun to see them I
believe Kasa Corley and Daniel nitki
will have the call there so that is
coming up right next you will not want
to miss Gotham and the rest of group re
go head-to-head in the IMC but it's been
a very fun day one it's only halfway
through it's a double header and while
this group is coming to a close and we
will have more chess later we also want
to bring attention to an extremely
special event that's near and dear to
our hearts one of the legends of the
game none other than Judith Polgar has
her Global chess Festival that's right
please join us on Sunday October 15th
and celebrating the game that connects
us all with Judith POG girl's Global
chess Festival tune in for an exciting
Triathlon where powerful teams compete
in puzzle battles tandem chests and
bullet chests featuring our very own GM
David Howell and other prominent players
use the command chess Fest in chat for
details on the event you will not want
to miss it Judith pogar one of the
world's best in basts for the game of
chess and one of the strongest players
of all time will be having another
Global Fest and James it's been a global
Fest in the first group here in the imcc
any final thoughts of what we just
witnessed and what is yet to come this
is just the beginning of course we got
three other groups to go through all
these strong players I mean you don't
know who's going to win what right of
course we all have our fan favorites
make sure you got you guys stay behind
your fan favorites there and just keep
watching you're going to learn so much
from this and it's so much fun so much
exciting chess and uh it's more exciting
when we got people like you know Robert
chess with you and also the chat it's
amazing Greg shahadi he was the winner
of group a but we're all winners because
chess is for everyone we love seeing the
the game celebrated some of the biggest
content creators like you James KY and
up next we have Group B featuring Gotham
chess Nemo trus Royal and kristofh suck
you not want to miss it so come back
join us for more chess we will see
shortly for more from the
[Music]
imcc
out
[Music]
a
it
d
[Music]
oh
d
[Music]
mus
a
[Music]
mus
oh
[Music]
B
yeah
[Music]
n
oh
I
[Music]
oh
B
[Music]
now
d
[Music]
oh
d
[Music]
B
a
[Music]
oh
a
[Music]
I
B
[Music]
w
oh
a
[Music]
oh
B
[Music]
pap
w
[Music]
oh
mus
[Music]
oh
w
[Music]
oh
I
[Music]
d
you've seen the speed Chess
Championship now it's time for the rest
of us to get a turn with no Grand
Masters allowed it's the I'm not a GM
speed chest Chann
Championship watch your favorite chess
personalities duke it out in chess.com
exciting speed chess
format there will be brilliancies GL
stacking another P Bishop C3 and Rook a
one oh Rook a one there will be blunders
no no he fell for it 16 players are
fighting for a chance at the eight
player knockout see old rivalries this
is how long new
foes with a 15 ,000 prize pool who will
take home the crown this year and that
is the match the imcc starts right
[Music]
now welcome to the I am not a GM
Championship speed chest championship
this is the second edition we've already
had a lot of action today but the action
is not complete quite yet it is an honor
to to be commentating this event I'm
Grandmaster Daniel nitki alongside me
today the one and only I am Kasa Cori I
am Kasa corle commentating the I am not
a GM feed Chess Championship how do you
feel I feel pretty good to be here with
you da it's an exciting exciting event
to follow and uh we get some of our
favorite players and commentators in the
mix so uh love to see it so many Legends
this year and it's a new format so folks
who are watching you know bear with us
uh there's there's a couple of new
things to explain but first of all let's
take a look at the group standings there
are four groups as you can see each of
them features four International Masters
who accumulate points as the tournament
progresses Greg shahade already staking
his claim in group a there's a name at
the top column of Group B Levy uh C I'm
having a hard time reading it I just
called you Levy take that as a
compliment yeah no uh this this kind of
reminds me of uh the World Cup so
essentially what you have is you have a
group stage they're four players in each
group and they play each other in a
round robin style and so the dynamic is
that there's going to be one player out
of each group that makes it to the semis
um uh we already have Greg having
advanced in a very very intriguing uh
matchup earlier in the day and uh we
have basically now other players vying
for spots so that's what it's going to
come down to very well explain cets it's
easier than it seems as you said four
groups there's one player from each
group who qualifies to the next stage
there's the tournament format card and
the bottom three are eliminated and
we're about to get to the actual
specifics of each match so each match
consists of six games uh it's not the
same way that the regular SEC works
there's no 90 minutes of 5 plus one it's
two games of each time control same time
controls as the SEC uh and the first
player to accumulate three in a half
points uh advances if the match is tied
33 then Armageddon will be played so
Kasa pretty cut and dry uh you know it's
it's
a little bit
less Yeah so basically there's no timer
basically like you see in Trad the
traditional format and you theoretically
can have a scenario where one side
basically sweeps someone else in the
first four games right because it's the
first to three and a half so there's a
possibility in some matches that you
might not even get a one plus one uh
segment but essentially each player is
going to play everyone else in everyone
else in their group uh first to three
and a half and then after that matches
is played they're going to play another
person in the group so it's going to be
very frenetic Pace today and frenetic
Pace during our show because we will
have two matches going on
simultaneously today one of them will
feature Levy Rosman the internet's chess
teacher against Nemo zuu uh and the
second one will feature Kristoff seki
also known as chess explain that's
probably how most people know him the
author of so many amazing opening
courses so many YouTube videos he will
be facing the Australian Phenom
International Master Shas Royal I I'm
afraid to say how old he is Kasa because
I don't remember is he 12 is he 13 they
keep getting younger and younger these
days but we'll have these two matches
going on at the same time folks and we
will be looking at both of them as they
unfold what an exciting day ahead of us
Kasa yeah it's going to be really fun
because again we have these great
Personalities in front of us uh everyone
knows who Levy is everyone knows who
Nemo is and kristofh seli has been one
of the great uh chess teachers on the
internet as well frankly he's uh come up
with a lot of courses explaining various
openings and so I I expect him to be
very very well prepared in dist
different aspects and he's playing a
extremely talented Junior in trus Royal
so that's going to be Battle of the
generations but you said it Levy Rosman
is the most famous name in the entire
field he holds the largest chess YouTube
channel with over four million
subscribers and close to 2 billion total
views he is also of course a commentator
and a content creator but mainly in the
context of this tournament he is an
excellent Blitz player he has achieved
over 2800 Blitz rating he recently
defeated Ali razaan by recently I mean
two days ago um at the uh title Tuesday
tournament so Levy Rosman is nothing to
sneeze at when it comes to the blitz
Arena Casa yeah no doubt about it and
you know he again did beat F a few days
ago so he has been putting in some
decent practice leading up to this event
and uh I'm really curious how often is
he going to make that face you see on
screen during these matches because I
think that will probably be a bad sign
if he makes that too often I don't know
if that face means my opponent blundered
a rook or I blundered a rook I guess
we're going to find out today but Levy
definitely has his work cut out for him
so so once again folks we'll have often
both games from both matches up at the
same time and what we will be doing is
kind of zooming into each match in turn
when things get get excited on one of
the boards so be prepared for a day of
frenetic Blitz action we'll do my we'll
do our best uh to bring you all of the
exciting moments from both matches Casa
but uh definitely plenty of
entertainment today to go around yeah no
question about it so do do you have a
favorite in these in these first initial
matchups so far because I'm really not
sure how it's going to play out uh
particularly in uh seli and uh Royals
match up I I honestly have no idea um so
I think it's actually a bit closer than
we think yeah Levy is the very heavy
favorite uh Nemo's a great Blitz player
but levie is the heavy favorite in that
match and I think between Saki and Royal
it's going to be very close I think
that's going to be one of the most
tightly contested matches uh in in this
entire tournament as we see Levy and and
Nemo on on camera there waving their
hell to you know their their millions of
fans who will be watching every move
they make that is Mr seli very
recognizable face and well we can't
really see his face right now but we're
about to and uh that's christop
CI yeah and uh folks getting set up
getting ready for the for the action uh
uh we got our folks all sitting down in
their seats and we're going to tune in
quite shortly to the first moves indeed
Kristof soy there taking care of
business uh before the games begin but
uh one minute to go KAS a really unique
tournament exciting tournament and uh
seat belts fastened and and mandatory
the other thing too is like how how much
does the strategy change in this one
because essentially you have you have a
situation where you need to win these
mini matches um like but do you I I feel
like if you're trailing early in a mini
match you have to really adjust quite
quickly because it's the first of three
and a half so I think you you know
typically you might see people stay with
openings or positions longer uh for a
longer period of time in traditional SEC
this might be a little bit different
given that if you're struggling you
can't struggle for too long or the match
will be
over yeah no question about it
so so yeah that is that is where we're
at right now and uh
I do I do think we who do we have we
have seli on screen you know I think
trying to work something out with a with
an iPad what's what's going on we're
figuring out got like six devices you
know he's got like his control room yeah
that might be a his uh his camera set up
you know uh we uh you know making sure
you know the fair play stuff is uh is is
taken care of reasonably um but yeah
Royal looks focused and ready to go he
he looks like he's uh he's uh been in
many a matchup online and this just
looks locked in right now so very
exciting stuff and we're doing our final
fair play checks of the games will begin
momentarily but Levy's mentioned this on
interviews that these tournaments
produce a kind of anxiety in in the
players that is not comparable to the
way that you feel let's say before an
over theboard tournament where you're
pretty calm you're Focus it's a
different Dynamic and I can attest to
this Kasa last time I had this feeling
was before the bullet chest champ ship
you're sitting there at your computer
and you're a mess I mean your
butterflies in your stomach it's it's a
kind of anxiety that really can cause
you to derail in the first couple of
games so there's a big psychological
component and when all you need is three
and a half points if you let that
anxiety get the better of you you can
drop a couple of games before you even
know what planet you're on yeah and
again the Tilt is real we've actually
spoken about this in uh in previous
editions we've we've commentated
together da and yeah it the Tilt is so
real so you really have to be able to
adjust course and deal with adversity in
a in a really kind of fluid way which is
super hard to do especially when they're
T tons of you watching absolutely we
welcome uh the many tens of thousands of
you across the platforms to the I am not
a GM speeds Championship the gong is
about to sound and the first two games
of five plus one have begun we've got
selki against Royal on the right and of
course levy on the blue board against on
the left D4 on the left E4 on the right
what more can we ask yeah I like that
we're going to get uh some diversity
right off the bat all right we have a
trumi from Levy and we have a Moscow
variation Bishop B5 check from seli I
think that makes sense playing that
against the young junor take him a
little bit of out of book quicker and uh
Nemo is still thinking after Bishop G5
so we'll figure out how she wants to go
does she is she wary to face these
double pawns or not yeah she plays E6
which is I don't want to double my pawns
and both players who have the white
pieces right now Levy and Kristof they
are known for their opening preparation
they are the authors of many dangerous
opening courses I would say Kristoff has
a more positional bent to his
recommendations and his repertoire where
whereas Levy likes those kg tactical
positions but the kind of trompowsky
that he's playing it resembles a London
system the only big difference is the
placement of that dark squared Bishop so
Levy just kind of quietly settling into
the match trying to get a structure that
he's more comfortable with and Nemo
burning a lot of clock in the early
going yeah I am a little wary of this
early H6 move from Nemo which is totally
fine in these structures but it does
create an early hook opportunity I
wouldn't be surprised if Levy actually
doesn't rush to Castle um I think you
could very and see he's actually aiming
for F4 Knight F3 Dynamics with this H6
move on the board there are hook
possibilities and so I think that's what
you have to really look out for uh he's
going to plant that pony on E5 and
initiate an attack and I think the style
here that we talked about before is
coming to the four Levy's a attacking
player uh and he's going to try and uh
he's going to try and put Neema Under
Pressure early and often mhm and a
trivia question for the newer players in
chat what is the pawn structure that
Levy attained with the move F4 called
and you might recognize it with cers is
reversed uh in a different opening but
it is the same structure it's an easy
structure to play and you've got this
big bind on the E5 Square that's not
allowing Nemo to liberate her light
squared Bishop which is currently stuck
behind her pawns Levy has a great
position uh right off the bat here he
seems comfortable he might delay
castling Casa he might also Castle King
side and still plan a knight on E5 uh
you can attack the black king with your
pieces Queen E2 and then you can build
up that battery with Bishop dropping
back to C2 and the queen sliding up to
D3 threatening the Checkmate on H7 Nemo
trying to counteract that by expanding
on the queen side Stonewall is correct
good job don't don't uh overestimate uh
basically the eval bar here cuz I think
Nemo is doing exactly what she should be
doing which is ultimately trying to
undermine the queen side structure that
white has with an eventual B4 and so you
see Nemo's basically preparing A5 and B4
it's so important to hit at that chain
on the queen side because ultimately
that's where uh that's where her
counterplay lies and so a lot of times
when you're figuring out what to do it's
playing on the side that you're better
and white clearly has established a grip
and dominance on on the king side and in
the center and so Nemo has to get
something going on the queen side uh in
the interim but it seems like her engine
uh is not getting started because you're
not playing B4 anytime soon Levy has the
bind on that square the Black Knight can
get to C4 Nemo developing her Bishop
first covering the C6 Square there would
have been a fork uh if she had gone
Knight C4 immediately and here I really
like the move Bishop C2 threatening
Queen D3 and to make matters worse Kasa
G6 is going to be met with Knight takes
G6 this might already be close to
winning for Aly after Queen D3 Nemo
ignoring the Brewing storm on the king
side she's going to have to go Rook E8
and make a run for the center with her
King uh yeah it's uh not the Tor of
France that you're uh you're hoping to
make on foot you know like you you
typically want the bike and uh and here
you know this is why we're seeing the
exclam because queen7 is mate G6 really
doesn't help matters in the slightest
because of Knight takes G6 and already
here there are there's trouble in
Paradise um and so she's going initiate
that king walk with Rook E8 but the
question is how realistic is it for this
King to kind of Dart down the yell brick
road or the the dark squares in this
case and be secure tough to say what
white wouldn't what white wouldn't give
for a bishop on C5 right now a dark squ
Bishop would be so good and you can see
Levy not he's taking his time because
Queen H7 a lot of newer players they get
very excited at the prospect of giving
those checks but if you play Queen H7
and queen h8 all you will have done is
Drive the black king where it wants to
go anyway and then you're going to lose
a bunch of Tempe having to evacuate your
queen so I actually like the restraint
from Levy he doesn't need to rush it
he's better positionally and then he can
casually go back to D3 with his Queen he
can involve his Rooks and he's just
sitting on the position which is what
you want to do in a Blitz game by the
way black is also in trouble on the
other board I've been keeping an eye on
selki against Royal Kristoff is up a
clean healthy pawn and holds a
two-minute time Advantage so black
having a hard time getting out of the
gates on both of the boards yeah and
it's it's funny here because I do
believe the worst is over for Nemo at
least for now I think black will have
this opportunity now to shift gears if
she recognized it and play for this B4
break now that white has just just sort
of played a few extra prophylactic moves
and hopefully she does get an A5 B4
that's what it's going to come down to
if Nemo's able to undermine the queen
side we have a discussion if not then
there might be trouble on the king side
and that's what Levy is building up to
forward lining the queen back on pun G6
not exactly subtle uh da not at all I
almost called
you hey I appreciate it here we go is a
sacrifice incoming our first sacrifice
of the match Levy has left himself with
plenty of time to calculate the
ramifications of Knight takes F7 and
queen takes G6 you can sense the wheels
turning in his head he doesn't go for it
Knight F7 Queen G6 and F5 was winning
pretty much on the spot but he's taking
the Slow Burn approach in this game
yeah I mean I think one of the things
about this Knight F7 move is I didn't
see Checkmate and so if you didn't see
Checkmate maybe you're a little bit
reluctant to kind of be temporarily down
a piece but OB but there was going to be
some really nice attacking possibilities
drawing the king out to F7 and opening
up the F line so understandable that he
didn't go for it because he still has
great control and the question is how to
continue um maybe get the other rook in
the game yeah Rook
bf1 uh Nemo is definitely you know
curling up into a ball now with Bishop
just battering the hatches against any
opening of the lines with Knight G6 or
Knight 6 F7 and queen G3 sandbags yeah
Queen G3 oo so I suspect it's connected
to some H4 H5 idea but again now Nemo is
getting closer to B4 we said this is
what it's about if B4 happens there's
something to be said for counter play
the Queen sign so I love what Nemo's
doing yeah she's boarded up the windows
and shuttered up the curtains and she's
put the sandbags against the garage and
then you wake up the next day and the
skies are blue and you know your house
is still standing and that's what can
happen in these games where one side is
constantly pressuring what worries me
more than her position is her clock
she's down to 40 seconds and the nature
of the position hasn't changed it's hard
to make a move here for black Nemo kind
of keeping the status quo she's got the
best position she's had in ages but the
attack isn't over and you called it Kasa
the queen is going to slide over Lev is
going to keep battering the king side
with G4 will will Nemo have enough gas
left in the tank to deal with the
ramifications of this position I don't
think so I'm very concerned about this
King on H7 there just seem to be some
nent tactics uh along this diagonal you
can see Queen E2 Queen takes H5 looming
and I think that's why rookie through is
played subtly entertaining Queen E2 at
some point also now that F6 is played E6
is a massive Target although a must be
said Nemo is down to 16 seconds
defending well but the time is going to
be a factor and this bishop is clocking
over time defending the two massive
weaknesses in Black's position and in
the other game Shas has just blundered a
bishop if we could go back to our birds
eye view really quickly Kristoff is
about to take the first game uh Shas was
worse for most of the game he came all
the way back and as you can see he just
overlooked the move Queen to D5 which
pins the bishop and the queen he got
himself into time pressure and he was
unable to deal with the complications
Kristoff is going to eat eat up that b
Bishop with his Queen the Knight is
protecting it and he's got some
technical work to do but I think he
should be able to convert that position
yeah he's probably going to reposition
the Knight to D2 or F3 up he's always
played Knight D2 uh maybe even go H4 to
shake the tree on the king side a little
bit and eventually the house will
collapse and in the meantime Levy has
actually broken through on the king side
with Queen takes
G6 the Clock Was A certainly a factor
and I think that's the adjustment that
Nemo's going to have to make in this
next game and it's already off they're
back in carocon land uh Levy is a been a
well-known kocan player for some time
and he's played the C5 line against the
uh against the advance it's the Ken arle
line and queen G4 I love this variation
as well hitting G7 Bishop f8 is
interesting let's let's maybe watch the
end of the the first seki Royal game and
then go straight back to uh the the AR
variation in Levy's game because I'm
actually not 100% sure that Kristoff is
doing a great job he's given up a second
Pawn Shas is sending his a pawn down the
board white has to be a little bit
precise here not to allow some sort of
Perpetual check uh in some cases a queen
trade could actually make the situation
harder to convert uh because you might
run out of Pawns yeah Knights are
notoriously poor uh with guarding Rook
pawns so The Rook pawns are the a or the
H pawns so that's why Queen trade would
basically make the Knight Tethered to
the a pawn so got to be a little bit
trickier Queen d8 is a flashy move note
that Queen takes C4 cannot be take made
Queen G8 check and I don't think that
was strictly necessary because I think
you could have gone for some Queen D5
stuff but this is uh I think this is
harder now and a harder conversion after
Queen D4 and now Knight E3 the Knight
heads over to D5 trying to set up some
sort of mating pattern queen f8 queen
takes A3 I think he's just going to pick
off the pawn and the rest is going to be
really really simple so let's see if
Kristoff finds queen f8 queen takes A3 I
think we can safely leave him to do the
rest yeah okay this one's over we let's
go back to the levy game that that at
that point at this point that's more
interesting this is over Queen E7 uh
that's going to end in a couple of moves
all right so I actually want to just
take us back just for a moment if I can
just just early on in this game because
basically this line of the advaned Caro
is very very interesting with C5 and the
point is you give up a pawn temporarily
um but you typically get it back quickly
either C5 or E5 it's quite hard to hold
on to that pawn anyway the thing that's
unique about this bishop takes E5 move
so quickly is it does allow Queen G4 and
there's pressure on G7 right away and
black has to make a decision play G6 and
create some type of weakness on the king
side punt on the PLA and play it like a
French almost like a win style or bring
the bishop back all the way to f8 which
is what our guy Levy did here and now we
have a very interesting position on our
hands where the bishop is back on f8 and
you know it would seem seem like black
lost some time but the structure in the
center is quite stable and that's why uh
black can get away with this and the
caran of course is Levy's main
recommendation in his black repertoire
opening Series so he knows this opening
backwards and forwards and obviously uh
in a match this important again it's not
necessarily about playing objectively
sound openings although I've played this
OTB it's a good opening it's about
playing structures and positions where
you know where the pieces belong you can
play fast you feel right at home
and I like what Lev's gotten out of the
opening he's got the bishop air he's got
his Center and Nemo could try to batter
away at that center with C2 C4 I think
that should be White's main strategy
here while Black's King is kind of stuck
in the center yeah if you get in C2 C4
one of the huge benefits of it is you
actually might clear the E4 Square for
your knight uh which could be at an
opportune moment really if this King
ever castles you could see the knights
combining on G5 and potentially
delivering mate on H7 and so in that
case the kolon would become you ready
for this the Carol can't but we'll see
if uh if that comes to the four and
that's why Levy is going to delay
castling pretty much as long as possible
um because he needs to figure out what
Nemo is going to do with her pieces to
determine how he's going to orient his
King yeah and uh okay
so Nemo taking her time here uh she is
playing white in this game correct just
double checking yeah yeah that's right
that's right I I do believe she's
playing white in this
one there we go uh so and I I should
also say Christopher seli did Kristoff
excuse me did actually win that game
against Royals so they're now in a
positional Affair uh and they're and
they the game going on right now so
we're not going to tune in just yet um
but he is a point up in that match he is
indeed and they've got a pretty equal
position in the second game a lot of
pieces getting traded but definitely
Kristoff seems to be in control at the
start of the match Nemo again she did
this in the first game she was burning a
lot of clock in the early middle game I
think she's trying to decide whether to
try to open up the center with C4 I also
like to move B4 to expand a little bit
on the queen side first from an
objective standpoint white is probably
slightly better due to the space
advantage and the safer King but again I
hate to be a broken record but the clock
might be a really big factor in this
match overall yeah she just took a long
think to play Rook fb1 and basically I
don't love The Rook here cuz it's it's
quite passive but the idea is clear uh
she's thinking that if I play C4 under
the right Circumstance the be line will
open up for The Rook on B1 and then
there's some initiative but the thing is
is Levy would do well to not help uh
help his opponent here and make that
happen and he's not going to take on C4
absolutely not that would allow the
Knight on D2 to not only reach C4 with
Tempo but later jump into D6 and wreak
havoc on black black center so instead
we see Bishop C5 from Levy he hits the
F2 Pawn but what's his followup going to
be is he actually going to go queenside
Castle I would be terrified to do that
because the move B4 would blast open the
queen side it would open up all the
files for White's Rooks I like the way
that Nemo has positioned her Rooks they
lie in weight like a tiger in a cage
ready to jump out and blast open the
queen side yeah and I I I'm going to
also say I really like the way Lev is
handling this too because this knight7
bishop Bishop C5 knight7 maneuver is
extremely close the point is is he's
basically just improving his pieces and
and waiting still for what White's going
to do because as long as you know black
doesn't commit the king um it's going to
be tricky to figure out exactly where
you should hit and so I really like the
decision to keep this K on King on E8
potentially reinforce the D5 Pawn now
even all give yourself the opportunity
to maybe capture with the knight at some
point um and um there's even ideas of
Shifting the bishop over to C6 so I like
the prophylaxis he's making here and
again Nemo is down a minute and this was
what happened in the previous game she
had a pretty reasonable position and
then got into time trouble and so she's
going to have to make that adjustment
absolutely and the time control isn't
getting any longer it's actually going
to get shorter after this game and and
I'm deep point of concern for Nemo
because you have to make these
adjustments in Flight you don't have 10
minutes to to consult with your coach uh
and and take a drink of water you need
to make these adjustments immediately
she's down to a minute now and I think
the reason she's burning so much clock
is the move I think she was busy
calculating it instead she's decided to
bring her Rook all the way back to F1
again we see Nemo curling up into a ball
Levy's making progress on the king side
and this game is heading his way once
again and again the benefit also of not
castling is this Rook is really putting
in work on the hline without even moving
it assert asserts so much pressure and
you could see at some point that there
being something happening on the hline
uh Bishop C6 is logical uh basically
just trying to put it on the diagonal
get all the pieces active you see these
Bishops oh that's a bad diagonal I just
drew there but you see these Bishops
storming down uh on the upon the white
king side uh black speets are extremely
active here and um that's uh that's
basically the story now there is a
potential Knight E4 and Knight C4 now
but it doesn't hit out in the same way
it once did because black basically is
controlling all of the business squares
on his side of the board and so that's a
really a huge thing when you're you're
playing like trying to figure out are is
is the real estate on my side of the
board covered I tend to just look at it
like that I'm going to draw those arrows
and if the the squares on your side of
the board are covered usually you're
you're doing you're in good shape that's
such an instructive point if you look at
that rectangle black controls all of the
squares right on the fourth rank on the
eighth Rank and notice that Lev has kept
his King in the center this entire time
so yes the Rooks are not connected I
think now would be a great time to
consider castle and kingside uh you know
better late than never but you could
also go without it you could go Rook A4
you could hit the pawn on B4 and Nemo
just hasn't managed to start her engine
at all on the queen side she hasn't
managed to create any problems against
Black's King and there's Rook A4 Levy
making moves Nemo Fighting Fire with
Fire Knight C4 is a great response
though again better late than never and
she could try to sneak that Knight into
D6 and open up that King site a little
bit maybe her other Knight will be able
to access E5 so Levy trades castles
keeping things simple again 25 seconds
Kasa that might be the story of the game
yeah and again there is one second of
increment but to make really accurate
moves uh when you're under pressure is
going to be tough and it's funny because
the dust is settled the material is
equal but white is the one left with
potential targets the B4 Pawn's a
potential Target the E5 Pawn is a
potential Target and this KN F5 is
excellent um there's always ideas to
play Knight takes G3 if you would like
at some juncture it's also controlling
D4 really the n on F5 is a little bit
better than its counterpart in F3 and
that's I think why black is is clearly
better also an escape square has already
been made and so it's just going to be
tough here in the next 10 12 seconds so
here we go Levy is winning a pawn and
you can't take on B7 because the back
rank issue but G4 Nemo trying to create
space on the back rank with Tempo so
where is the Knight going to drop back
to is it going to drop forward to D4
Levy kind of wincing there I think he
missed G4 or he saw and just didn't like
it Knight D4 King G2 Nemo defending very
well she's got drawing chances
objectively there's no question about
that but 6 seconds to defend this end
game at infinum Lev could just chill
with B6 by the way Kristoff is about to
win his second game but we can stick to
this end game for now and this end game
is going to be so tough to hold if you
just you know you just take on E3 and go
Rook B8 The Rook will be behind the pawn
it's going to be tough to to to to
defend it I think it's actually going to
be really key for white to not allow the
pawn to go much further but yeah Bishop
takes E3 now that's an ugly structure
and objectively this is just going to be
tough to hold G5 here would be a really
nice move fixing the the the white uh
King side but all right there's uh it's
not really about a big I you know it's
move by move ideas here so that's Pawn
number two that's it that's Pawn number
two that's game I mean F6 that Rook is
not trapped it can be easily defended by
the pun I would go F6 and G5 just cover
all the dark squares but he's just I
mean ly Rook C4 King
C5 just walk walking walking her down an
alley basically that's that's
essentially what's happening the the B
Pawn is going to you know just continue
to be pushed it's well supported by the
king and the Rook now and uh again
Nemo's been playing at a very very good
level until the time trouble and so
that's really the adjustment that needs
to be made and we're the pace is going
to Quicken but now Levy's taken a two
two lead and perhaps we should switch
over to seli and Royal because seli also
has a twoz lead against his young
talented opponent and we're in a a D3
ruy um we've seen many of these before
haven't we da we have and it's an
interesting choice by Kristoff to play
one E4 in this match because he is known
primarily for his uh opening
contributions in you know one Knight F3
systems he likes the Catalan but against
the Australian youngster he has shown a
pred elction uh actually for for sharper
more principled Ru Lopez lines and
actually it was Shas who changed his
opening Choice he played a sicilian in
game one now we see a Lopez and quick
executive summary of the previous game
it was an equal London system but
eventually Kristoff developed an attack
against whes King and he was able to
deliver kind of a version of Anastasia's
mate to seal off the second game so he
leads two as they start the 3 plus one
portion and uh we've got just a very
typical R Lopez position I feel like
this might as well be aonian Vash from
like 2009 you know you get this position
every time yeah seriously and it's it's
interesting to talk about the plans here
uh for both sides so a lot of times
white is banking on this A6 Pawn later
in the game being a bit of a weakness
because essentially what you have by
playing A5 is you separate the a a
Black's a pawn from the B Pawn and uh so
typically you press you could press that
later in the game in the middle game a
lot of it comes down to uh black
maneuvering their piece effectively and
sometimes preparing a D5 break under
decent circumstances although that's
quite unrealistic here and uh yeah black
normally is a bit congested and so uh
White wants a key piece on the board and
that's why Kristoff played Bishop B3 and
definitely I think it's music to
shas's ears it was a combination of his
first name and his last name maybe
that'll is next chess.com account name
the reduction in time control definitely
favors the younger player I think
there's no doubt about that um Kristoff
was benefiting from all of that extra
time he was taking sometimes over a
minute in critical moments obviously you
can't quite do that here you have to
rely more on your intuition but 3 plus
one is still a pretty generous time
control as we know from the SEC as Shas
I think he found a great time to strike
at the center with D5 this is the
classic breakthrough and if white is not
prepared for it these weak Pawns on C3
and D3 they can be targeted by Black's
Queen and you can have a hard time
defending that pawn on D3 Kasa I like
Black's position here yeah and Bishop
takes A4 was an excellent switch and Zug
or in between move basically exchanging
those Bish Bishops diverting the queen
to A4 or The Rook uh uh White chose the
queen but the problem again is this D3
Pawn's a massive Target also the Knight
on C4 don't be surprised if a well-timed
E4 could undermine the protection of
that Knight on C4 so uh it's doesn't
seem like it's the end of the world but
black definitely has a clear Advantage
here and D4 is a great reaction by
Kristof I think that was the only move
if black plays E4 which is what most
people would find tempting that Knight
could have snuck into E5 instead we have
a trade in the center and I think
black's Knight could jump into E4 right
now causing a lot of problems to these
flimsy pieces on the queen side that
Knight on C4 Bishop on D2 they're not
all that well and a 30second Time
Advantage for uh for for shus this is a
game he has to win yeah and I think
basically right now you could see that
even though this A6 Pawn still might be
a a potential it might seem like a bit
of a liability in the end game it's not
going to be easy to be attacked because
the Knight is to on C4 is two diagonals
away from it um black has excellent uh
complimentary pieces on the light
squares with this Rook on e4 Queen on D5
and basically now Kristoff's trying to
shake the tree with knight3 Shake That
blockade maybe potentially press onward
with D5 at some point after the queen A4
jets away and you can see here he's
trying to get some counterplay before
black establishes a bit more of a grip
yeah I don't like the move Rook E4 I
think sh was kind of playing for traps
he wanted to win White's Knight with
Knight B4 now he's going completely in
the wrong direction I think Queen C6
looks good even the end game does not
look bad for black uh for white because
the Rook could slide into C6 the as6
pawn is now eminently attackable Shas
has lost his entire advantage and
moreover I would actually prefer white
in this end game so just not the most
confident decision-making by the oh
922 oh and has again he still has has it
again retreating Night Moves ladies and
gentlemen but the hilarious thing is the
way he's playing is also good he's still
much better in the end game yeah this a
paon is going to you know it's just
going to run down the yellow brick road2
again I mean you can you can you're
almost at the point where you can uh
almost sack an exchange and play A6 but
not
Rook A3 might defend Knight C4 would be
very strong now because it covers the3
Square he finds the hard knight move and
misses the one move Fork yeah that's
crazy but you know you're talking about
you know you know playing for tricks
earlier and I mean I was told you know
back in the day that tricks were for
kids so I wasn't so surprised that we
had this uh this type of dynamic and uh
yeah available uh most days during the
week um A7 is going to be a huge problem
basically yeah and and you see A8 Queen
is Rook h8 check is a huge threat and
basically Black's going to have to
jettison the Bish oh no and Kristoff
wins his third game he is half a point
away from taking this match only three
games in trees needs the comeback of a
lifetime folks Kristoff seki the
representative of the older generation
leads 30-0 and the levy uh Nemo third
game is still going so let's go straight
there we've got a fascinating end game
and I think Levy might be taking his
third game as well Kasa and it's the the
time it's just the time it's not a
totally untenable position although you
do like white structure now in
particular with this nice long Pawn
chain from the D D4 to H3 um I think
Levy can afford to take the pawn on B6
and then uh kind of ask you know Nemo
what are you going to do cu the bishop
on A3 is kind of stuck um Levy chose a
different route he's basically playing
in a more principled route to give you
know create some exchanges and so on I
would have kept the pressure just
because it makes uh Nemo's decision
making harder but there's no question
that it's still easier to play for white
just cuz the structure is so healthy
yeah you're exactly right there's that
pass Pawn which Levy has just pushed I
think he might want Rook C4 now the pawn
is Untouchable because of Rook to D4
pitting the night 4 seconds for Nemo and
it's the carbon copy of the previous
game okay is the end game defensible
maybe but can Nemo do it with almost no
time on the clock she's doing a great
job so far King f8 The Rook on D6 is
defended I do do not like the decision
by Levy to trade Rooks I think he should
get his Rook out of there oh Shee King
E7 and it's a it's a w it's just a piece
up now I would keep the Rooks on the
board with Rook C7 or Rook C4 and you
know just you know these checks are
going to be hard to to Dodge in the time
trouble and Kasa that's why we keep
talking about the clock because it is
always the decisive factor it's only a
matter of time before something like
this
happens yeah Lally that these games are
a lot closer than the the final uh the
final gong makes it seem frankly so you
know just that adjustment uh needs to be
made and um it could be very different
story but this is getting seal it off
yeah
D7 and uh Nemo throws in the towel both
matches at a score of three to zero
that's pretty crazy yeah this was not
expected not expected at all and um uh
yeah I mean both both folks are going to
be fighting for their life right now now
Nemo and shus are both going to be
fighting to stay alive because it both
uh Le Levy and Kristoff only need a draw
now to
advance win their mini match and
Kristoff is very close to achieving it
he's got opposite color Bishops we could
stay on the levy match because uh that
position just seems very sterile it's a
little bit better for Shas but will he
win that position with opposite colored
Bishops and a high probability of a lot
of heavy piece trades obviously Kristoff
knows that he only needs a draw and he's
he's adjusted his opening Choice based
on that so not only do they need three
and a half points out of the next four
games but for Levy bullet might be his
strongest time control so man I don't
know what has to happen this hh4
business uh that Levy just went for is
actually really impressive stuff because
you basically take carve out more space
on the king side and you undermine this
Knight that I think started on C3 went
to E4 then to G3 and now back to E2 and
so that Knight has made a ton of mov
moves and black does have the bishop
pair and usually in these structures the
reason white gives it away is because
you have a lead in development and some
attack on the black king hard to
actually see where that's coming from
right now but I think we're actually I
think Levy is is in the driver's seat
right now I think we actually would do
well to get to Royals game in particular
because this end game he needs to win
and I think he's trying he I mean well
of course he's trying but I think he
does have some chances some Prospect of
pushing here just because Black's
queenside pawns are pretty easily
blockaded yeah he does and I think in a
classical game if you had an hour on
your clock no question Kristoff would
hold this 10 times out of 10 but in a
Blitz game the pie activity the fact
that white can generate some action on
the king side maybe with some G3 F4
nonsense later in the game maybe get
your king up okay White's got some
chances at the same time I actually like
the move B6 he gets his Pawn away from
the seventh rank I I think he's
preparing the move Rook to D7 and he's
going to seize the defile because a rook
trade is always out of the question
right a rook trade in most circumstances
is an immediate draw so Shas has to keep
going on the eighth rank with his Rook
but what's his plan going to be with the
pathway for White's King already sealed
off yeah I think he's going to tickle
the queenside pawns as he's doing with
Rook A8 he's going to probably bring
that Bishop back to C3 and slowly try to
prepare some combination of f4 Andor G4
and I think in the long run the I the
the best case scenario is that this F6
Pawn becomes a Target because Rook the
can give a check oh here we go F5 that
was a well-timed break although again
you're opening up the scope of this
bishop now so I I do think there's still
some decent chances here you take on F5
at the right and then play G4 you fix
those pawns on the dark squares there is
some winning chances here one way to
lose for black would be to recapture
with the King and then after Rook f8 to
drop back to G6 missing a four on F6 so
this kind of stuff it happens when
you're under a minute that's why
Kristoff takes the bishop but I still
like the move Rook to f8 here
threatening to infiltrate F6 he plays it
and suddenly storm clouds are starting
to gather around Black's King Kristoff
might have to evacuate his Bishop to D3
you always want your Bishop on a
defended Square he puts it on C2 now I
would still give this check and and toss
the black king back some chances remain
yeah again this majority I I like this
G4 move even though the computer isn't
liking it the idea is you're trying to
fix the black uh the black kingside pawn
structure and it's maybe a bit too early
for that but the idea is there and you
can see here that White's structure is
going to be a little bit easier to
mobilize than uh than blacks although
this construction with Bishop D1 and
Rook D3 makes it very hard to to push
the F Pawn oh King G6 Rook G7 was
Checkmate obviously Kristoff was not
born yesterday his King is driven back
to the eighth rank we're going to get a
trade of Pawns and now that B6 Pawn is
an additional Target it can be attacked
from behind with Rook B7 I think
Kristoff should take with the Rook on F3
he takes with the bishop okay he's
covering the B7 Square making it harder
for white to access that pawn but shz
goes Rook G6 he's going to pick up one
of the pawns I think he has excellent
winning chances now yeah and don't be
surprised at some juncture cuz I saw
when the bishop was on D3 earlier
there's some some positions where if the
white King's on D2 and The Rook is not
covering the bishop there might be some
B4 ideas where B is not possible because
the bishop on D3 is hanging um but we're
a bit of a ways away from that A4 is a
very very legit decision trying to push
that pawn further and now A4 is under
attack so are you willing to trade that
a pawn the computer's not a fan although
there's still some work to be done here
to hold this the problem with every Pon
tray the position gets harder and harder
to win because Rook bishop and pawn
against rook and Bishop is going to be a
a dead draw but Kristoff with eight
seconds Rook B3 is an excellent counter
Bishop C3 cut that Rook off from the
King side cut it off from the from the
third Rank and then you can activate
your own King I think that was a missed
opportunity you still can do it now
though Bishop C3 there we go plays it
now G5 is super weak Rook B5 great
defensive move by Kristoff but can he
hold this forever with 5 Seconds this
would be a miracle hold in 4 seconds
King F7 he gets his King up hard for
shes to make progress though because his
King is cut off along the fifth rank his
Rook doesn't have any good parking spots
he might do it he might pull this off
King G6 and I'll King takes C4 yeah King
takes King takes C4 was a was a would
have won the pawn you needed to win and
now it's still equal again although the
time is going to be a huge Factor here
now while we're diing through this we
should just point out Levy did win his
game and so he won his mini match
against Nemo and so this is the game
we're focusing on now and it's a
must-win for shus it's a must-win bishop
D2 and he gets it to and he does it he
does
it oh my gosh I mean oh my gosh that's
only one win the subtle fist bump from
shus is like finally I got him I got him
and and I think this is basically the
story arc we're talking about the faster
time control is going to favor the
younger talented Junior and so he's
still in it he's still in it with a
chance here yeah and and Levy's game was
completely one-sided out of the opening
a clean sweep by Rosman for zero against
Nemo he advances and uh he controlled
that match from the very first couple of
moves yeah and
so the question is is is Kristoff going
to make an adjustment because it has
felt like he's been in control
throughout and you know basically you
know a loss can kind of tilt you a
little bit but he only needs a draw here
I hope he plays with ambition cuz you
see a lot of times people only needing a
draw and then making concession after
concession along the way to try to get
that draw so uh hopefully he uh he plays
a normal game here might see the bishop
B5 stuff again the Moscow
variation um against the
Sicilian okay here we go Christoff has
the white pieces this is really the game
I think where where his bread should be
buttered he's got white he's so solid uh
due to his extensive opening knowledge
and I like this Choice he doesn't go for
E4 Cas he goes for his Knight F3 B3
stuff he he maybe knows it better and
it's a little bit more positional but 10
seconds already off his
clock yeah and right now the setup I
think is going to favor white in the
long run because you have this play
against the iqp and basically I think
Kristoff's got a dream position right
now he's probably to play knight2 and
just massage the D4 Square indefinitely
this is exactly what you want he puts a
bishop on D4 also good the Knight can
slide over to G3 threatening Knight F5
he might induce this very weakening move
G6 and now that's a pawn queen takes D5
on the other hand he gives up the bishop
pair so that gives shr some Dynamic
chances Kristoff has to be a little bit
careful in these next couple of moves
where he puts his Queen great move Queen
G5 Queen G5 is an excellent choice um
Queen trades are just not desirable now
now Knight F5 Knight F5 that is a
massive Tempo on the bishop and you're
looking at the G7
square and you're threatening Brook 81
which would win on the well not win on
the spot but effectively you would win
on the spot if you could force black to
play Queen F6 because not only would
there be a trade of Queens if the bishop
moves away from D6 there will likely be
further trades no knight4 should just
end the game yeah and it's found pretty
instantly and draw Knight H6 Knight F5
you can force a draw right now by
repetition yeah and does he want more
because that's you know there's I I
think Rook A1 also is sufficient but
yeah he goes for this repetition which
wins the match that is
up such a you see this in the World Cup
you don't care whether you win all you
need is a draw easy clap Kasa that was
so well done by Kristoff yeah and he
wasn't in a whisker of danger the whole
time I mean shus did not have a chance
so very impressive stuff great opening
play by both of these players that
concludes the first two matches folks
kristov zetki chess explained as he
takes a sip from that gargantuan water
bottle he deserves it because he has won
3 and 1 half 1 and A2 against the
Australian Phenom Imus Royal those two
victories in the 5 plus one portion by
both Levy and Kristoff that did their
opponents in it's so hard CA to come
back from a two-point deficit uh given
the constraints of these matches yeah no
question I think already there's some
like there's some lessons or learnings
from it one thing I think that we're
learning very very quickly is that you
have to really manage your time well
because it doesn't really matter how
what your position is going to look like
if you have 10 20 seconds to navigate it
and you're still under pressure um so I
think I think that's one of my big
takeaways thus far absolutely well said
folks we are going to go on our first
break of the day give these players a
little bit of a breather but the action
is not over as we look at our group
group b cross table 40 by Levy he scores
a victory Kristoff scores a victory Shas
and Nemo they will have some winning to
do but they will have a different
opponent I think they're a little bit
more well adjusted to the constraints of
the match you're watching the I am not a
GM speed chest Championship we will be
back with more fun matches on the other
side of this break stay
[Music]
tuned love playing chess variant or just
looking for something new join us for
the variant Community series every two
months we'll be featuring a different
variant in a series of events and
competitions learn a new variant and
compete against other players for prize
money or just play for fun look for
Community Arenas streamer Arenas and
Championship events six weekly Arena
tournaments held every Thursday will be
followed by a championship event with
cash prizes including a $11,000 first
place prize the third and final weekly
Arenas will be streamer Arenas featuring
gifted Subs as prizes win any of these
events to qualify for the championship
the variant Community series kicks off
on September 7th with King of the Hill
where the first to occupy the center
wins the game but getting checkmated
still loses and join the variant club
today to learn more about upcoming
events how to participate and much much
more
see you in the arena on chess.com
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
B
International master Kristoff seli who
managed to win the first of the matches
against Shas Royal who I was mistakenly
referring to as Australian he is in fact
British uh is the young International
Master but he met his defeat at the
hands of Chess explained a great Blitz
player such a recognizable chess
personality uh and a deserving
participan in the IM not a GM speed
Chess Championship which you are
watching the 2022 chessable author of of
the Year Kasa how many players have
built their entire repertoires on what
this guy has done yeah I was going to
say you don't think these guys want it
because uh in his last game he closed
out against shus he definitely went for
some stuff he's written about with this
Knight F3 B3 E3 business and it was to
great effect the guy is an amazing
player amazing teacher and it's it's Al
it's always cool when people practice
what they
preach absolutely um and Levy was also
practicing what he preached we saw a
carocon from him we saw chowski we saw
all of his opening recommendations on
the strength of which he managed to
score a 4-0 clean sweep of Nemo Xiao
here are the standings folks pretty
simple right now Levy and Kristoff won
their first matches Shas and Nemo lost
and now the matches Shuffle and uh the
tournament goes on we will have Levy
against Kristoff and shus against Nemo
really really EXC exciting to already
have the winners facing off Kasa yeah
and I think it's going to be a real
contrast of styles we saw in the the
matches that Levy and Zi won Levy was
you know playing extremely aggressively
and Zi was really playing in his you
know his sort of patented positional
style so we'll see how that how that
develops and then in the other matchup
trus uh you know basically found his
footing towards the end of the match and
just he was kind of stuck in the mud
early on and uh Nemo needs to play a
little faster she's been playing well
but not playing fast enough to deal with
the time scrambles but we're off and I
think we should probably dive into uh
our uh our our the levy excuse me Levy
and zi's match up right now cuz we have
I I was flabbergasted because I was like
wait this is a trompowsky but then not
really cuz there's bit H6 and G5 it just
there's a mess on the board and from our
perspective there's so many names that
we have to keep track of like at all
times you have to be ready to say
anybody of these four players uh so it
could be a little bit hard okay Levy
with a trumpski what a trumpski it is is
this still preparation is this in one of
my opening courses so I actually have a
question for you da because the Knight
never developed to F6 so D4 D5 Bishop G5
technically not a trompowsky right I
think it's called something else like a
I think it's like theit levitzki that's
the one that's the name that's the name
I was going to say it and then I like no
you know it's when when you think you
remember something then you're like no
it can't be that uh sometimes happens
when you watch Jeopardy and you think
you know the answer and then you don't
say it and you kind of regret it yeah it
is the
levitzki and I'll say this black is
extremely well prepared because
essentially right now he is
temporarily in a bit of a messy T type
of position but his bishon G7 is quite
active this n on A6 is prime to
recapture on C5 and I think for many
folks at home you might say why not
Bishop takes A6 and B takes A6 and
doesn't black structure seem awful well
black would have the two Bishops and
excellent counterplay against along the
B file at some juncture B2 might be
quite weak not right away because the
bishop on G3 is covering but you know I
have this buice for the bishop pair and
um you know I think basically all of
Levy's play here is it's just a bunch of
short-term assets if zi is able to
navigate that he has the long-term
trumps a little off topic but fun his
iCal fact for for players levitzki full
name step on levitzki was a 19th century
Russian Master uh but what he is most
famous for uh is that he was on the
losing side of one of the most famous
games actually one of the most famous
moves in chess history Frank James
Marshall the US champion played this
move Queen G3 putting his Queen on pre
uh against three different pawns against
levitzki in 19112 and people watching
the show uh you can Google litzky
Marshall really quickly as you're
watching the show if you want want to
see the move but a lot of you I'm sure
will have heard of this game and yet
levitzki that's not all he did he also
contributed directly to opening Theory
okay so Knight comes out to D2 I have no
idea how to evaluate this position I'm
not even going to try E3 hold on is this
even chess yeah I mean basically you
have this bishop pair from hell that's
essentially raining down on White's
position and this is why Black's able to
jettison these pawns because these
Bishops are performing an excellent job
of controlling the business squares in
the middle of the board and this king is
feeling mighty Airy so Advantage black
although it's still a mess and uh you
know there'll be there'll be more
developments from here but you already
have to deal with how do you defend that
E3 Pawn Levy goes for Queen F3 but it
does allow Rook da with Tempo and the
pressure's on Levy is really stuck in
mud right now that Rook hits the Knight
on D2 Rook D1 comes to mind and if white
plays Rook Rook
D1 oh keep the Flames
burning yeah basically G4 you try to
dislodge the queen F3 and if you the
queen actually does capture this queen
takes E3 which is just devastating
because this K E1 is just in a horrible
horrible way uh it's it's kind of
intuned by uh its own pieces I wonder
what White's next move is like if black
also just plays a slower developing move
like Knight F6 is Levy going to jump out
to E four with his Knight and try to
orchestrate or even Knight B3 try to
orchestrate some heavy piece trades it's
hard for white I mean Black's Queen is
is more stable than it appears yeah and
I think pay four KN I think you're
totally right about that because now you
do get Knight B3 you get this
opportunity to trade some pieces and
that's what Levy desperately needs so I
was suggesting I wasn't suggesting for
Kristoff to walk into that move and like
deliberately provoke it I was just
saying maybe you need to make a
developing move move he's forced Levy to
find the best move and now he might have
to take on D1 and once all the trades
happen let's not lose sight of the FASA
white is up a pawn I hate to be that guy
but white is up a pawn it's totally
justified to be that guy um and this C
Pawn is a potentially really dangerous
one the other thing you should one
should point out here is this bishon G7
which I was sort of bragging about
before is a bit blunted on this diagonal
in particular by the C3 pawn and the
bishop on G3 so Knight of6 makes a lot
of sense trying to kind of shake the
tree on the king side um Knight E4 might
be an important intermediate move here
cuz I can't really afford to trade any
more heavy pieces on the topic of being
up a I have a fun story to share that
all Russians speaking chess players know
about this is a chess phrase uh but I'll
wait until the conclusion of the game
because we've got an exciting end game
to watch and yeah we've got no Rooks on
the
94 yeah it makes sense I mean basically
you're you're trying to kind of you know
keep keep some more pressure on uh on on
white there Knight takes C5 now the C
Pawn is the most dangerous Pawn on the
board and so eliminating that uh would
be huge and this bishop on A4 is
conveniently pinning the Knight on B3
but still messy can you play GH here G
takes H6 Knight takes G3 H takes G7 I I
think Lev is spotted and I think that's
what he's GH there maybe bishop takes C3
though it's a mess to be sure um and uh
I think Levy likes these messes so um I
think he he'd probably do well to take a
little bit more time and think about it
but not too much because again we see
time plays a factor later on but um he
goes for 92 much safer decision does
allow the recapture on G5 I think the
worst is over for zi I remember growing
up Levi Rosman hey pretty good at these
positions 92 is a very measured response
you're develop it's a logical move
you're developing your you're defending
your Bishop now you have to defend the
C5 Pawn which is hanging because the B3
Knight is pinned but how are you going
to defend it yeah that is uh that's the
million dollar question yeah you're not
that's essentially the maybe but okay
try to attack
A7 I you know chat we're gonna have to
figure out how many um Impressions is Da
G to give us in this broadcast today I
think we're gonna have to have an over
under I'm going to say I'm going to set
the over under at
nine I think we already have like four
or five so I think we'll get there but
anyways we have a position now where
essentially the issue is this Pawn was
hanging and I think King C1 is a smart
decision because you're basically saying
in order to get this Pawn C5 you're
going to have to jettison the bishop
pair which is uh you know a huge part of
blacks fishion so that's why zi is
actually saying I'm actually not going
to rush to take this pawn and see if I
can get it under better terms and
conditions you know some people we we
when we we sign we look at these
products and we just sign away our sign
away our rights you know these terms and
conditions except except Lev's like nah
I'm good uh or excuse me zi's like I'm
good I'm going to slow it down and uh
and not rush to capture on C5 this has
been very well handled by black I mean
we're taking for granted that both
players really this was an ultra
complicated position in a Blitz game
it's so easy to blunder and yet other
than some minor inaccuracies I think the
players uh have handled it really really
well but Levy is in the same spot that
Nemo was in his previous match he's got
the 4 seconds to play this entire end
game and I'm getting worried about
Black's Pawn majority Casa on the king
side there we go F5 you're mentioning
Bishop C6 will hit the G2 pawn and if
you eliminate the G2 Pawn black will
have a three onone Kristoff doesn't seem
happy though he might have overlooked
this move Knight A5 that covers the C6
Square Well Done by Levy to keep the
bishop at Bay at least for now yeah just
a few moves ago Bishop C6 would have
netted the G2 Pawn with no problems and
that three-on-one would have been a
reality now it's just not going to
happen
um because black has to essentially
babysit um the C Pawn a little bit and
this majority could get a little
menacing and so it's hard to imagine now
the G Pawn gets picked off although
maybe there's some Bishop B5 Bishop F1
ideas Bishop B5 maybe will be met with
C4 Kristoff activating his reserves
Bishop F6 to d8 will be an option
hitting that Knight freeing up the C6
square but now his light squ Bishop is
gasping for for air yeah basically
inviting the bishop to come to B5 now so
I think again Bishop B5 with this idea
to go to F1 makes a lot of sense um okay
Alex for Bishop C6 this will be captured
immediately and we have this very very
peculiar end game on our hands where
both sides have a majority but this king
is yeah it's bizar it's bizarre it's
bizarre um like and where's where do you
want to go with this King you could
literally go this way or you could could
go through via C4 it's a it's a fun
question to figure out where this king's
going to go my my coach would always say
if you have a position like this it's
always going to be equal like if you
don't know what's going on probably the
game is going to end in a Dr he's allow
C6 that was questionable now this bishop
can come to F2 take on A7 and uh that's
going to be too many pawns it's going to
be a three-on-one even if black
eliminates the C6 PA which he has to I
think black has to try King D5 but When
the Smoke Clears and it's finally
cleared after King D3 Kristoff is
shaking his head Black's Pawn majority
is not going to result in a new Queen
White's King is way too close Levy
should be able to convert this into a
win now now I will say just for the
folks at home this is the wrong color
Corner um so there could be C certain
circumstances where if White's only left
wi it with the a pawn and this dark
Square Bishop it won't be enough to win
King D5 and King D5 might be a chance to
get this bishop okay
there there's this is still not
completely over um again oh I was going
to say don't rush to trade on B5 because
now it's too connected on the BNC files
this is there's no no chance for uh for
a draw here but okay zi had to resign
that one but that was a very very high
level game until the time trou and I
think I've said that a few times now but
zi really you know I think he showed his
strengths and his weaknesses in that one
I'm so impressed with how Levy handled
that with no time on his but Kristoff
got in his own head he was shaking his
head and moving his but it was still
almost a draw and I think that Kristoff
was mad about the way he played the
earlier endend game and that interfered
with his ability to hold that position
what a game Levy takes the first game on
the right side we still have the first
game and it looks like Shas is going to
take that one he is up a knight and yeah
Black's king is not in time to access
wh's pawns that one's over and Shas
takes the first game against Nemo it was
a top C Turvy Affair but the British not
the Australian the British youngster
will win this one and I'm will he I
there is some potential tricks but I I
trust he will convert this and yet he
Knight F2 holds this one I'm going to
just draw some arrows on the zi Rosman
game because this queen this bishop to
F5 and then Queen C8 to Bishop to H3
maneuver is was a lot of time and so now
white has this opportunity to
potentially jump in the center in the
next she moves with E5 and I think
that's the way zi's got to punish this
um otherwise well bringing the queen to
H3 I'm not a huge fan of but Knight G5
is a reasonable followup hitting the
queen um Lev's basically basing his
whole plan on some Tom Foolery with H4
but it's just not fast enough basically
yeah it's a very dubious setup chosen by
Levy at the same time he's playing to
his strength Levy is a very talented
tactician he's super tricky and he's
trying to get one of those kg positions
get Kristoff out of his opening
preparation Kristoff says listen I want
an endgame that's really all I want if
I'm Levy I'm saying great I trade Queens
go Knight
bd7 maybe get parked that Knight on C5
Kings Indian style sure I I think
black's doing fine now yeah and I think
the thing is is by you know the reason I
didn't love H5 when it happened and this
queen C Bishop C3 is cuz there was a
lack of development there was a bit of a
neglect in in the center and by trading
Queens in the way that zi did he
basically punted on all on punishing all
of those potential Dynamics and so now
the the space grab with H5 is a bit more
legitimate um you know Black's pieces
start to make a little bit more sense
and space is still a factor but it's not
as prominent a factor as it was um with
more pieces on the board and so that's
why the boots on the ground have changed
just a little bit I think the games have
settled enough for me to quickly share
my story with with your permission Kasa
so remember when Levy was up upon PA
anytime anyone is you're analyzing with
a Russian speaking player and uh
anyone's up upon there is a common
phrase and the phrase goes in the
opinion of international Master matak
kanyan Armenian I am black is up upon PA
or white is up upon PA why is that funny
so The Story Goes that in Soviet times
in the 60s there was a world
championship match that was going on
between I think petan and spasy And the
reporter that was assigned to cover the
match for one of the top newspapers did
not play chess it was a mistake made by
the editing of apparently there was a
Soviet person who didn't play chess and
she's writing a report uh on one of the
games and the game was adjourned after
move 40 people know that games used to
be adjourned uh and one of the
commentators of the match was this
Armenian IM Edward matak kanyan so the
reporter asks Edward how would you
evaluate the position after Mo 40 and
matak kanyan goes well petan is up a
pawn but blah blah blah blah blah and he
starts assessing the position but in the
actual newspaper article the first
phrase was in the opinion of I am natak
kanyan black is up upon why is that
funny because the reporter didn't
understand that being up upon is not a
matter of opinion like it's a fact that
black is up upon so that's why it's
supposed to be funny but it's a common
phrase did that make sense like does it
make sense why it's funny it does and I
think you know it's it's interesting
because there's a lot of like situations
like that where like you know you know
understanding like what's happening and
why sometimes is not obvious to someone
that's like familiar with the territory
right so it's just this Dynamic of like
this person's basically staying stating
something as if it was opinion but it's
fact and there are many things like that
that happen in chess what he actually
said was black is up a pawn but in my
opinion white has compensation and it
got mistranslated to in his opinion
black is up a
pawn all right well anyway speaking of
up a pawn and uh and back to the game
the game in front of us the material is
actually equal I counted wrong I thought
that that black was up upon for a second
but the materials actually equal uh and
it's a really interesting uh position of
who's better and why because you have a
bishop and Knight and balance um you
have you know some pawns that look
menacing in the center but they're
pretty well blockaded
and you know it's really one of these
positions where I actually would prefer
white because this Knight on A4 is
pretty unimpressive to me um this bishop
is doing an excellent job uh controlling
the pawns and also eyeing some key the
key diagonal some key squares on the
king side and I think if you had to ask
yourself what's the strongest Pawn on
the board right now the most dangerous I
actually want to say it's the G Pawn um
and so just because white has so many
pieces that are close to the ewn and so
I would prefer white here I absolutely
would prefer White the bishop dominates
the Knight Black's Pawn structure looks
impressive but you called it Kasa the
pawn with the most potential energy to
become a queen is the Pawn on G4 it's
got you know it's 401K it's it's got all
its finances settle where the pawn on e4
has already taken all the money off the
bank account it's not really getting to
E3 anytime soon now who does The Rook
trade
favor it definitely favors black because
you know basically black needed to get
some counterplay and the B file is where
that's going to potentially happen this
king is also kind of boxed in at the
moment by these two pawns the E and H
Pawn and so this why the king is trying
to Nestle in a little bit closer to the
center maybe position itself in a way
where it's not going to be you know
Tethered to the second or the first rank
but very very interesting I think that
the the position has changed a little
bit since I said I like white just
because now Black's pieces seem to be a
little bit more active than they were
before and I also see Knight B2 as a
possibility maybe this Knight actually
will assert itself
self definitely now Knight B2 looks like
a great way to get that Knight back into
the action what is the setup that
Christoph is aiming for I think he wants
to to Center his King on E3 or E2 first
of all do not play G5 and miss the fork
on D3 do not play Rook B1 and allow a
discovered check so there's always
tricks to dodge when you're playing
against the Knight I would play Rook F1
or King E2 so I'm I'm going to ask you
for a moment cuz I know how much you
love positions with F5 and Kings Indian
style that we switch very briefly to the
Royal zo game Nemo game because we have
a mess in the center with F5 and F4 and
I just I just need your I need your your
take on this because it would seem that
black is much better position to open
things up my Kings Indian take on this
my Kings Indian take on this is that
black has a position that I have in my
like best Kings Indian dreams I've never
actually had uh a structure this good in
my life we've got a pawn Cube and just
for that reason alone we have to devote
this game some attention I'm also
keeping an eye on the levy game we'll
get to that game uh once the end game
clarifies I think black is better and I
would play a move like Queen E7 keep the
tension Casa I would not prematurely
start trading pawns at least until I've
developed my bishop and connected the
Rooks yeah and I you know when you say
connecting your Rooks it just like music
to my ears like I I truly believe the
side that connects the Rooks first in a
lot of POS winds up winning the game and
this 94 move it it in a way it releases
releases tension because we're talking
about keeping the pawn tension the peace
tension is a is a factor in that now by
playing the Knight on e4 you allow Nemo
this opportunity to consolidate and
clarify the situation in the center and
have less pressure on uh on their own
pieces that night on D2 was a spectator
it was not doing much and now it got to
exchange itself off for a really active
Knight that was once on C5 so Nemo can
be thrilled with this development
absolutely and F takes E5 such a heads
up move by Nemo because if instead she
had taken on If instead she had taken on
e4 that would have allowed Knight takes
F4 that just gives up a pawn that might
be what shes was aiming for instead she
first takes on E5 then she's going to
recapture on e4 and as you said Casa
that Knight is heading straight for E6
or C6 impatient by Shas and I think Nemo
has a good chance here uh to recover
in game two I think maybe we should drop
back to our bird's eye view because
we've got more action on the levy board
uh but I still want to keep an eye as
this game unfolds we can get the both
The Best of Both Worlds yeah and here we
go basically now this this King on on E2
is about to get drop back to the first
Rank and it's going to be in a cage
essentially and so now all of a sudden
the most dangerous PA on the board is
that E Pawn the G Pawn has been gobbled
up when you know no the terms and
conditions change this King now has
potential to get escalate down the board
potentially to D3 one day and this Rook
if it ever moves the King was just going
to advance a bit further so E3 and king3
over and Kristoff is the one who's got a
minute and a half but it feels like
Levy's the one who's got an hour on his
clock he's so calm and somehow Kristoff
keeps losing his mind in these equal end
games yeah and it's funny because
stylistically it is the end games where
he
I would suspect he him to assert himself
you know and it would seem that instead
he's actually been basically on the back
foot perhaps again it's a little bit of
karma sometimes when you have a position
where it's so dominant early on and you
elect to kind of not prosecute that
advantage that uh you know you know bad
things happen there maybe there was some
justice in chess sometimes and I think
what what makes Levy one of the
favorites in this entire field is his
ability to stay calm in time pressure
Kristoff res there's nothing to play for
King E4 King D3 is game over and that's
a lot of respect shown to Levy Kristoff
knowing that he can convert that even
with 10 seconds left great stuff by Levy
he wins a second endgame and Kristoff
with his back against the wall takes a
sip of coffee just says I need to
stabilize I need to come back in the
three-minute portion looks like a good
position for Nemo as well yeah Nemo
looks like she's going to get on the
board here she has a menacing Pawn a
menacing E Pawn that one on E6 is just
extremely dangerous and let's not forget
that A5 Pawn we had a structure in
another game uh in the previous match
between zi and Royal where we talked
about this a Pawn on A6 versus the pawn
a the white Pawn A5 now that a pawn
might be a weakness one day I see the A6
Pawn being a weakness later although I
wouldn't have opposed a queen trade
there um maybe with some combination of
Queen takes G5 or Rook E1 I don't love
dropping the queen back to E2 because
you now you allow some checks like Queen
F4 Queen f four maybe D4 breaking in in
the center ultimately black would like
to create a pass Pawn on the queen side
and once again Nemo not able to handle
her clock while she's got 5 seconds but
the position is relatively clarified so
it's easy to play Rook e one and E7 she
puts her Rook on D1 pressuring the D5
Pawn man this is Peak tension can shes
keep things stable with a move like Rook
to
E8 and uh while we figure that out I'm
just going to draw some arrows here
because H4 again has been played by Levy
and he's trying to get some stuff going
on the king side and I will not be
surprised the Knight jumps to G5 one
day and sorry I've been mesmerized but
his Nemo made a move with one second
left and the e- pawn is gone the ewn is
gone where' it Go and will we have a
Perpetual check no shre playing for a
win Nemo has to move she's losing it
she's losing the game she's down a pawn
now and now he's ging some time with
checks and he can play G5 trying to
limit the activity of white Rook Nemo
staying afloat for
now but will she be able to keep the
balance for the rest of the game yeah
and queen trades are basically off
limits now and so this King on ac6 is
basically got its it's hiking boots on
and it's surviving it's it's doing it's
thriving it's it's it's live live what
is it live laugh love it's doing a great
job so eat pray love live laugh Queen C7
he goes King D6 he's blunder A6 with ch
and and then Queen B6 check and now the
game turning
around now this q& H1 is still very
exposed so you have to basically take
stuff with and she's won the queen Rook
takes G5 Rook takes D5 Nemo wins the
game that was insane and a comeback
Victory shes can't believe it how did
she do that that was a clutch win and
Nemo knows it she is thrilled you can
see her on screen there beaming because
that was a much much needed win to
equalize the match so now we're back
actually we can switch to rosan and zi's
game where again this Bish one B I don't
know what to make of this this Bish 1 B2
is basically in jail uh but on the other
side these Knights have real promise so
you know black has got to be better with
this bishop on B2 and this Pawn wedge
with on D3 and C4 but it's still a mess
because all the piece are on the board
and at some point if this chain can be
well properly undermined it might turn
yeah I mean we've got our share of
unorthodox unconventional Pawn
structures in the the ly match yeah we
can definitely zero in on that one uh
because on the other board we have a
relatively tame Main Line Ru Lopez to
kick off the three-minute portion
Kristoff is down by two he really really
needs to win this one with black First
Impressions Casa is that black has the
upper hand but again it's such a
difficult position to evaluate and A4
doesn't feel feel like the right way to
prosecute this Pawn structure yeah and
we and we spoke a little bit earlier
about undermining the pawn train and the
problem with these early uh
encroachments into White's position with
A5 and A4 is you're actually helping
white in a way because you're actually
weakening your own Pawn chain and you're
making a little bit easier to get at
some of those targets and so I could
easily see a future now where there's
some pressure on the C4 pawn and already
actually Bishop takes C5 and Knight E4
is a
nasty great stuff by oh Queen A4 I mean
A4 was a that that was a pawn an A4 that
just disappeared A4 was a terrible move
by Kristoff that that is the move which
is likely to lose the game he's losing
literally all of his pawns Pac-Man style
one after the other Queen takes C4 there
Knight takes E5 no he's threatening
Bishop G1 look at this he's threatening
Bishop G1 how do we like King H3 as a
nice little profis better than King H1
which walks into Knight F5 and you
called those light squares out on the
king side Levy does have to be on on
alert but he just grabs another Pawn hey
sometimes you can get away with it if he
manages to get the queen out of the way
uh and start to mobilize although
Black's Bishops are quite decent um so
you know in conjunction with the Knight
coming to F5 this is not going to be
some trivial conversion oh definitely
definitely not C3 is going to be is is
basically a Target now um you know there
could be some Rook A8 and Bishop A6
Dynamic to slow those pawns down and so
I wouldn't be surprised if we have some
type of Knight takes F7 and Knight G5
stuff if this bishop on E7 ever leaves
that diagonal yeah definitely and I I'm
still counting the pawns I can't believe
that Levy's actually up three pawns it
looks like a completely normal position
everything's fine there's one small
difference that black is doesn't have a
queen side it's a small issue Oh's given
up D4 yeah although these trades I they
they're just going to help white
ultimately because the C Pawn is going
to be so strong and let's not forget
there's also still an a pawn which is
controlling being is you know that
queening square and eight is controlled
by the bishop on G2 so very very hard to
set up some type of meaningful blockade
here yeah that a pawn is lying and
waight saying I want my moment in the
Sun but right now it's the C Pawn's
moment in the sun
C6 black intention here this is uh Queen
takes D2 almost works not quite but
we're almost at that point where C7 uh
becomes a thing if that Rook was not
unprotected uh you you're almost at a
point where you can sack your queen in
some circumstances basically black has
to chase this Rook uh before C7 happens
but C7 can happen right now actually C7
Queen takes Queen A8 but Ley just going
you know Russian school boy mode just
moving The Rook up Queen takes A2 black
basically has to keep the queen pinned
tagged to the rook and again C7 works I
would play C7 that's the cleanest win
yeah 100% I think the the thing about it
too is that there's just no pressure on
the G2 Bishop so the queen would be
comfortable kind of darting away but C7
again C7 again yeah Queen takes F2 now
actually
works yeah this this is
enough is going to have to resign this
one as
well you can recapture The Rook with the
Rook on C3 and just be up a clean rook
and there we go 3 dominating fashion for
Levy thus far playing really really
powerful chess and ultimately winning
the time scrambles that's been the
detail of today uh is those time scribs
have been huge we have a really cool
position in in Royal uh and Nemo if we
can get to that briefly because this is
some really classical kavian stuff and
the reason I say that is because you
have this pressure on both sides of the
board you have the pressure on the H H6
Pawn which is hanging but you also have
this nice buildup on the queen side um
and this is beautiful stuff by Royal
this might be a case of the kids
actually knowing the classics I think
it's pretty scary how much the how much
the kids know these days and look at
this Knight G5 switching seamlessly from
the queen side to the king side that
Rook is about to lead uh the charge with
Rook e 3 Rook F3 I think that's the
decisive maneuver Knight F5 I was going
to say Knight F5 that looks even more
Dynamic cuz basically the queen after
Queen takes F6 you're you have so many
things you could do um but uh I I think
you can actually almost pick up uh one
of White's Queen side pieces like the
bishon D3 maybe even The Rook on A5 in
some situations and still be winning
that's how that's how dangerous this
attack is on the king side and Nemo has
had enough of that that was a beautiful
beautiful uh uh basically example of
playing on both sides of the board it's
a completely different time I mean 20
years ago it would be Unthinkable for
you know players of this age to handle
uh strategic complex situations with
with this level of poise but I mean now
the kids all study the classics at age
four and you know by the time they turn
five and they learn how to you know how
to eat with a spoon they're already
familiar with more than half of Robert
Fischer's games and you know karpov's
end games it's a different time man it
it it totally is and um yeah the game
the game ideas about the game the
perception of the game just changes and
so we see an evolution with this young
talent but anyway let's get back to uh
actually maybe maybe see the bird's eye
viw for a little bit longer but
basically zi's in a in a must win
situation because he's down three 0 and
he's got a position that's that's viable
right now I do think I slightly prefer
white because of the pressure in the
center uh the control of the center
rather rather the this F Pawn has in
pushed I don't like that although black
is actually quite solid as well the
Rooks can be connected on the next move
you know I like that this 9 E4 might be
a Target um okay Queen E6 does allow
Knight G5 and I think that has to be
played yeah but I just to point out that
a draw wins Levy the match first to
three and a half wins so if you're
Kristoff you're fighting two enemies
you're almost siming one is an enemy
called Levy Rosman the other is the fact
that every decision you make you have to
also ask yourself is this bringing the
game closer to a draw because a draw is
tantamount to a loss so from that
perspective I like what kristofh has a
dynamic tactical position as he pushes
the Knight off of F5 but Levy later in
the game can slide his Queen up to E5
you can't do it yet well right now the
Knight is hanging but if you do it in
this position then after the trade white
will have a fork on E6 yeah I I I do
love this repositioning of the Knight
that Levy went for with Knight H6 Knight
G4 it's very nearly an outpost and I the
reason I say that is because this F Pawn
can be pushed to to Target the Knight
but you don't feel great about it
weakening the diagonal and so on and uh
Levy's even comfortable trading queens
now because he's felt like he's
established enough control his pieces to
kind of negate the the space that white
has with his pawns but okay they more
twists and turns in G5 opening the king
while the Queens are still on the board
a little bit of a question mark to me as
well as the engine I'm going to I
actually I'm going to veto that I like G
G5 and in general I like the fact that
Levy isn't changing his style based on
the fact that he only needs a draw
that's the best way to lose all three
games is to artificially modify the way
you normally play here we see again
pandemonium on the board Knight E3
allows Queen to F2 very important detail
the queen on D4 is
unprotected yeah look at that buildup in
the center again this Knight on G4 I
said it before when the opponent is f on
F2 now it's an extremely clear Outpost
and you can see it's lording over the H2
square there's dark squares that are
very soft and and this King G7 is quite
secure uh frankly now knight3 is an
excellent move because we talked about
before Queen F2 being a oh Rook takes E4
now Rook takes E4 crashing down defends
the Knight on E3 and the exchange
sacrifice would open up the bishop that
is a bad Arrow but from me but you get
the point Kasa Queen F2 Bishop takes E4
Rook takes E3 even Queen takes E3 look
at those tactics yeah we got to show
this if Levy doesn't play but he
probably will
C4 yeah and and and again this this
bishop here is just coming down it's so
dangerous right now you you can't you
can't break this you can't break this
construction right now and no this Rook
on f8 is also lying in Wake to to exert
some influence but Queen takes
E4 Queen takes C4 that's it King H2
Knight G4 is going to be the match and
King G1 Queen H1 mate oh my goodness we
I got to show that King G1 Queen H1
Checkmate look at that woo
it's resign time for Kristoff he's going
to be down a full minor piece in the end
game and Levy takes another match 4-0
and a fist pump he deserves it he's up 8
Z over his opponents in the I am not a
gmcc come on yeah and it look at the way
he's Prosecuting these attacks it's just
body blow after body blow after body
blow um I feel like I'm watching chess
boxing dude Levy Levy is playing Amazing
chess I mean G5 there yeah maybe it's a
mistake
objectively but he sensed that he wanted
to take this match in style he didn't
just want to end it with a whimper you
know with some draw uh in some long end
game defensive task he wanted to win
that fourth game this is honestly great
stuff by Levy his form is pretty scary
right now yeah and I will say zi is is a
guy that is very very good positionally
but he just hasn't been able to put it
all together today and it's a credit to
Levy but as we get into this this game
we're looking at on screen between Nemo
and Royal uh oh what happened there what
game Nemo Nemo blund her Queen earlier
and now she blunders another exchange
and yeah I was going to say there might
have been some hope uh with a you
there's a rook and Knight for the queen
but not after you lose an exchange there
so that was a a tough tough break for
Nemo but the match isn't over yet and we
going to focus on this one because this
is the only one going on right now after
Levy clinched and we have an Italian how
does Nemo handle this one
okay normal stuff thus
far yeah Nemo has to win both of the
bullet games in order to force
Armageddon that's T order sh is a good
experienced bullet player and we've got
a lot of Trades here in the early going
yeah and I've seen so many so many games
take this course uh especially with fuia
playing the white side of these with
Bishop takes A7 and A5 and Knight F1 to
sometimes to Knight H2 and G3 and King
G2 it's it's so we've seen these so many
times D4 playing it now a lot of times
you really wait on that break um but the
idea now is you're kind of forcing the
action I would just trade on E5 trade
the Bishops and start surrounding the E5
Pawn with Knight C4 oh there is
apparently which was missed to little
too late that ship was sailed when you
have those a lot of times when they're
doubled pawns the square in front of the
double pawns can become a Target and and
sometimes an outpost for minor pie and
so that's why that Knight on G6 had F4
or H4 to work with after that exchange
sacrifice Nemo's playing way too
passively she had to go bobbing for
apples with Queen D2 when you're in a
must-win situation you can't you know
you can't play moves like Queen d8 and
now Knight to G4 a retreating move
hitting the queen guarding the pawn and
then H takes G5 is going to seal the
deal because you're also going to lose
E6 oh and rug G3 no this is over yeah
it's everything must go sale um
essentially I think Nemo actually saw
Knight G4 I saw her react on screen um
and again it's a bullet game and so we
actually had this discussion in a
previous SEC da where when it shifts to
Bullet with the OnePlus One you
sometimes play Too Fast um and maybe
that was the case there but Nemo is down
to her last five seconds and it's
trouble here yeah the issue in this game
was the opening it was too quiet there
were too many trades going on and when
Nemo tried to complicate the game you
know she ended up dropping a bunch of
her puns but still a couple moves left
to be made here fores who is okay with
the draw draw wins the match for him but
unless he blunders a full heavy piece I
cannot okay Queen E6 is going to be
resignation Rook F6 even is a nice Mo
even yeah there's a lot of things you
could do here you could even play you
could double the Rooks you could you
play G3 you can check the weather you
know you can you know do so many things
here but um but uh but Nemo has done a
very reasonable job at various points in
all our games of turtling when it seems
like she's just going to go down
immediately and it just playing a little
bit faster a little bit more precise
earlier you avoid some of these
situations cuz more a would go down oh
he blundered a he blundered a rook
that's exactly what I said was the old
thing oh she's got a move though she's
got Queen C1 Queen C1 just give a few
checks Queen takes C6 this is insane
Queen E3 oh you had to block that check
Queen takes F4 sh dropping
everything wow no way Nemo I I I said
right at that moment that again Nemo's
been defending pretty well when she's in
time scrambles she just has to be a
little faster and she got she got the
win she desperately needed that was the
only way to blunder it was to put a rook
on F3 shes forgetting that the G2 Pawn
was spinned he's got really nervous in
time pressure and Nemo is one game away
from forcing fordon what is this and the
look on shas's face is like really
really this this actually happen cuz he
knows he could have he could have forced
a draw in so many different ways and he
he he did not do the professional thing
that zi did in the last match right take
the repetition it was in the offing
there were so many opportunities there
with the heavy piece on the board he was
looking for mate he was looking for
something you know stylish and he got
punished it's like in basketball where
you know the player can't decide if he
wants to dunk it or make a leg up he
ends up doing something weird and
missing that's kind of what happened I
think shus just couldn't decide on the
on the way that he wanted to handle it
but right now we have another R Lopez
Nemo sacking a couple of Pawns in the
center but trying to eliminate Black's
dark Square Bishop hold on their T
Knight G5 Knight G5 and you cannot play
King takes H6 because Knight takes F7
man nerves of steal for sh has to play
King G7 here okay Knight takes D4 I
don't dangerous some Knight F5 Concepts
after Queen G4 right yeah you're dra
look at the clock again Nemos it's 30
seconds to a minute not the time to
think this is this is bullet Gotta Go
Gotta Go Gotta Go Queen G4 got to move
Nemo's
Frozen yeah
and yeah she's 15 seconds this is uh
this is not ideal it's not an ideal
circumstance I would go Knight df5 and
and queen D4 but okay Knight G4 instead
H5 just chasing right away and the
initiative is over if he plays
H5 it's still messy though I could see
her throwing in Knight F5 check or
something like that and queen D4 yeah
the Knight retrea H2 I don't love
although you do have these white Bishop
still pointing towards the king side but
you've just
given shus a nasty time advantage and
that's going to be probably the biggest
problem with her her position I'm going
to repeat what I said in the last and
this is obviously a lot less one-sided
than the previous game but the only way
this game turns around is if sh blunders
a piece in one move yeah and this Knight
is going to try and hop around maybe get
to
E3 uh but something has got to give
there's going to be some D4 breakthrough
and here it's happening right now and
queen trade just go D3 C4 and chill
yeah and again take a draw take on D2
take on D2 play Knight E4 um you do not
need to win this game sh I know I know
you want to you know just look good
while you're doing it but just win the
finish the
match professional he's doing a lot
better in this game of converting he's
in control and he's going to take this
match Rook E1 and Bishop C2 and what a
recovery psychologically Kasa for for
for the young player to to execute on
this game after losing such a painful
one that's not easy to do no especially
when your next game is is is a one plus
one so uh it's not like you getting you
know was really think and process
through it early on you just got to read
and react and he did that really well we
see him there uh he wants to smile but
he knows what happened in the previous
match and or the previous game and uh he
does take out Nemo 4 to2 that was a fun
one that was a great match and we had
two great matches Lev Rosman with his
second Clean Sweep of the day he wins
4-0 shras rebounds off of his lost to zi
and defeats Nemo with a score of 4-2
unfortunately Nemo is still winless but
the good news for her is that there are
two matches left to be played let's take
a look at our group b cross table leevy
Rosman in clear first he hasn't dropped
a single Half Point that's really all
you need to know about Levy's
performance today Casa yeah I mean
dominating games really nice attacking
uh positions and pling to style whether
objectively it's always the the right
thing or not we could question but
practically he's he's getting his
positions and sometimes when you get in
your bag good things
happen and what's more interesting is
remember folks only one player from each
group qualifies what does that mean that
means if Levy wins his next match uh
then the group is over Levy will have
scored three wins uh and he will already
advance to uh to the next stage even
without playing the force match so the
Intrigue is at a peak because shus Royal
has to beat levy on demand in the next
match to keep this group going we will
give the players a breather folks you
are watching the I am not a GMC we will
see if Levy can take this group with a
victory in the next group the next round
on the other side of this short break
stay
[Music]
tuned October is is here and so are some
familiar faces Martin learned chess just
to play with his kids and occasionally
the family dog a workoholic Philip hopes
chess will help him relax before he
works his fingers to the Bone Lura the
librarian loves to learn and has
recently developed a penchant for spell
chess an aspiring influencer and
self-proclaimed meme Queen Isa can be a
monster on the board when she puts her
mind to it Paul morphy's undying genius
lives on to this day through his mortal
Opera game just your average old Bots
nothing else to see here play them all
on chess.com
I really love watching games by top
female players and studying their games
from the past and I think that's like
one really cool thing that the chess
Community could do more of I know my
friend Luciana is publishing a chess of
full Horus on some of the great games by
the early World Champ iamps veric
rudenko and you can learn just as much
from these games as you can learn from
any game and yet it does provide
inspiration and like adds like depth to
our chess culture so I about 10 years
ago I published a book called play like
a girl with like tactics by female chess
players and I'm actually redoing that
book and it's so much fun to just like
kind of like dig in and see some of the
most important tactical themes in chess
decoy in between move
pins double attacks um and to look for
like some of the the best examples by
top female players so when you hear all
these discussions about women in chess
it's great sometimes I'm just like wow
you should just like go study some muu
[Music]
games
mus
[Music]
he
oh
[Music]
B
it's all up to I am shus Royal he must
defeat Levy Rosman uh in order to force
a group b tie breaks strus uh he
achieved his first Grand Master Norm at
age 13 that is the youngest Norm
achiever in English History he took
third place at the 2020 youth speed
chest championship and yes 2020 that was
3 years ago so at his young age Kasa he
already has a strong Blitz pedigree and
he came back from his first match loss
to Kristoff with an impressive victory
over Nemo now he has to beat the
Unstoppable Ley Rosman yeah and he's
gonna have to play his best chess yet in
this format to really even challenge
Levy here because Levy's been playing
fantastically but Royal's a great player
um he's he's someone who you know as
we've seen from the games thus far in
the event really could play tactically
can play positionally I was especially
impressed with the game he played
against Nemo where he had the queen side
pressure with the Rook on A5 and then he
snapped on H6 and had those two knights
and the queen converging to to get
deliver mate so really impressive young
man and uh yeah this is it we're going
to figure out if he can stop the
unstoppable train so far Levy he hasn't
just not given up a point he hasn't
given up a single half point he defeated
both of his first opponents with a clean
sweep of 40 the opening choices the
Tactical Vision the way the levy has
fought for the initiative has been so
impressive and shz will have to step up
his game Let's uh let's not mince words
Kasa you know you have to eliminate the
Tactical blunders you have to manage
your time well the most important
important thing for Shas is not to go
down two z uh in the 5 plus one portion
I think that's the key to the kingdom
yeah and I I said it before these match
matchups got started that if Levy made
the face he had on his his picture in
the matchups that it probably wouldn't
be a good day and he hasn't made that
face yet he's been calm cool and
collected um and it served him very well
now everything is predicated on the
result of uh Royal against Rosman if
shre manages to defeat Levy
uh Kristoff also needs to defeat Nemo in
order to tie then we will have a
three-way tie with three players having
won two matches and lost one but we'll
cross that bridge if we get there first
and foremost Kristoff he needs uh Shas
to defeat Levy and for that to happen
Shas will have to play his best match of
the day obviously we will be focused on
the Royal Rosman match man that's a lot
of
RS like it's so hard to say all these
names without stuttering
yeah say try to say that 10 times fast
Rosman Rosman selki Nemo say that 10
times I'm good but uh but yeah uh I'm
really curious what Royal's strategy is
going to be because um I mean he
probably hasn't had the chance to
actually look at any other games
obviously given that he's been playing
the same time but I'm wondering how he's
going to play against the potential D4
trompowsky stuff or against a kocan and
here we go we're off we do have a
trompowsky and so this is the first
question is he comfortable with the Del
Knight C6 I have seen this once or twice
before yeah and Fabby had a really nice
game where he played this you typically
take with the G Pawn here no with the E
Pawn interesting um how do you feel
about this Knight on C6 it's an
interesting line I believe that Fabby
played it against n abasa to win a
critical tiebreaker game at the World
Cup it's an interesting line but you
have to know the resulting structures
now the D5 Pawn is a serious liability
and and this Pawn structure with the
pawns on the dark squares is one that
Levy is extremely comfortable with he
had the structure against Nemo and the
plan for white is typically to quickly
push C4 and start expanding on the queen
side Queen B3 definitely a more
comfortable position for white yeah and
I think a lot of it comes down to how
well can white tickle the black queen
side there are ideas of Knight A5 at
some juncture if the queen is not
controlling that square and if that n A5
is very tough to push off of that square
so so I think that's typically what
White's going to try and do put the
Rooks on C1 and D1 and slowly but surely
try to massage those queenside pawns
yeah Rook D1 Rook C1 a lot of loow
hanging fruit kind of moves for white at
the same time B7 B5 is a move you have
to be careful about that would push the
Knight away from C4 on the other hand it
would seriously weaken the C6 Square so
for sh I would probably keep the status
quo and play slower moves like Queen to
D7 maybe Rook e to d8 that kind of stuff
and I actually have a question da cuz I
feel like in a lot of these positions
I'm so I was going to say Bishop H6
because I'm so Keen to get this bishop
to assert itself and a lot of times
playing with F5 actually is a mistake
because you give white a little bit more
real estate you don't truly open up your
own Bishop so a lot of times this bishop
gets reactivated via f8 or H6 and my
question for you was would you have
thrown an H5 before going Bishop H6 cuz
I feel like in a lot of positions you
just want to invite this H4 Dynamic and
uh okay it's a different game now but
that was one thing I was curious about
yeah I've seen this bishop H6 quite a
bit the concern of course is that you're
leaving some of the dark squares on the
king side and in the center unattended
and we have a trade Levy will take back
with a G Pawn of course that does damage
White's King safety a little bit but
again you're pointing out Knight D6
that's the threat let's not forget the
A7 Pawn is hanging I think we're on the
same page Knight C8 yeah we followed the
logical process Knight C8 Rook fd1
though I still like White's position
here yeah and I think here wow okay so
very aggressively just punting on uh the
A7 pawn and saying KN D6 is not the end
of the world um I don't mind it simply
because if you get to play Bishop D5 and
exchange these light squared Bishops
under the right Circumstance the a
Pawn's not going to be super relevant if
the king is you know relatively exposed
so um I do think this is a dynamic
choice and uh you know I I'm can stand
behind it for sure Queen D7 Queen G4
that kind of stuff can cause some
discomfort but Levy meeting fire with
fire I was going to say my preference
would be to grab A7 but that's also
because I didn't have uh breakfast or
lunch today so you know it's like when
you go into a grocery you know never go
into a grocery store before eating yeah
and basically what Levy did is by
pushing e4s he kind of compromised the
security of his queen of his Center his
uh his Pawns in the center Central
Central structure and so there's a
little bit of risk involved in that that
you might be overextending cting some
weaknesses and he's going to try to hold
it all together that being said black
kind of did the same Royal kind of did
the same with his B5 move making the C6
Pawn just a permanent weakness and so
both sides have targets to play against
and uh and T and A lot of time actually
more so than we've seen in previous
games before we get to this like late
middle game almost end game point so
they also have the chance to play a lot
of accur moves with because given they
have a lot of time yeah this has been a
pretty balanced high level game felt
like Lev's been in the driver seat since
the opening but treas has uh quitted
himself really well now he has to count
with the threat of D5 and threat it's
more of a positional threat than
anything so D5 CD Ed there might be Rook
to C8 so I don't think it works just yet
I think Levy should make a patient move
maybe even H4 to create a Lo Square for
his King on H2 uh you know for a rainy
day
yeah whenever I have a light squared
Bishop I definitely want my king
protected on the same diagonals that
Bishop so I'm always Keen for Bishop F3
King G2 uh allaha kramnick he did that
in so many catalon but um all right
different game uh Queen D6 what was the
idea with that move I guess hitting it
the F6 Pawn but does leave your king a
little bit Exposed on the back here yeah
and Rook A1 causing Levy to elicit a
little bit of discomfort because if you
trade on A1 you have to block with your
bishop and queen from A1 can slide over
to D1 and deliver a check on G4 so Levy
has to be very careful here both sides
kind of walking a tight RPP Bishop F1
played of course black and guard the F6
Pawn with King G7 but don't sleep on
Queen to D7 which hits both the rook and
the Knight at once yeah it's a weird
position because honestly you see this
queen and it's like wow it's very active
but I this rook and rook and Knight on
E8 and E7 respectively don't really have
great squares and they're there doesn't
feel particularly secure and so um it's
a it's a tough position to play well I
must say and queen D1 is on the board
hitting the Rook Rook slides up to C3
preparing to block a check on G4 with
Rook G3 very heads up play by Levy and
anything can happen here first blunder
is going to decide the game yeah no
question and again they still both have
quite a lot of time and so I I I still
think um it's kind of B balanced here um
but uh after Queen G4 check you can also
block with a bishop and then it's an
immediate repetition so I I doubt that
Levy would go for that given uh his play
playing style but that's also an
option yeah critical moment has been
reached King G7 Queen G4 Queen
E6 so many options and the clock
starting to tick down Knight F5 I was
going to point this out earlier the idea
is e takes F5 rookie one and black
develops a devast in attack on the first
ring but Levy can take on C6 here and
hit the Rook yeah and the justification
for Knight F5 would actually be harder
to identify there because um I think
Knight G7 isn't actually an only move
now basically you have to deal with this
oh Queen A8 Queen A8 yeah and you pick
up KN you take on F5 and then you can
bring the queen back to G2 and protect
F1 so don't go Queen C8 because then you
won't be able to defend the bishop but
this is what Levy has been seeing this
whole match and this whole tournament
you can't blunder in one move against
him and treas forgot the queen can drop
back it's a full extra piece like I said
c of the first blunder in these types of
positions it's always the one that
decides the game Levy needs to do a
little bit more work here to untangle
his pieces but this one should be over
yeah F5 is such a like just smart way to
play a lot of people would just
consolidate without maintaining their
aggression and Lev is not doing that I
was actually going to say there are
scenarios where if this B Pawn comes off
the board black could have entertained
some drawing chances just cuz there's a
wrong color Corner as far as the bishop
is concerned and the H Pawn and you know
there could be some type of blockade
with that kind of Tepe of Pawns that
were there before but he's not allowing
black to set up any type of bind he's
maintaining this aggression even while
being pinned which I think is impressive
that Levy's keeping that pressure on and
now he's just got to look forward to
eventually getting an H4 but be careful
if you go for a quick Rook G4
takes F1 Che and that would have turned
the tables and even here if you play
Rook G first of all doesn't make much
sense but yeah Queen F3 is a great way
to play and queen C1 trus has to keep
himself pinned to that Bishop that's his
only chance to keep white at Bay but now
H4 white is going to start chipping away
at the security of Black's King and once
one of the dominoes Falls I think the
rest are going to fall very quickly I
would play Queen C4 right now gain a
Tempo by threatening a queen trade and
then push H4 at the first available
opportunity and he does just that and
again a lot of people would just play
King G2 and get out of the pin and
Levy's been doing a great job
identifying real danger and fake danger
and he's been making them when there's
not any real danger he goes on for goes
onward plays what he wants to play and
you know that's why you know Black's the
one that's actually having to make the
defensive moves now it's almost like
he's mastered the concept of danger
levels
so yeah so again I personally would go
King G2 but Levy style tells me that
yeah he might just go B4 or do something
really active like Rook e 3 because he's
saying I'm secure why do I have to
defend okay he did go for King G2 now
yeah I mean he can take his time even
God forbid if the Queens get traded and
he loses the B3 Pawn which he shouldn't
it it should still be winning biggest
thing is to make sure you're keeping
tabs on the F2 pawn and the bishop on F1
and Rook D3 is a great move cuz Rook d
mate you have to trade and once the
Rooks get off the board then it's really
easy yeah and now it's going to be a lot
of checks and this king is going to
basically hop scotch on the light
squares but not for long um I'm a little
surprised he didn't Dart in with the
Rook but um doesn't change that much but
I I The Rook D7 would have been
automatic and it would have been check
check check into Checkmate so Rook D
love the insertion here because you're
giving black another move um there's no
effective check here very weird move
Queen C7 now Rook D7 does run into Queen
E4 check he's down to 24 seconds can
Levy keep his composure for a couple
more moves I think he can Queen E7
preparing a devastating check on E8 and
if the king slides over to the file why
do oh Queen E4 to no this is winning
this was a great move E8 makes a lot a
lot of sense I was highlighting E4 but
they're both extremely effective um and
uh yeah now Rook
H that should be all she wrote what a
move if you had taken Queen on B1 would
have been hanging yeah Rook H takes H
the queen B1 would have been hanging now
Queen E7 is mate in two folks Queen E7
if all right Queen E7 Bishop C4 was mate
that that would have been a pretty one
can I show that one really quickly um
the game end uh okay the game's
basically I just want to show it just
ended but I wanted to show that if the
king oh actually we don't have time we
got to get to another game it's Levy up
one nothing and we have a Dutch we have
a Dutch on our hands is it going to be
Leningrad or a Stonewall what do you
think quick folks in chat what do you
think Stonewall or Leningrad uh well I
think oh it's going to be this B6
variation which I think is a very good
setup against what shes has chosen shes
has chosen a very quiet positional line
and again Levy playing to his strengths
I really like his opening choices
throughout throughout this day of
action yeah and this bishop on D6 is
really interesting because it's a
provocative move to not to move your
Bishop in front of your D- Pawn we do
not teach this typically but the idea is
that these Bishops now are really
pointing right at the white king side
and that's why sh is like hey back up I
don't want to see you there but A4 very
committ weakening the de the B4 Square
that's a massive Outpost for the night
black is better in my opinion just
because now all of Black's pieces are
going to make sense um although okay
there's a lot of game left and uh it's
just allowing this Knight to come to B4
is not to be preferred I'll update
people on the fact that Kristoff and
Nemo had a very even game throughout but
Nemo got herself in time pressure and
she actually flagged in a drawn endgame
so Kristoff picks up the first game he's
taking care of business so far but he
needs trus to win this match and the way
Levy is playing the guy is 90 and he's
got another good position out of the
opening here there's an asymmetry CA
between the two knights you might say oh
well black is an outpost so does white
but the Knight on B 5 is not an outpost
because it can be kicked away with a
move C6 now should black Rush the move
C6 no because that move comes comes with
a tendent drawbacks you're blocking in
your Bishop you're making some
weaknesses but the fact that black has
that move in reserve I think is really a
big asset for Levy yeah and how do you
imagine the story arc going well I can
tell you typically uh this queen or Rook
sometimes would have liked to Nestle in
on G6 or H5 and actually play against
the white king the exchange of pieces
there and the manner in which it
happened I think does favor white cuz
now white can try to Open Press onward
in the center with some combination of
D5 or C5 at the right moment and that's
basically where White's trumps are white
is better in the center and on the queen
side black typically has some prospects
attacking prospects on the king side
although C7 is hanging so you can't rush
with this queen E8 business I think you
have to step on it if you're shz and
goes C5 if you play D5 I think Lev is
preparing to meet that with E5 and if
the center dries up particularly if
black achieves a a hold on the C5 Square
white is in trouble because eventually
black is going to start gaining ground
on the other side of the board so tras
has to make sure that his Central and
queen side play remains alive Bishop A3
is a great move by the way hitting the
Knight asking black some very impolite
questions yeah basically saying are you
going to are you going to move that
Knight and then you don't have this
fantastic Outpost anymore uh if you move
the Knight C5 might actually be even
further supported
um I actually think in some
circumstances you just give up uh the
pawn to get the bishop pair and you just
press onward so I could see a scenario
where you just go Queen E7 and punt on
it we're also talking about C6 earlier
uh maybe it's a good time for that
because in previous positions where we
were worried about C6 it was kind of
based on the Knight still being on e4
and having some attack there is no real
Attack on the king side for black
anymore and so you could kind of switch
to more positional bases with C6 Queen
but it's not Levy's style and yeah he
goes back with A6 but now C5 C5 is a
very scary move because Black's Queen
side could just spontaneously collapse
and White's pieces are so well equipped
to deal with the opening of the center
shre heads up move and Levy is in huge
trouble I think this is the biggest
trouble that he's been in so far in
these first 10 games how will he react
to this situation if you react
improperly you might end up in a lost
end game you end up with a bunch of weak
pawns on the queen side and if you play
D5 and try to keep the queen side close
well obviously white has C6 discovering
an attack on the rook and the bishop
yeah and I I linked this the the tail of
two sides here look at all of White's
pieces all kind of converging in the
same area based up oriented around that
break Black's pieces are a bit more
scattered it really tells a very a very
good story about who's better and why
and the remaining pawns here even though
black is the bishop pair this C7 pawn
and the E6 Pawn in particular are
massive massive weaknesses so
essentially Levy has to seek activity
now and he's good at that so I think he
something like Rook d8 trying to uh
trying to get in on the on the defile
maybe some eventual Rook D2 um I think
you have to punt on the C7 pawn and
pursue Activity one thing that's nice
about the pawn A5 is it is holding up uh
the pawn Duo here and so yeah Rook Rook
FDA it's a really good decision from
Levy and it's perfectly fits his style
yeah what you never want to do in these
situations is try to cling uh to your
extremely weak pawns because you're
going to do a lot of damage But the
irony of the way this game has
progressed is that black was the one
with the better Outpost White had the
shorter end of the stick and yet the
Knight on B4 is gone it's dead and the
Knight is still sitting on B5 so Shas he
did such a good job of chasing webby's
Knight away with his Bishop with his
dark squar Bishop uh which ultimately
was traded for that Knight now he's got
to prosecute the defile tension
correctly cuz if you take on d8 Lev will
recapture with the Rook he could
infiltrate uh the second rank so a lot
of accuracy remains uh to be displayed
by shr if he wants to take this game and
the real question uh for for shus here
and I think it's a really tough question
is how do you ultimately solve your back
rank problem because essentially if you
play a move like G3 you basically open
up this light squared bishop and you
give it more influence if you play F3
then the E3 Pawn will be sensitive there
might be some tricks along the dark
squares and so so neither kind of Pawn
push is particularly desirable and uh
it's for that reason that maybe move
like King F1 just kind of suly inching
it towards the the king side that way
might make sense but not an easy
decision to make so that's really the
one issue for white here is solving the
back rank problem and if you don't solve
it correctly Levy's going to jump yeah
and I mean listen if white misplays this
black could get so much activity that
the game could turn around completely
and Levy knows this I think that's why
he's not so concerned Bishop D5 right
now and if white plays Bishop C4 that's
exactly how you blunder mate in these
types of situations you forget that
white Bishop holds the D1 Square
instructive for newer players always
make lft that is a Checkmate there on D1
so basically that is that is the problem
and so Bishop D5 hasn't played and uh
here we are we do have Bishop D1 and
yeah like it's a passive move uh again
black is a pawn down but has excellent
Bishops and white still is a back rank
problem Bishop takes G2 recovering the
pawn but I'm worried about Levy's eight
Pawn Rook A7 and I guess you could
defend it from d8 with the bishop still
feels like Shas has the Practical
Advantage but Levy could also play for a
win and go Rook D2 and Bishop H4 trying
to go for the complete Pawn in Balance I
wouldn't do that though White's pawns
are too far Advanced but now Knight D4
very unpleasant Knight D4 Knight D4
hitting E6 then Rook A8 is also a threat
and it's so funny basically the that
extra Pawn that you know basically Levy
cashed in one of his Bishops for um it
actually wasn't worth it the bishop pair
was actually way more valuable than that
pawn turned out to be and you also
solved White's back rank problem at the
same time so that's basically why the
game is turned Knight E5 Knight C4 I was
literally about to say Knight E5 Knight
C4 is game over because Rook d8 Knight
takes B6 defends the bishop if TR finds
Knight E5 he will deal Levy his first
loss in 10 games and he does he spots it
and this match is going to be tied whoa
we've got some Intrigue here and again
whenever this King moves let's just say
King F6 Knight C4 and that is forking
the two pieces that is that's it and so
yeah Levy is uh Levy is thinking here
but the reality is surely setting in and
oh here we go we do have Knight C4 and a
piece P sack that doesn't really Garner
much the A5 Pawn will ultimately be
collected as well white will have more
than enough to win and Rook B8 is a is
an interesting decision kind of classy
saying you know what I'm going to keep
the pawn Duo because sometimes it is
hard to to Usher the a pawn down board
but it's not over just yet black hit
some counterplay here there's H4 H3
energy happening um sometimes H4 and G3
might also be something so still a few
more precise moves need to be played
from trus if Levy's pawns are on H4 and
F4 this would be a game but King G3 very
very sloppy move by shus allowing F4 or
H5 and you know you have to involve your
rook and Knight in the defensive effort
against King H4 King H King King H
threat ideas has spot it wait a second
what ISR is doing yeah and now now le is
all of a sudden attacking a down King F1
you have to evacuate in immedately F3
King E1 threat threaten M again and then
and then you can get your Rook from the
back and start to really harass one of
these Pawns F3 and then you go after the
F Pawn Rook C1 Rook F1 and King E3 and I
think king4 King F4 yeah King four
because we're in time trouble I I can't
I'm not going to go back but there was
an opportunity to get played Rook C2 and
not allow the king out of the box here
still but Kasa still rookie 2 is coming
on the next move if Levy can pick up the
F Pawn his King is actually the safest
piece on the board for now although she
could get checkmated in some weird bucks
I would go rookie where does this Knight
where does this Knight go to deliver the
body blows is it to G6 knight5 Knight E5
right yeah that it looks it looks like
it's almost there to deliver some damage
I think there's tactics Knight E5 Rook
takes F2 and then Knight takes G4 and
you can't recapture
mate oh my gosh that's dirty and after H
takes G4 not taking the pawn but Rook h8
is mate so that is why 95 is a move but
with 40 seconds he has SP sped it Levy
just got to go quickly though Rook takes
F2 Knight G4 Rook G2 but then King takes
F3 is going to win great Poise by stres
if he spots Knight takes G4 and he does
and he does Rook G2 King takes F3 is
gonna end it and again that would
actually give up the night but then the
the connected passers here uh would mean
that it's a winning end game so
sometimes you basically jettison
material to get to another kind of
transition to conversion that you know
you can actually win God Levy just won't
die this game Knight E3 Rook B1 take is
Checkmate though right F2 Knight F3 Rook
G3 is Checkmate and that's what's
beautiful wow there were some twists and
turns there but Royal got the win he
needed um I am impressed by Levy's
tenacity even in positions that are
almost gone he's finding different ways
and uh yeah we're in this exciting match
the first Point Half Point the levy has
given away his score is now a miserable
nine wins and one
loss but this match is on it's 1-1 uh
the three-minute portion I think is
Levy's strongest this is where uh you
know in previous interviews he said that
his his bread is buttered but remember
the format was completely different uh
in previous SEC matches here the margins
are so much thinner and Levy's got a
position he's got to be really happy
about it's an unorthodox uh Sicilian
line where he's basically played an
early 93 Bishop B5 but he's also manag
to open the Bel line and it's one of
these misss where this bishop on D3
normally we say do not put your Bishop I
already said it in an earlier game don't
put your Bishop in front of the D Pawn
Levy's broken this rule a second time
and it probably won't stay there forever
it'll probably drop back to C2 at some
point I was actually I thought he was
going to go Rook E1 and Bishop F1 um but
essentially here the reason you don't
normally put the bishop in front of the
D Pawn is cuz you're just gumming up the
works in this uh for your Central
Central Pawn and for your Bishop
developing to a normal Square so Black's
doing okay here and Kristoff has just
won another game he is up two and a half
half he's taking care of business that's
been a pretty one-sided match so
Kristoff is one game away uh from taking
care of his end of the bargain of course
now all eyes are on the Rosman Shas
match if Shas wins this match we might
have we likely will have a threeway tie
uh and a tiebreaker to boot and I love
the way that he's meeting Levy's opening
h H4 going after White's Knight chasing
it back to F1 yeah chisling away at that
King side chisel
away
but yeah and now basically this Pawn I I
affectionately call a thorn Pawn it's
just a thorn in white side if a queen
ever lands on G2 it's obviously mate but
it also gives white back rank problems
pretty much indefinitely because um you
know deep into the end game and so
that's really the the huge issue with
this oppent H3 um and I think shres has
a really comfortable position here Levy
has to mix things up uh very very
quickly to kind of saave off uh this
this kind of control that black is
establishing in the center and the queen
side yeah E5 Mak has to be automatic CU
if you had allowed black to play E5
white would have been permanently buried
under a pile of rubble on the king side
you wouldn't be able to get your knight
out of F1 now at least you have a little
bit more Breathing Room the Bishop from
C1 can come out to A3 the queen can
slide up to E2 although watch out for
the move Rook H5 uh attacking the pawn
laterally maybe it could be met with G4
though yeah I'm I need my Bishop on C8
to just assert itself on this diagonal
so uh whether it's some combination of
Bishop D7 and Bishop C6 or B5 and Bishop
B7 would expedite that process I need to
see that and Levy meanwhile has to shake
the tree in another way he's going to
try and land the bishop on D6 maybe play
Bishop E4 to contest that Bishop that
might come to B7 and ultimately white
has a you know a little bit of a
coordination Advantage thus far a slight
lead in development here um with the
Rooks already being connected but if
black is able to get the same done
shortly um that can change C4 is a very
Levy kind of move he played that move
fully intuitively his time management
has been excellent yeah he could have
spent 30 seconds calculating this move
but he knows that from a peace placement
standpoint this is probably going to
work out for him and black just does
have a good place to put his King can't
Castle Queen side that side of the board
is wide open if you go King side then
your H Pawn is left unattended and white
could pick that pawn up with potentially
a move like Knight G5 uh or Knight D2
Knight E4 Knight F6 so your king isn't
as safe as it looked Rook bd1 lot of
improving moves white could play here
yeah I think white is has massive
attacking chances now um basically the
the benefit of this C4 move is that now
this D Pawn that recaptured the C Pawn
now gives the Knight some life we talked
about this 9 F1 having literally no
scope a little while ago and now it has
amazing Dynamic potential now Tak some
time but uh White's pieces are starting
to make a lot of sense there's a lot of
concentration here Bishop B4 Queen E8
apparently there was something better
but I don't know what it was Knight E3
also would be a good way to get the
Knight into the action but Knight G5
heads up move by Levy realizing that the
bishop on B7 disallows precludes the
move Knight que G Queen G
attack this is perfect this is this is
this is Levy style go for that
initiative there Queen G4 there Queen
takes H3 there's Queen H7 business there
is trouble on the hline got if shz can
get out of this and obviously this is a
very double-sided position F5 would pick
up the bishop but it's not about the
bishop right now it's about Black's King
that is the deciding factor can tras
keep that King safe the check on H7
after Queen takes H3 is going to be not
check bank Kaa but it's going to be
really
really devastating with a sacrifice on
G6 opening up the center I'm not sure
how to defend this um I think there just
a lot there's also Bishop takes G6 might
also be an idea and Rook takes C6 and
there are just too many attacking
Concepts here I think Bishop F6 is a
good practical Choice you're trying to
knock out that Knight but I don't think
the attack slows down I mean I would be
seriously considering the sack on G6
even right now um although maybe there's
Bishop takes G5 so lot to calculate here
for Levy as he drops down uh close to
shrz has clock both sides under a minute
here we go rookie six rookie six he's
going for it and oh my
gosh there's Knight E5 there was Knight
E5 G4 now I think white has the move
Knight E4 dropping back and opening up a
pathway with the G6 Pawn too many
attacking threats Queen takes G6 and
Knight F6 Kasa yeah it's it's
devastating and basically in that line
there's a pin that Bishop on G7 is
pinned to the King on G8 so Queen takes
G7 is automatic here Queen though I
think still Knight
F6 King f8 and I think Levy is trying to
puzzle that out I don't see a move maybe
oh just keeping the tension but Levy
might force a draw here if he doesn't
see anything he'll force a draw and I
think he will yeah the clock is getting
just under 10 m 10 seconds excuse me I
almost said minutes there oh he go for
the levy losing his mind there now he's
worse it's not over he's got lot of
Pawns but the attack is over the problem
is this H3 Pawn is a massive issue and
we spoke about it earlier that this this
Pawn just gives black white permanent
back rank problems if you play Knight F3
here you get rid of those Knights that
King is in jail it is ined indefinitely
and so now oh rookie eight rookie rookie
eight what on Earth is happening rookie
a was game over yeah and it's the
product of pre moves and not a lot of
time
Lev was just trying not to flag B4 here
shakes the tree excellently if C takes
B4 Rook C4 wins material it's actually a
good thing that Levy is not going to
know about rookie eight because if he
recovering from the knowledge that you
actually could have won this game at the
last second is almost impossible Levy is
down this is insane yeah and it's funny
cuz he's been in control for most of it
but you know again tricks are for kids
shus is is showing us right now uh he
has come to play and the now the G now
it's gotten serious cuz Levy has got to
recover 3 plus one this is his best
segment he's got to respond right and
he's going for he invited he invited
some iteration of the Owens with be an
early B6 allowing E4 but shus did not go
for and is going and staying in uh
Queen's gam uh Queen's Indian Land
essentially Queen's Pawn structure land
with
white wow I'm still in total recovery
mode after that that previous game
rookie 8 is going to be in Levy's
nightmares today yeah I mean this is a
pretty reasonable position a little bit
different from the previous instance of
this opening shz though showed a lot of
knowledge of how to prosecute the
initiative on the queen side and he
could push D5 right now and cause some
trouble in the center it's a big time
move because you can't play E5 and close
which is typical because the pawn is
just hanging uh currently and if you you
know do if you play D6 then he's
actually going to take on E6 and the
structure will just be a little bit soft
on the queen side there's ideas of
Knight G5 so Lev's trying to keep the
tension but you can see here white is
first in the middle and yeah now there's
some squares that can be massaged Rook
D7 is also a concept as well so white
definitely has the edge here I think
Levy should be okay with the draw here
he given his superiority in bullet the
goal right now should be to avoid a loss
but again this is completely going in
trees's Direction just look at that
Knight you called it Rook 8 d8 runs into
a fork on
C6 I and the Knight on A6 is misplaced
this is this is very problematic for
Levy once again yeah and I think he
basically just needs to try and trade
pieces and and and just sort of get out
unscathed Queen of6 is actually pretty
clever the idea is that if white takes
on e4 there's a threat on F6 uh and it's
not that easy to Parry without going
passive again which is not what you want
when you get your Rook to a beautiful
open file so really Choice um you don't
really want to take you could go F3 to
hit the hit back on against the bishop
there and then try to double the Rooks
and uh a lot of blacks play in this
mission is based upon fighting over the
E4 Square so that's basically what
Levy's trying to do and shus has got to
try and fight back against that but a
lot of what Lev is going to be doing is
based upon this E4 square and so some
capture on G2 and Knight C5 getting that
Knight D4 makes a lot of sense to me for
sure and F4 committ decision by sh but
he had to find some way to stabilize the
KN but now B4 and now is a problem
because actually B take C5 is an
excellent move basically getting instead
of taking this bishop you you do not
allow the Knight to get to that Outpost
and this Knight is dominant and
unassailable now maybe playing C6 was
not ideal maybe Rook D7 instead just
invading Bishop takes C6 but yeah Bishop
takes C6 that Queen is undefended you
could take the pawn and Levy these are
the tactics that were automatic in the
previous two matches and he spots it oh
what a big blunder by shess now he's
just a healthy Pawn down the funny thing
is this night is so good this night is
so good da that I'm actually not that
concerned if white just doubles I think
it's going to be really come down to the
control of the defile because this
Knight is a awesome attacking piece yeah
the problem isn't even the fact that he
gave up a pawn it's how is he going to
react psychologically to this now I
would put the bishop on e4 yes there is
a fork on D7 but if you can eliminate
that Knight at all costs I think black
would be happy and good heads up
decision by Levy sacking The Exchange
and uh yeah we've we've all heard of the
sacking the rook and here it makes it
makes perfect sense basically this king
is Airy we can put it like that very
airy there are very weak light squares
all around um I affectionately call
these types of structures swiss cheese
um and so this exchange is not really
one you want to pursue because this
Bishop is going to be pretty nicely
entrenched indeed and we've got a lot of
intrigue on our other board looks like
Kristoff is about to take his match yeah
no he's taking care of business in the
first game of the bullet time let's just
go to the bird's ey view for a second
and watch from a distance as christop he
had the move Rook G2 there winning
Black's Bishop all he needs is a draw
he's up three to one there's no way he's
losing this with white and this uh you
can even sack The Exchange down go King
B7 which he does which he does it's over
yeah that's that's a
w yeah as Mr KY says that is a WAP
Kristoff he takes care of his he just
making sure that black doesn't end up
with any pieces or
pawns and now what you do you just you
just move the bishop to a square where
it can't even begin to stal made or
anything but yeah that wasn't
necessary okay back we go to the levy
match all eyes on our Marquee matchup
all right so the defile now is totally
in White's control and again we said
that pawn might not actually match and
it was about the defile Levy needed to
challenge earlier now it's pretty firmly
in White's grasp and is there a queen
takes A7 here oh my gosh Queen takes A7
sick Rook takes this Knight is
controlling s what a move proba it might
not be the fancy it might not be the
best way objectively it's just beautiful
and yeah it gets the brilliant move
moniker there we go the double exclam it
looks so aesthetically pleasing again
after Rook takes A7 Knight Rook takes
D well but this Knight is just so
dominant that I don't yeah Queen f is a
move but anyway we got to get back to
the game because they're both low on
time and Levy does not go for it he does
not see the queen f8 stuff that you saw
da and so after Queen takes D7 it's
going to be tough sledding because with
the Queens on the board there's still
massive attacking chances do you have
time for a move like H6 giving yourself
you have to Great move by Levy H5 H4
have to create weaknesses in wh's oh but
Rook D6 White's just striking first and
the white King has the F2 Square so the
back rank check with the black Rook is
not going to be dangerous this one looks
like it's a almost a wrap and oh my gosh
this will be three to one if shz can
take this home Rook takes E6 what is he
waiting for two seconds Levy has two
seconds as well but Rook E6 Queen d8
might Force the queen trade that might
be what's giving shre some plus Rook H6
Rook H6 Knight F7 no way what a call
Casa Rook H6 will he find it you can't
you can't take with the oh he didn't
play no he missed it and now Levy back
in the game still winning this seven n
G5 yeah he's he's just going to trade
and go for The Rook end game no why
didn't he take on e4 King E3 King E3
over King E3 no heed upon why didn't he
trade and go to the clearly winning Rook
end game it's a game now and look at
tr's clock he's blundering all of his
pawns back oh no it's it's no longer my
god king F7 I Rook takes C5 winning
chances again he's going to put the
Knight on G5 and just start to tickle
and harass and this is going to be a
tough hold for Levy Levy could have kept
his seon alive and if that seon were set
in motion he would have had winning
chances now objectively this is a draw
white should not have any ways to make
progress but how easy is it Kasa to
stumble into a fork to blunder a pawn 2
seconds Knight D6 and knight4 and King
E3 Rook A3 can he get to that
pun this is a very peculiar position
but draw by rep a draw by
repetition oh oh oh my I can't believe
just witnessed oh my goodness oh my
goodness was not going to go into the
into the players Memoirs of you know
their best smile says it all Rook H6 man
he he played Queen takes A7 he could
have found Rook H6 check that would have
totally turned things but we got no time
for that we are into one plus one folks
in game five of this this match here and
shus Royal has to win this one to get us
into tie break scenarios and so Levy now
is going to we're going to figure out
what is the bullet situation and the
moves are coming hot and heavy yeah and
let's not overstate the case yeah sh
could have won this but he's still up a
point so Levy still has a monster
comeback he needs to make in the bullet
a loss gives Shas Roy the match folks so
if Shas wins one of these two bullet
games he wins the match and he after D5
I think he's already majorly in the
driver seat this is disaster out of the
opening for
Levy and yeah like look at these Rooks
are not connected the black Rooks are
that pretty much tells the story here
Levy is he's let the nerves get the
better of him here take it and take it
yeah every Everything Must Go sale and
the problem is the resulting endgame
black is just way too active Rook takes
G2
Knight takes C5 I mean anytime you have
an end game like this you've got and
you've got two knights for Levy so maybe
Knight B5 go for Rook D1 just Rook G5 oh
Rook G5 would have won a knight now Rook
D1 don't get mated don't get mated Rook
D7 oh my gosh that's so easy to miss but
a great move by sh trading off the night
he should win this this is completely
winning end game with his Pawn majority
there on the king side I think they're
playing a little bit too fast da you
said this before in SEC match that you
know you don't have it's the one second
increment is there you do not have to
play bullet right now very concerned
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa there's a four
BR Bishop back bring that Bish back to
D7 oh but H5 and Rook G1 and Levy H4
attack the Knight now you're lying way
too much counterplay it's it's just too
fast you do not have to play this quite
this fast right now but it still should
be winning for black with his two
passers I mean Levy's got the Knight
which is a very poor piece at stopping
pass pawns but look at black The Rook on
F7 is keeping black king at Bay Levy's
got the best chances to hold he's had
all game long no question about it and
he's got the time Advantage which makes
you feel even better about having the
Knight because we know how tricky
Knights are c4 and watch out cuz C5
threatens to win a piece Kasa and white
could win this game oh my goodness that
would be crazy um but yeah no actually
black can really make progress here the
C5 is like you're saying is just a
massive threat and you know Rook F6
check is also possibility in some
positions this is probably just a
repetition and that
favors well it's hard to say I mean
again black was so winning in this game
shrz goes for it with Bishop E6 though
C5 King
D5 and it's still oh King E5 okay okay
so he's I get Bishop in C6 he's up a
pawn he's up a pawn in The Rook Pawn end
game so he's trying to justify that
decision but this is Choice look at this
Kasa King takes s C7 C7 and he wins he's
allowed C7 but where does the king go
how do you hide walks up King B4 King A5
it just escalates up the board King B4
King A5 King B6 and then you support the
B7 Pawn oh my gosh Levy is winning and
then you're going to hide it on d8
behind the the black king you're going
to also take the pawn while you're at it
and King C8 King d8 you called it this
is insanity King d8 it's over oh way
goodness heavy wins oh my goodness I am
I dreaming Kasa did somebody slip
something in my coffee this morning oh
my goodness man this is wild and we're
back in game six they're both tied at
two and a half this is as close as it
gets we saw this against kristofh zul L
you playing the same very dubious
opening but these types of openings work
a lot better in Bo he mous he
moused oh he just gave this away and
it's just playing too fast
again both it's it's not as it's not as
quick as you think you got to just slow
down a little bit and that's basically
the downfall here oh there's a mate on
H1 TR is playing this like it's a
10-second game you can't do that you
can't do
that oh Levy you can even trade Queens
here but knowing Levy he's not going to
do it he's going to put the pressure on
and he goes Queen F5 to go Queen H3 it's
made in two it's made in two it's made
in one
and Levy takes the match what did we
just
witness we witnessed a bit of a collapse
of epic proportions and we also witness
real tenacity right Levy did not go down
in situations where frankly a lot of
other players would I mean this even
this past game with being a few pawns
down C4 C5 business happening um he he
kept putting pressure and it and it
really planked his strengths even when
he was in trouble objectively and that's
the that's what you got to do sometimes
there's no question that Levy caused
this his tenacity particularly in that
previous end game was incredible he just
pulled off a comeback winning both
bullet games to take this match and to
take Group B Levy wins all three matches
but I've got absolutely no words and I I
have words for everything I I don't have
any words to describe this chrisop zi
has to be uh has to be like I want a
conversation with tros because he won
his match he's in second place but Levy
Rosman takes the match and takes the
group Kasa yeah so pretty impressive
stuff Levy advances to the semis and we
have two players now in the semi-finals
we have Greg shahadi and Levy Rosman uh
two players that I think a lot of folks
know fairly well so pretty exciting
stuff and uh the I'm I'm curious to see
who the next two semi-finalists will be
because it's going to be a show
it is indeed and The Show Goes On folks
we will have an interview with uh the
winner with lbby Rosman uh well we're
going to ask him all about his thoughts
his heart must be beating a million
miles an hour uh but what did we just
witness you're watching the I am not a
GMC guys we will have a winner an
interview with Levy Rosman coming up on
the other side of this
break
[Music]
what
[Applause]
want my name is Ood Dawson I'm from
Chicago I'm secet Blackman my name is
herero basa Jr and what I want to share
is I love tacos tacos and chess so
[Music]
yeah with the chess program really even
chess in general like on the deck you uh
you kind of Lose Yourself you don't
really think about your case you learn
to think differently you know you
strategize more I sometimes come out uh
7:30 in the morning I probably play
until lock up you know so it makes my
day go by faster it's competitive it's a
lot of trash talk it's is it's crazy you
know like the chess players we got our
own little circle you know and all of us
play each other we talk trash about who
be who who garbage yeah I never play
that dude again he garbage I never play
but yeah it's real
competitive
looking for a new way to learn chess
meet Dr Wolf the ideal chess coach and
companion play against Dr Wolf as he
explains everything step by step points
out strategic ideas and alerts you to
your mistakes train with him and go over
your past mistakes until you master them
choose from over 35 lessons created for
all skill levels no matter your level
everyone could use a coach download
Learn chess with Dr Wolf for Android or
iOS devices
[Music]
today
oh
[Music]
mus
oh
[Music]
we are back at the I am not a GM speed
chest Championship with the winner of
Group B Levy Rosman who wins all three
matches Levy I thought someone slipped
something in my coffee I can't believe
what we just witnessed can you walk us
through uh the emotional roller coaster
of those last uh three games against
tras yeah um I I mean I got super super
tired um after like the first Blitz game
that we played uh I am not cut out to
play five plus one da as a seasoned
veteran of 3 plus Z chess I would
imagine you feel the same uh and I was
just kind of sitting here and the pieces
were like melting into one and uh I lost
that game and I thought okay well I'm
still in good form so let's make a
comeback uh I I almost went down
3-1 uh but all I knew is that three and
a half points uh is what you need to win
and I was confident that if I didn't
lose in the blitz uh then I could make a
comeback in the bullet but it was still
very very close and um you know I was
hoping for a 12 and0 run after I went
eight no but uh this will have to do so
I'm still happy with how I played but I
need a
beer yeah Levy it felt in a lot of games
that you were playing kind of an
aggressive style like where even if
objectively uh the position maybe wasn't
you know great you you were playing to
your strengths constantly was that a
decision that you made going into today
or was that something where it just when
the clock gets low you start playing
moves that feel feel good to you
no uh it definitely wasn't any I did not
prepare uh anything for today I just I
generally tend to overthink these
tournaments and competitions I remember
my match against Eric Rosen the last
time I played in this uh I am not a GM
Spees Championship I prepared for hours
stressing about and I decided today to
just kind of show up and play uh I was
very nervous to play against Kristoff
because um he's very well prepared he's
extremely solid it's almost like when I
play against ucasa it's like plays fast
positionally like very very good good
practical decision- making and I'm
always kind of like the The Temper
Tantrum throwing child who's like trying
to throw pieces around and create
tactics uh and when I got off to a win
and then another win that really built
my confidence like oh if my Nemesis is
not taking me down you know like if the
person I was like the most afraid of is
not taking me down then today's probably
going to be good but I think it's just
reverting to you know habits whether
they're good bad so low on time always
trying to create something tactical and
every time I sit there for a while and
overthink I generally do something bad
so um but that's why I'm in in this
tournament and not in any higher level
tournament
so fair enough Levy we've got a couple
chat questions before we let you uh
enjoy that well-deserved beer first
question from Pier luga how did Levy
manage his time so well today and uh to
add to that do you think that all of
your experience in title Tuesday and all
of your bullet experience do you think
that makes a direct impact on your
performance in these types of
tournaments probably like a tiny tiny
bit but you can see in some of the more
intense games that definitely not like
there I think more often than not I am
still falling into bad habits I'm uh
still getting super nervous like for no
reason
well there is a reason obviously like I
I really really want to win and I don't
want to throw away any games but um
maybe a little bit subconsciously but uh
I tried to play a little bit faster
today I think every single time that I
took way too much time I got myself into
trouble uh but I guess today I managed
to kind
of contort and circus dance my way out
of it more than uh more than I would
against like a 3100 rated player in
title
Tuesday
you did more than contort uh today you
you really you know played spectacular
chess uh and and a spectac spectacular
attacking chess I should say but Aeris
the gamer 10 wanted to know after today
do you think you're going to win the
whole tournament because the form you
showed today I mean you were
basically uh just blitzing folks with
wins um for a extended period of time
before you even caught any
adversity I don't know I don't know if
I'm going to win I I have no idea who
else qualified uh if I'm being
completely honest I I there was no
social media post about the event made
until yesterday so like I don't even
know the
field uh I probably should have looked
that up uh but I I I I know deep down
that um when I play my best uh whether
it's getting over my nerves or just
somehow not having them although it's
mostly getting over them uh I think I
can play at uh GM level um um it's just
about being consistent like weak GM you
know crappy GM like 257 GM and then like
never play chess again and you know got
invited to random European Shady Norm
tournaments and lost like 100 Fay points
but um like that type of GM not like you
know 2650 or not like Daniel neris GM
but um I don't know uh I hope that you
know in the
semis uh I uh I show up and I can
overcome whatever Rising heartbeat and
uh self-doubt that will creep in I made
it to the final of this event in the
first edition so I guess I know what it
takes but uh there's a big challenge
ahead and I think most of the people
remaining will probably get The
Grandmaster title in the future I can't
I don't know about myself so big task
ahead L you very quickly your thoughts
on facing Greg
shahade oh that's my
opponent oh wow yeah um yeah yeah uh
listen uh Greg uh Greg is a nightmare
opponent uh because uh all he does like
for eight hours a day is CrossFit and uh
openings and um I hate preparing for him
because I can't play anything stupid
because he just knows openings really
really well it's kind of like Kristoff
it's how I feel against playing against
Kristoff like I feel like if I mess
around in the opening I'm G to get
punished
um just G to show up and listen I'm
going to let the chess speak for
itself
well we're excited for the match I am
Levy Rosman congratulations on as
centilating performance today we look
forward to watching more of you in the I
am not gmcc go enjoy that
beer thank you
guys all right that's all she wrote in
group b as we look at the final
standings of group a and Group B we
still have group C and Group D yet to
play out their matches Kasa but Greg
shahadi Larry Rosman not really a
surprise that they stand at top their
group yeah look uh the CrossFit and
openings are paying off to some extent
so uh it's going to be really
interesting to see uh how Greg and Levy
fa in the semis and um look I think it's
also we're discovering that this format
this year has changed the terms and
conditions slightly where you have to
adjust quicker um you have to maybe
change up things if it's not going well
and you have to be ready to play game
after game after game quickly and then
transition to a match against a new
opponent so um those adjustments are are
are unique and interesting and um now
that once we get to the semis it'll
revert back to the traditional uh SEC
style stuff that most folks are more
used to indeed it will uh with that
today comes to an end we wanted to
remind you though of a very important
day happening 2 days from now folks
chess kid is celebrating National Chess
Day on October 14th by unlocking all
access to chesk gold for one day only
this is your chance to check out all the
features available to chess kid members
ches kid Gold members that is like
unlimited puzzles lessons videos Bots
and more if you have kids or students
looking to become the next chess prodigy
or simply develop their skills in the
game or have a little bit of fun don't
miss your opportunity to survey all the
benefits of Chess gold coming your way
two days from now October 14th don't
miss it well we hope you haven't missed
today's I am not a GM action uh you
won't have to wait long for the next
dose of craziness Kasa incredible day
very quickly your final thoughts yeah I
mean there's going to be more exciting
action tomorrow so certainly tune in to
that and um and yeah I'm I'm looking
forward to seeing it me too well the
action resumes tomorrow bright and early
mark your calendars guys we hope you've
enjoyed watching Lev Rosman tear up the
field
you have been watching the I am not a GM
SEC GM Daniel nitzki I am Kasa Corley
saying goodbye for now have a great rest
of your
[Music]
day
what Jack it
out what
[Music]
[Applause]
what
[Music]
poweroll
[Applause]
[Music]
how
n
[Music]
laah
la
[Music]
[Applause]
n
a